guys welcome guys
it's pewdiepie
how's everyone doing
hey what's going on can you hear me all
right there's supposed to be a bit of
delay in the stream
my voice should be all right
uh yeah
let me know if you can hear everything
correctly
checking
yeah there's like a
12 15 to 20 second delay so if i say
something
uh then i that means i've said it like
20 minutes earlier so
all right good
last time there's this weird patterning
uh cool
so we're gonna be here for uh about
eight hours
so you know feel free to tune in and out
it's a long time
and um
yes so what we're going to do here is uh
it's actually pretty fun what i thought
out we're going to
build
a horrifying american suburb together
and then we're going to fix it
with as little uh
sort of money as possible so to speak
uh right
and so first off why this stream is uh
happening this uh i thought uh this
might be a good opportunity to for me to
play city skylines of course to
entertain you guys
and to uh
collect some money to as i've said uh
ngos mostly in hungary helping
disadvantaged youth mostly roma
um
these will be charities uh such as
you know helping them
uh cover some expenses in higher
education
and uh having so uh like uh providing
some after-school programs for children
um
so they won't you know uh get lost so to
speak
uh i already have a good list of ngos in
mind
um uh but uh i'm going to uh i'm going
to do some more research on tests to who
will get what uh and then i'm going to
be uh of course publishing everything of
like
what
what
funds go where i myself i'm going to
kick in uh money of course
uh and on top of that if you want if you
feel like donating then uh feel free
in the meantime i'll be answering your
questions in
because this is also a q a so
uh let's get started i guess uh if you
have any questions uh i recommend asking
a super chat
um
because i will not be able to keep track
the whole live chat
right so as we get to work we already
have the first the donation uh aditya
shankar thank you for the 100 rupees
no question asked
how dare you
uh
yes and as someone said in the chat you
should join the discord
uh let's see
let me get you a link
to my discord
because it's very nice
[Music]
yes so if you want to join my discord
then here's the link
right and unfortunately i will not be
wearing cat ears uh the cat might
actually show up and uh
visit us uh later on
uh we'll see
anyway oh onsca thank you very much for
the 10 donation no question asked
only this beautiful emoji or uh
animation i guess nice
donations are except through super chats
uh if you're wondering
uh that's the easiest way because then
there you can ask questions you know you
write out your question there and i'm
going to answer it uh the live chat is
right next to my city skylines
screen i have two screens now if you can
believe that so
all right let's get started
we're gonna be here for uh
eight in the
uh for eight hours also why are gaming
at seven in the morning because i can do
it so
uh right let's get started so what do we
have here we have a
we're gonna first set up the road
network
and the idea is that this suburb is
gonna sprawl out here
uh first first just here in this uh i
suppose in this uh
area down here and we have a
uh this all leads to
the city
this way
this will not be on the map of course i
do have finite processing power but the
idea will be that
this is a suburb next to a major
settlement
which means
uh i mean it's horrible [ __ ] car
centric whatever and we're going to fix
it with the least intrusive amounts
methods possible
and so
yes meanwhile i'm just going to talk to
you guys and we're going to have a
conversation
uh
chiang kang you leave thank you for the
compliments you love your videos discord
is magnificent well discord
is what it is but we still like it i
guess
all right let's uh
i'm going to start out by dragging out
this road because why not beautification
details
etc those will come later
for now i'm just going to set up this
very
basic
uh
[Music]
settlement structure
all right so the idea is that
uh it's all like
uh it's all um
let's see
so it's all built uh built up by real
infrastructure
uh
builder ever that's only been shipped
which books in the world this world sure
uh
it's actually a good idea
let's see hmm
where should i i'm just here for now i'm
just gonna put it here do we have a lot
yes we do have a library in city
skylines
it's a public library
doesn't fit there anyway public library
i'm just going to put it here for now
let's see
there i love how city skylines handles
gradients
uh yeah it's uh very interesting okay
so it's the
so
true
allegiance
all right it's it's just copies of true
allegiance
only true legions
uh
yes
yeah
for those of you don't know true
allegiance that's actually a book
written by ben shapiro
i cover it on my channel it's disturbing
enough
uh in it ben shapiro basically advocates
for
um
for uh
oh yeah a public library basically
wouldn't approve like it should be like
you know the free market library or
something
uh
right so in the in that book ben shapiro
actually advocates for like state
terrorism among other things and uh
like people who commit terrorism against
the state because they don't they don't
like government measures they are made
to look like heroes meanwhile by the way
a large portion of the book is dedicated
against the taliban who do the same
thing but you know they're brown so uh
it's uh
it's
ben shapiro doesn't like it
anyway
so and we had we have ties online in the
chat cool i actually i never thought i
would
uh
have him in my in the midst of my fans
actually it's very nice
um
so
let's go
[ __ ] snapping
oh camille uh i got super chat from you
thank you would be great if you named
this city shapiro will or my wife is a
doctor town oh no no
um
let's see
here we go
my
wife
is a
doctor hospital
there we go
yeah like uh
we can actually
we can actually theoretically do a city
with just like only ben shapiro
references like every building is named
after some kind of
uh
dumb [ __ ] uh he did or he's he's saying
hmm
darko mesa or sure that's a slovified
hungarian name nice
do you think it's possible to have a
public transport centric suburbia i.e
people do not live in affordable housing
but more american style homes you want
to get from seattle cool
um well that's what we're going to do
actually we're going to find out if
that's possible
public transport centric suburbia
first i'm going to build out
uh the road network and everything so as
you can see here it's
actually we're gonna we're gonna do one
more road here just for good [ __ ]
measure
so it's gonna be first off this like
very heavily built out uh
sort of road infrastructure all around
and uh well
with a very very like not densely
populated uh
areas we'll see what and we'll see what
actually comes out of it
all right
yeah oh
god
uh super chats tired me too actually a
bit i'm like
uh
a bit exhausted still like what like i
didn't sleep enough but i have this this
goddamn thing it's the
it's a german thing i would say i only
saw it locally but it's very nice it's
like a very caffeinated bubbly uh iced
tea sort of thing
uh so lauren martinez hey i wanted to
ask
what do you think about electric bikes
or
electric motorcycles i think electric
bikes are fine i mean especially if you
live in uh sort of hilly territories
it's that can be a godsend
um
they didn't really pick up in in hungary
much because of course hungary is flat
so you know what can you do just like
the earth
anyway
heckland oh one of my mods how long have
you been a cia asset and how much of the
charity money is going to your handler
uh
about like uh 85 will go to my handlers
and um
yes the next the the rest the 15 i'm
going to spend on overthrowing south
american democracies in the name of the
government so yeah
i actually won't don't worry like for
those of you who might not get the
reference i i'm not actually a cie i
said or am i
no it's fine
so
let's get
started so we already have like let's
see 276 people watching wow
all right so uh the thing about suburbs
is that as you can as you can see
it's um like the road structure like the
road system is set up that it's full of
[ __ ] dead ends and um
and um
where am i currently living in germany
and thank you for the donation
so we're going to do
here
a an area full of cul-de-sacs and uh
just like
horrible [ __ ] uh
as with most suburbs
i'm not going like this is not going to
be of course an exact 100 representation
of suburbs
uh i don't spend my time memorizing
suburb layout but
i think it's going to be fair enough oh
before i forget uh the yeah whatever the
most important
grover house water treatment plant
i need a water treatment plant to build
grover house okay
um
and i'm just gonna place it here for now
whatever
water tree
well it's wait wait a second what a
treatment plant
i don't know if you can hear that the
cats are running around like crazy
hmm i don't know which one okay i'm just
gonna place all of them and see see
which one is uh
see which one it uh
it wants
oh what a treatment plant oh god damn it
okay this this might actually might
actually need a mod or something i i
really wanted to place grover house in
this suburb
and why would you put it behind uh
anyway
so um
also i saw a question about uh
from wing uh winsigerman where are we
currently living i live in germany right
now
thankfully i am not going back to
hungary
for obvious reasons
oh by the way also um
the um
the meetup
that i mentioned in my community tab
that is
uh budapest also got a fair bit of
um
a quite fair bit of actual uh um people
responding that they are they would be
interested there won't be a meet-up in
hungary because i
i honestly am concerned about this this
is ironically i'm concerned about a
bunch of neo-nazis showing up
uh happened before actually just like a
bunch of you know
athletic young men in black
to uh [ __ ] you up because they heard
that you are um
you you're doing a stream you're doing a
like you are
a
lgbt supporting lib degenerate and so
whoops
uh
yeah so no um
no um
uh
one sec
right so no
um meet up there that would be i think i
think dangerous uh it actually happened
in hungary so uh there was like a
uh there was like an
area where uh like in hungary actually
uh a bar where you know not to it up
because they thought it was like
something like d gen stuff is going on
in there or thank you for the donation
of five heroes for uh ethelion
so they showed up um and then well in
the end they didn't do much they just
like left these like
i think [ __ ] bottles look like they
wrote something on the
damn the cats are going insane
uh they just they just left some um
i think graffiti or something else on
the
uh door or something or they like i
don't know tried to pry it open or
something like that happened and
you know
where was the police [ __ ] if i know uh
but um
yeah the funny thing is though in
hungary like the only the um
the reason why i why i know that there
are any lgbt events
within budapest like i i don't follow
this normally but like the only reason i
know about these things is because
uh
like
from neo-nazis like when they when they
make public threats against
this
[ __ ] gay event or this address where
he's going to talk about this thing and
it's like oh okay
okay i guess thank you
well i i don't spend my waking hours
going over where
uh
different lgbt events will be held
but i guess they do so more power to
them i guess
um captain william let's see i looked at
the map and i realized it's the exact
map i'm building my own city and i've
gotten much more into serious kindness
lately yes this is actually the one the
basic the og maps
uh i think i chose this because it was
flat enough
and uh
yeah
it was
very nice it is very nice in fact
okay uh one sec so
let's uh i have a bit of a i have a
actually the grover suburb in front of
me
for those of you don't know who grover
is
also
kushagar and thank you very much for the
100 rupees once again for those of you
who don't know what grover or who grover
is
um
just google grover house
it was this
dude who
decided okay
i'm going to just do some do some home
renovation
and
people told him hey dude it's nice but
like
th this is this isn't
this is not diy because he wanted to do
it just like fully diy
um
people were like
dude like this this is this is
like
you should hire a professional and the
guy was like no
i'm i'm good i'll i'll build this entire
house myself and oh my [ __ ] got it
that that is
actually
that went as well as you might expect
um
the uh i think there's like a bunch of
pictures everywhere like twitter or
whatever
and uh
oof
that's um that's some
prime real estate
there but what the guy actually managed
to put together
uh just like
looks like everything is like barely
holding together falling apart
um and um
yeah it was it was it was bad
uh how do i get rid of these [ __ ]
stones here
uh
nodes segments trees no they can stay
props decals
okay like this
like
i don't know like i don't know if it's
one of my mods or something not like the
moderators but like serious kind of nice
mods but
the stones stay on the road even if you
put them down anyway
so
uh let's see
hmm i'm gonna look out look up look at
the live chat as well i'm not gonna
ignore you guys
uh
let's see
oh we're a big fan of the dubai video
i'm i'm glad
and
all right
yes uh as blood orange asks what dude
what is this road network are you trying
to make an unwalkable hellscape yes
that's actually what exactly what i'm
trying to make
and then we're going to fix it so that's
going to be the whole
conclusion of i'm going to just have
this suburb
up and running and then and then we're
going to just
essentially
take a look at how this could be fixed
now as you can see this is completely
[ __ ] like this is not suitable for
human habitation
but
but yeah it's uh
this is what we're going to fix this is
the point uh to show you show us how
this uh
how this horrible [ __ ] suburb can
actually be made
uh more livable
or like more more walkable and just like
not be this [ __ ]
uh travesty
let's see
right in
meanwhile this is as i said this is also
a q a so feel free to if you have a
question feel free to ask
um either at me or or do a super chat
because this is also a charity stream
the reason uh or like the goal is down
in the description
all right
if you missed the beginning no worries
uh there's not much not much was going
on
uh i was just firing up things oh we got
two super chats right in a row
so corey springer happy ten dollars
thank you very much happy holiday season
i'll likely miss a chunk of the stream
this is just past midnight here in
minnesota but i'll be
back to check out the grover house thank
you well yeah feel free to check back
i'm gonna be up for about eight hours
um
yeah so you can feel free to come and go
everyone uh plus the stream will be
uploaded later on to my channel
uh so josh judge five pounds thank you
very much uh what's your take on the
west getting involved if russia invades
ukraine and what do you think about the
ethiopian civil war
uh that states collapsing oof some nice
questions
uh first ethiopia
um
uh well let's see ethiopia is uh yeah i
mean they're pretty much [ __ ]
as far as i can tell
i
don't follow it that closely though uh
of course i'm following issues more
close to him like the russian threat
if ethiopia collapses i mean
got him i don't know
um i don't think they will but like so
far things are in looking good we'll see
what happens maybe the tigre region will
just break away and then that's going to
be the end of it
uh
right
the meetup can be a front for urban
sprawl protest
yeah
so the second half of the question
what do i think about
what's the exact question let's see
uh
what's your take on the west getting
involved if russia invades ukraine and
what do you think about the ethiopian
civil war that's terrible okay so the
the russian part was getting involved in
russia invades
uh at this point actually i don't think
that russia will invade um
although
it's so difficult to know because russia
is set up in a way that uh
political decisions are not made by
this like
shadowy group of technocrats behind the
back of the dictator
rather it's it's it's all inside putin's
head you know well not all of it but
it's uh
he has a he has a very very much
outsized
um
control political control it's kind of
like an episode of this monarchy like
the czars were before
and uh well putin himself is is a kind
of tsar actually
um
yeah so
whether or not whether or not uh russia
will invade that's a question i would
say
probably not
but um
really i don't [ __ ] know at this
point
um
hopefully not though and if the worst
gets involved
then
well the way i don't think the west will
get involved political like militarily
no no no that's i think that's pretty
much out of the question
uh too bad but like but but i also
understand that politically
no one will want to take
uh that [ __ ]
like risk of like okay we're we're
like having our soldiers die and they in
that country etc
uh yeah
it's a real just a relative situation
unfortunately and uh
no why did i okay and um yeah
i think uh once again i don't think
there's gonna be an invasion uh the
ukrainian army is i think it's much
better much better equipped than it used
to be uh plus miracle is out that's a
big thing actually oh i'm gonna [ __ ]
talk about miracle
uh
holy [ __ ] i i really want to i really
want to get this off my chest
at some point
let me just put it to some pipes
uh safely
and rupees thank you what do you think
of saudi arabia's line city project oh
boy
oh boy
oh
um
yeah
i'm gonna be making a video about that
soon it's it's as far as i'm concerned
it's like the same [ __ ] dubai tier
[ __ ]
um
also
uh
the thing is though um the next one is
going to be the this like [ __ ]
egyptian
um
uh what's it called the new
administrative capital
uh which will i think also contain a
wider sort of rant against the [ __ ]
construction project
community on youtube
uh because
like
i think i think actually i might i might
need to lay into people like
b1m or what's his goal and whatever
because
they're a bit irresponsible
um
there's nathan stone thank you for the
donation it's crazy to think i subbed to
you when you had a few hundred
subscribers
i only have my crypto blew up like if
only
my crypto blew up like you did
come to melbourne and say hi thank you
for the donation and yeah
i mean
yeah my growth actually uh was a creepy
insane
uh
okay i'm gonna power this whole thing
for now with like a geothermal power
plant whatever i'm gonna rearrange
things later and i have this mod which
means i don't need power lines so that's
nice uh right
a bunch of people adding me in chat uh
speaking which do you listen to the
chapel episode about neo nope
i don't actually listen to chapel and
that much i i listened to the to their
true allegiance cover that's that's what
was my uh
inspiration
actually
uh
to do mine
to mind religions bit
let's see can you explain how
social cons wait how could social
conservative hunger is
you come from egypt is illegal to be
lgbtq
um um
i mean men who have hearing earrings are
seen as gay yeah um okay hungary is not
as conservative as egypt but like in
terms of like european standards
they pretty much are um i mean it's it's
like
there was like this law saying uh
stating that if you are
like the there's this law they pushed
through it was the so-called pedophile
law
which there was directly against gay
people you know so
what can you do
so
hungary is still not as conservative as
poland though so that's good [ __ ]
polish
saying this as a person with polish
ancestry by the way
you know it's new tesla but that's kind
of a joke like
see like no one's it was it was unveiled
like a few i think a few weeks ago or
something no one's talking about it
already like at least i haven't seen
anyone bring it up
and yes if you if you're wondering why
i'm building a suburb
that's what i like that's the point so
we're going to be building a suburb
just this car centric horrible [ __ ]
american style
thingy and then we're going to fix it so
uh stay tuned for that
um
so
zen five years thank you very much are
you vegan
if not why do you still think it's worth
uh it's worth it to eat meat
um well i am i try to i try basically i
try to uh limit my meat consumption to
uh to a minimum
which i think is fair enough uh like i'm
not like a strictly you know
meaty's murderer etc i mean
philosophically it kind of is but
but i'm not that i'm not that
uh what the [ __ ] am i doing here
but i'm not that uh extreme i would say
just if you limit your meat consumption
within reason i think that's that's
that's good enough because
like the main problem is of course
there's the of course there's the animal
suffering considerations
but also um
also the fact that uh
it's uh well it's very
sort of inefficient environmentally
unfriendly etc i do actually look
forward to lab meet
like these lab grown
meat types and i can't wait for
the
[Music]
[ __ ] food equivalent of anti-vaxxers
protesting in front of my grocery store
saying that
uh you know they're gonna be planting
microchips into your brain
with that
with the meat so you know don't eat it
and also whatever
uh
if you if you don't think that will
happen then i'm sorry
it will um
so run.gift thank you for the uh
wrong that's is it norwegian i don't
know but thank you hey adam love your
stuff just wanted to say hi well hi back
uh thank you for the donation and we
have uh ff steve
five dollars thank you is it worth for
it uh is it worth it for a usa citizen
to become a hungarian citizen
by a descent or is it a better idea to
become a dutch nation looking to be an
eu citizen okay if you want to be an eu
citizen i would say
i mean if you if you can become a
hungarian citizen through like ancestry
or something then game fine uh if you
have other options though like if you
have other options for it like if you
have some claims some to some other
citizenship
then that's also good
uh yeah with europe like the point is
that you get a that you get a schengen
uh
a schengen uh passport
like you are a citizen of a schengen
country that means you can just like
actually know actually if you are if you
are
a citizen of any european country then
you can come and go it's just that there
are still borders like the words towards
romania and bulgaria
um yeah
so um
yeah so go for it uh
if i were you uh the
let me wait let me take a look at the
chat
um
yeah the robo meet is a 5g secret weapon
exactly exactly
um
hmm oh mobia strip thank you for the
uh
donation i love your content so much but
rip to the walkability of that
neighborhood yes people once again we
are uh
there's a bunch of new people tuning in
yes uh we are building a a horrible
american suburb
and then we're gonna fix it so that's
going to be
that's going to be the the whole idea
uh chandra sir thank you for the 25
a number of narratives american even
those
more left-leaning tend to have negative
views towards such groups as roma and
irish and irish travelers why do you
think vitriol towards these people
is so common vis-a-vis
others
i'm going to answer this question one
second
first i'm going to
uh because it's a good question
oh wait do we have a brush instead
um
yeah i need to make it clear for people
what this is about
uh
like this
uh we need a big enough
this
there we go
some trees
get out of the way
we don't want any trees here
trees are gay
there you go so um
hope i didn't misspell that though
uh
there we go
so uh
yeah so um about that question it's
actually a very good question
um
once again oh yeah i got people tuning
you know uh
well although all over the place yes we
are building an american suburb and then
we're going to fix it that's the idea
so
uh so once again
we're going to fix it with first we're
going to have to build the thing and
then we are going to
do
um
like we're going to have some measures
which will
um
be as simple as possible
as uh
cost effective as possible and we're
going to uh try to work
within okay we're going to try to work
within
the
the uh
existing road structure so this is this
is
this is the plan anyway
and um
and
wow this way i'm gonna have like two hmm
no i'm just gonna con oh no [ __ ] it
we're gonna go full american we're gonna
have two two interchanges here
right it's very terrible but uh let's
see let's see what we can do we're gonna
basically europeanize it um and so to
back to the question so why do i um once
again pull it up
back to
uh schandler's question
um i was listening to a negative use
towards such groups
yes um
so why why do i think that that kind of
ritual exists yeah so
wait a minute
[ __ ] man
uh shouldn't have put this back anyway
uh so why do i think that there's such
so much vitriol yeah it's something i
noticed too like i got i got an audience
who's like you know i do something some
like left-leaning content etc and it's
like oh yeah
va left-leaning let's support be nice to
people support minorities etc
and then i'm and then i [ __ ]
and then i mention the word roma and
then all that audience suddenly is like
looks at me as like
oh yeah blood and soil
okay
okay
uh mostly eastern europeans like the
people i saw like to be the most vitriol
like uh
[Music]
in my
chat were europeans like eastern europe
people with like eastern european names
which i understand i mean eastern europe
is uh
not quite there yet in terms of social
progress but the reason why
um
is because
well i don't think there's a
most like
most people are not like
exposed to roma and the like
on a daily basis you know they just like
sometimes see one or two and it's like
ooh they're kinda i don't know
and they're kind of uh
i don't know
louder or some things it's just like to
real stuff like that but they they don't
really have a room of friends relatives
etc so it's easier to other people when
you don't really have a
any personal connection to any of them
you know if you have a for example it's
a typical like i have a black friend you
know so like if you know and like black
people then it's super like super hard
but it's significantly harder to
uh be racist
and with roma i think not so many people
have
like
explicitly roma friends i would say so
this might be one of the
issues
calling son thank you 45 dollars your
work is great we need you
in congress to make our streets great
again i really though i've learned a lot
from your content thank you very much
um
and um
yeah well you know i might end up
running from running for congress from
you know
uh from germany or something i could
just do my congress sessions in like
zoom calls you know
um
adrian sasquatch thank you very much for
the pln that's paulie's life right uh
obligatory poll here yes uh can confirm
it's wild here at least outside of
warsaw anyway uh what do you think of
nuclear in energy mix i think nuclear is
fine
um
there's this strange agitation
uh about like shutting it off and
whatever i i don't i don't really think
so like we have like
this would i might actually i might
actually accept this if we for example
didn't have [ __ ] lignite
in the energy mix already like oh like
these very polluting fossil fuels if uh
since we have those
it's kind of
you know when someone says you know oh
we don't need nuclear then i go okay
wait so like we kind of do
because the the energy mix needs to be
uh made up of something and if it's not
nuclear
then um
then it's going to be inevitably uh
fossil fuels for now so yeah nuclear i
think it's fine largely and before i
miss this uh
it
it's your boy alex thank you for 4.99 hi
adam do you have any tips for learning
german also what city do you live in and
what country should i move to in europe
to get away from the us well
i would say if you want to get away from
the us and um like right now i live here
i live around dresden what the [ __ ] is
this
oh my god
anyway um
uh right now if you uh
want to move away from the us i would
recommend um
well that depends of course like what
level is your german
uh or like what languages do you speak
what's your budget etc because if you
speak german i would say east east
germany former east germany is pretty
much slam dunk
in terms of um
in terms of
just
affordability and uh quality of uh
quality of uh
public services and everything so i
think it gets a bad rep but otherwise
it's it's i think it's fine except
especially leipzig that's a very nice
place and it's super cheap too um
oh grace cascade i think for 9.99 uh
someone raised in a country that doesn't
use the imperial system uh i believe the
imperial system is far superior imagine
not knowing how many cheeseburgers are
in a freedom exactly i know right
yeah a [ __ ] imperial system by the
way did you know that the imperial
system is actually like we have that
because um
the reason why we have that
is because
um
i think the ship which was supposed to
bring in
the uh
the the this sort of uh
uh you know the the the the the units
you know the the absolute units
uh which means that is very very
meticulously measured
uh weights and distances whatever so
that they can be like the uh
so they can be you know uh
uh copied and replicated and etc
that ship that was carrying uh
[Music]
that was actually
uh attacked by pirates i believe
and hijacked
and so it didn't make it to
the uh the uh this sort of i think what
was it like congress hearing in the u.s
something like that
and since it wasn't there in the end the
congress people decided okay we're not
gonna [ __ ] this we're we're not going to
we're not going to uh
uh implement metric because it's not
here we're not let's not [ __ ] with it
we're gonna stick with imperial
and that's why we have uh the imperial
system today in the us which i think is
a mistake like in our world seriously
like i think like aside from the us
there's like
two three other countries that use it
and it's um
yeah i mean it's it's pretty stupid you
know i mean that's that's the thing
about it how it's uh it's complicated
versus um
metric is like
yeah whatever like
10 of this equals one of that and
10 of that equals
10 of the other and then whatever
yeah i think i think there was also uh
didn't one of the mars landers
uh
crash because of that because the
because it was like a cooperation
between americans and europeans and the
europeans used metric and the americans
imperial and so the measurements were a
bit like you know
screwed up
uh super chats are collecting in the
meantime sorry for
neglecting you people
uh super santiago 200 rubos hello to
something thank you for all the epic
vids what are your thoughts on aleksei
navalny um i mean he's an
anti-corruption activist
strikes me as like a civic nationalist
dude uh thinks crimea is russia which is
you know whatever
but uh i mean it's not not good enough
obviously
otherwise i support his struggle
that being said like he's still better
than
far superior than putin
um
yeah but of course i mean he's going to
he's going to
i think get killed eventually in prison
so
or is he still alive actually i i don't
haven't heard of him that much lately
but yeah the idea is that um
the idea is that uh
uh he's going to
be pretty much just
dead
soon i would say
oh you do you know what we need here we
need a [ __ ] highway interchange
just to make things more horrible
uh because you know [ __ ] it
yeah so
navalny uh i like the dudes and i also
like how i just like trolled
the uh [ __ ] russian leadership back
there
um
[Music]
like you know like he actually called
the [ __ ] agents who were responsible
for basically poisoning him and
pretended to be
pretended to be uh
from the government and the agent
actually
uh the the agent actually bought it
and so they had this very nice
conversation about like
okay
yeah we yeah we we poisoned him and you
know oh by the way this is not a secure
channel because he called him just like
a regular mobile phone
but nonetheless you know
uh it's so fun plus his his
investigative journalism on putin's
palace is [ __ ] great
if you haven't yet check out putin's
palace i think it's it's in english too
like it's in english subtitles
it's it's great
oh my god this this eastern dumb [ __ ]
you know
oligarch energy of like just building
this huge tasteless [ __ ] castle for i
think a billion dollars or something
it's something you're saying um
garth thank you for 200 rupees
uh i like your videos but they only
focus on developed nations india barely
has suburbs or even good roads how can
we solve issues of congestion
slums hope you'll cover developing
nations soon yes uh i i do uh
i do plan on doing that actually um
yeah the
the uh
the way you cover those areas is with uh
just
don't okay don't first off don't build
monorails okay so that's that's number
one number two there are there are
numbers there are a huge number of uh
just affordable
transit methods which are um
uh available like just just if you set
up a just a regular bus network which is
dense enough then like frequent enough
etc
and that's already very very good so if
you do that then hey that's that's
already uh half the battle uh also like
some basic urban planning like probably
the roads should be put together but um
like a you know fake stuff and etc
um
right and
so uh rob dot gif thank you very much
for the 25
rom that's still norwegian right i don't
know
uh uh no law americans kept imperial
units because factory owners lobbied for
it so they didn't have to retool their
machines
uh
no
no no i'm talking about i think this is
like pre
that area i think
uh we can look it up like i just sort of
read an article about this uh
a couple of months ago or last year
maybe and it stuck with me because it
was interesting but hey my favorite to
look it up uh derek 4.99 thank you very
much what's the size of your tv
everyone uses imperial european civil
civil aviation authority use the
imperial system just saying it's more
than two three countries
well then the european civil aviation
authority must be
cancelled
and i don't care
yeah but
no um i do i actually didn't know that
if they do then
good for them i guess
they might actually they might actually
use it because of america like if i'm
convinced if america like the most
powerful country on the planet
didn't use imperial then i think i think
uh
no one else would at this point now it's
just like uh you know we do it because
they do it
um
just checking if i'm visible correctly
all right um
all right
adam do you do voiceover gigs that's
smooth better tone oh yeah maybe i
should do voiceovers
i
i don't do voiceovers but hey if someone
if someone asks me
uh if they're you know if there's the
new [ __ ]
that oh god that [ __ ] half-life fan
game where they asked keemstar
to do the [ __ ] voice over and it's
like you know he's
it was what was his like capture the
free man or something like that i really
like half-life so that was i was like
pretty interested about that game but it
was pretty [ __ ]
it's like president keem story there
whatever
fellow americans
do you watch city skylines youtube if so
what is your favorite uh hi from queens
i'm from windsor australia uh thank you
tom jackson for the five australian
dollars the second part i kind of
mumbled it was like if so what's your
favorite high from queensland australia
i don't actually watch them i sometimes
see them pop up here and there but
i don't know
i don't
usually follow them i guess i kind of
know what they're up to but that's
that's pretty much it
um
nick bagnora thank you for 199. it's
nice what you're doing here keep it up
thank you
um yeah look i should lots of people
like the criticism it's a i find it
funny though like the weird criticism
that i get
uh sometimes is that
you know adam like there
adam
i really like your urban planning takes
but
i
i just cannot agree with your political
takes and it's like
first off like yeah dude like okay like
no no no no one's asking that from you
feel free like you know you can enjoy my
content for
for um
the urban planning part but also keep in
mind
that um
also keep in mind that uh
um
like all my urban planning takes are
basically informed by my political views
so it's funny when it's like to me it
like
just sounds a bit funny when people tell
me hey
i like your planning but not your
politics well dude like my my planning
is
based on my politics so i don't know
oh well
uh
i just started uh it's your boy alex 199
thank you i i just or just started in
germany a few weeks ago any tips
i'm just
kidding anyway
yeah so uh yeah with german it's the
[ __ ] dirty dust i [ __ ] hate it
holy [ __ ] but anyway
there are some good rules of thumb
uh okay so wait one second we're going
to finish this part and then we're going
to zone it out we're going to have it
all grow out into a suburb and then
we'll start
yeah so with german it's like there are
some rules there of like for example if
if the word ends with e then
it's very very likely then d
and then
with their ah
anyway then and
if it ends with ong
then it's also
then it's um
then that's also
d and
anyway they're the pronouns if you
what pronouns
[ __ ] i i'm sorry it's morning
anyway learn those uh the rules
regarding that that's that's going to
make your life vastly like much much
more easy i can trust me
uh
thank you for uh vasu sam thank you for
five
canadian dollars what are these hundred
ngos called so just so i can look into
more into it more uh
i saw of course there's the maltese
people i saw uh like the two that i
already donated to our
versitas i believe
and
i switch is this education program
and
the other is this so-called
invisible school
um
where they were there i'm gonna link
these things later on so don't worry
because i'm gonna i'm going to be
uh
donating to them
uh yeah so like they basically have
after after school programs for kids and
they they're like they provide like
financial and and
like
logistical support for rama rama kids or
like young adults who want to go to
university
because it's pretty rough out there
actually if you are if you are
even if you're a student uh chris b wow
uh five fifty dollars thank you very
much love your content any advice for an
american looking to become a digital
nomad what cities countries should they
be looking at moving to
that are well structured has good public
spaces in good public transit
well i guess
i guess
you should
let's see
um well that depends if you have a
digital nomad like i assume you work
you work
long distance
and
for you it's just a question of like
okay i'm gonna do the same thing just
where
like that's what i'm getting if that's
the case indeed then i would say
east germany
maybe
cities like leipzig etc which are fairly
cheap
and
good public services
uh but mostly it's in the cheapness
berlin is super [ __ ] expensive that's
the problem with it but
uh yeah
thanks to you
okay but that might not be completely
fair but still
ronda jeff thank you for once again the
ten hey adam many opinion on the
charity strong towns
uh strong towns i've heard of them like
i think they they actually they don't
they want to do the same thing i'm doing
right now not building somebody without
like fixing them
if so that would be super neat
um
but i did not look into them as much
actually so
remember to drink some more water my
dude hell yeah i'm i am i'm a big
drinker what can i say
oh we have the rail here oh this will
have a roll later on so okay
um
yeah um
so anyway as we wait for more
uh questions like super chance to roll
in i think i can talk to you guys about
um
so my since we're talking about germany
some of my frustrations with with
the
outgoing political elite
angela merkel
etc like there was this there's this
agitation
um
in uh i would say
just like in the in the new sphere and
the social series on the internet about
angela merkel you know she's she's done
with her tenure
and um
or like uh she's done with her uh
you know little uh
political career and then oh you know
what uh what uh what a girl boss we lost
oh my god hashtag
angela
angela like
true
statesman
you know example to all the women and
girls outside
and um
and it's just it's just so
and like
basically people people people um
perceive the miracle as this
um
progressive hero basically
and um
you know who stood up against trump held
together europe
and you know did all these very nice
things for us and
it's all [ __ ] and well not all
[ __ ] but like it's it's it's not
it's not what it's made out to be
basically like at the end of the day
angela merkel was a conservative and
and as such like she had some
mildly progressive views
uh but i'm convinced she only did that
to
sort of uh hold together the more
the more um
somewhat more progressive side of the of
the uh
um
of her party now
the thing about her though is that like
for example she uh there's this vote in
germany about
uh
uh
thanks for the tip do you play any
sports and
well no i just i just run and work out
and do that sort of stuff so yeah um
where was i
yeah anyway so um there was uh but
the fact that people
people talk about her like some
progressive i mean that's uh
it's pretty dumb i would say she is not
progressive she gestured towards it but
otherwise when push came to shove when
there was like the uh
the vote
about
uh gay marriage
etc she voted no
so
you know
because [ __ ] gay rights i guess she said
everyone should vote
uh based on their conscience and then
her conscience
said yeah
gay people don't deserve any you know
equal rights or whatever so
plus she is actually a big part of why
um
orban was was left to to to run amok so
in some in some senses she did the most
to
undermine europe
and uh even even on a geopolitical scene
her views were just uh were just uh
basically
deutsche and alex so you know
and not much else really that like there
wasn't much else there
every single position she held
uh
and every sort of measure she put
through
um
i mean it was all in service of this
wider german geopolitical interests so
uh so when i say when i see people
saying oh the the girl boss they
women and girls should aspire to be like
her like no
actually it was under her that that
orban was really just like allowed to uh
to um
to uh just faster basically because in
hungary the german core manufacturing
industry has some significant holdings
and they do get a super low tax rate in
hungary so
merkel was like yeah we we we want that
hey orban if you're
what are doing like deacons like
basically uh taking capturing the state
building like uh
um
building an autocracy eroding democracy
down to nothing
uh
well like into this like heavily
controlled power democracy kind of thing
feel free as long as our taxes are low
and that's what happened and yeah i i i
hesitate to forgive her for that because
whatever okay
i don't need to explain why i think
so yeah merkel was pretty cringe
actually and all of shorts i think she
is he's better though like he's
uh somewhat better rd vhs uh 499 thank
you very much any tips on how to start
pushing for better walkable
neighborhoods locally oh that's a good
question so what you see this
abomination that you see in front of you
it's uh
actually i i have to pay attention to
how i zone out or how i put out these
roads because i instinctively start
connecting things to
uh make it better
which we'll be doing in a bit but not
yet
so
okay any tips well uh
it depends on your locality doesn't it
like uh
for example if you have some kind of um
uh
public advocacy group for walkability
then hey then that's that's cool you
should probably probably join that if
you have a politician locally which
advocates for that or you know if you
have if they have some kind of like town
hall meeting etc uh the
point is like the these views about
walkability etc these are very agreeable
views these these are very very
potentially popular views just like how
you know just like
views
uh
views that are
um
sort of considered to be say um it's
like hardcore leftist whatever
views
uh such as like workplace democracy or
you know like basically ownership of the
means of production if you break it down
to people
logically like hey
you know workplace democracy which is
which is ownership of the means of
production to some extent
you say hey
uh
is your is your boss competent does your
boss always know um
what to do and uh uh you know like or or
is it rather your the employees who do
the work are there any people in you in
your workplace who are
uh more engaged in sort of office
politics than actual work and they get
paid more is your are people at your
workplace being paid fairly
and based on their performance and not
just you know how much they can suck up
well most people would say well no like
most people would just go
uh yeah okay whatever not really and to
these questions and it's like hey
wouldn't it be nice if we had something
like a co-op you know when workers have
more control people like hmm but
wouldn't the workers like yeah isn't
that risky i was like hey
just
what if we just try it with some text
incentives see if you see if it works
out and then people are like yeah okay
that sounds fair let's try it
sounds sounds uh
interesting and then there you have it
you have people who are in support of
trying out
the ownership like
essentially socialism so these views
just like decongestion are actually
rather
agreeable
and um
and uh if you
if you market it to people like hey
you know businesses will have more
revenue
the children think of the children oh
this is a big one with boomers think of
the children they're gonna be able to
play outside the streets will be safe
you know how all these kids now all
these all these [ __ ] kids nowadays
just like
sit in front of their
mining craft
video games
and
the [ __ ]
call of counter strike yeah
with these streets
finally you're gonna have those kids out
of their couches you know and then
and then just do this do what we did in
the good old times
which is
go outside and i don't know like
beat each other over the head with
stakes or something i
don't know what bloopers
are doing back then actually i do
um so these are actually some very very
agreeable petitions
um
so if you want to advocate for it
locally
uh
just yeah
easier i think the easiest part if you
find some kind of political
pundit who has that on the agenda
um but like who is like amicable if you
have some kind of like democrat or like
left-leaning uh
person there then um
then uh
then if you at least if you like if they
have some kind of like town hall meeting
or something and you pitch this idea to
them maybe even privately if they have
some
um
if they have some um
you know
some of those then then hey go now it's
like the problem the point is to put
these ideas out there okay
uh right so you wash yourself from me
thank you very much for the 25 canadian
dollars folk medal for
london to see solidarity with roma
community is
fascism yes uh that's that's actually
uh thank you very much
and holy [ __ ] dude jonathan thank you
for the 500 us dollars
uh grew up in suburban usa hating core
dependency
and um
but just assumed the whole world was
this way until i found your channel love
your videos and love this game keep it
up and jesus like thank you very much
for this
500 [ __ ] dollars
thanks
yeah um actually i might hey as soon as
the stream goes on we might actually
build
a um
a european suburb next to it just to
give you the contrast uh
so but first we're going to build this
up and then we're going to fix the
american one uh or maybe or or we can
actually also vote on it so
when i'm done with this suburb we can
vote whether uh i should start fixing
this
uh or we build the european suburb next
to it first and then we fix the sub the
american suburb and then we see how it
turns up it turns out so
so uh when i'm done
uh with zoning it out and like you know
the i grow out the houses and everything
then we're gonna have a poll about it
and jesus once again thank you for the
500 [ __ ] humorous dollars
uh jesus
um
actually the the
number of donations youtube since i have
to check youtube because i registered in
the czech republic i
have
the data in check crowns it says i have
17 000 check grounds
so far from super chats which is of
course uh all going to charities
uh
that's 772 dollars and 24 cents so we're
doing good hey we've been steering for
an hour so holy [ __ ] uh kishvanin thank
you for 400 hungarian foreigns nice
every bit helps
uh the winsig man uh 25 is lotis am i
insane i want to be pm of country where
i live poland i have left distant
progressive political viewpoints oh yeah
you're not insane that's called praxis
my friend
the thing is though
um
with political advocacy
like you can have some like really
[ __ ] um radical views like i have in
terms of urbanism
i'm extremely radical
like i'm i'm uh in terms of urbanism i'm
[ __ ] climate stalin so uh
okay maybe not that's severe but
i'm up there basically so i would i
would uh if if i got
a um
check youtube based oh exactly um
so if i got
um
i got if i if i had like control over
what to do in in a [ __ ] city
then oof uh
i would i would do some
amazing things there
amazing as uh jesse peterson would say
just like peterson do you do you love
black people
do you love lappy amazing
oh god that man anyway
so um
right but but see but see my advocacy
even though i'm extremely radical like
some people some people would call me
like uh i think in the czech republic
there's this saying called uh you're
you're a melon
oh a donation from alex jones five
dollars thank you and good luck with
your wife
um
if you've heard that news with derek
jones
um
anyway um
and jay rodman 10 thank you very much
good topic and good cause shame about
the game not supporting reasonable city
planning
yeah that's what uh that's what people
made mods for so don't worry my friend
um
yeah so basically uh
what was i saying oh yes um i was like i
am uh very radical when it comes to
urban planning but if i if i get got
into office
um i would actually
um
like i would actually uh
of course start implementing my views
but you have to be smart about it so if
you have if you're looking for for
political office political advocacy
opportunities etc the i would say the
best thing is
uh first you have to sell it to people
right so you have to well as the saying
goes you have to engage people on their
own level
so
uh i think this is why so many like
these tanki oriented leftist youtube
channels fail or don't garner any
support because
it's [ __ ]
um you know they're like okay we're
going to do a readout read of of [ __ ]
das capita chapter one
and then you know it's like no no one
really cares about that oh wait no this
is still walkable we can't have this
uh
you know let's do a reading of
das capital chapter one
chairman mao's thoughts about like no
um that's that's that's not how this
works uh if you like
leftist leftist political views
when you get rid of all the hysterics
all the all the right wing you know oh
my god boo boozer etc
when you get rid of all those
it they're actually pretty agreeable
and just like just what i said earlier
the the economic democracy part they're
actually super agreeable positions
and they make sense
and uh
you know they make sense because
they make they make sense to people
because people are generally not
billionaires you know
and um
you know they're only scary if you are a
billionaire so uh
whatever and uh
with that i think it's it's very easy to
advocate but you but
you have to sort of you have to be very
mindful of the dosage that you give
people
you know
uh so basically
don't mention that it's that it that
it's like leftist politics until people
agree with it at which point it's gonna
be never mind because there's
i'm sorry there's there's lots of
emotions associated with uh with uh
with such things like you know people
like oh leftism bad it's like why is
leftism bad well because it's leftism
it's like okay whatever
um but as soon as you start people start
getting people to buy into stuff like
what bernie sanders did you know just
like milk toast so social democracy etc
then suddenly
the overturned window shifts and they
become more amicable hold on let me
catch up with on these super chats
um yeah i see
uh m fuller five dollars thank you very
much living in the us and seeing people
drive around my city
in
tank sized trucks makes me feel climate
like climate starting to oh yeah
especially if they're [ __ ] like start
calling or some [ __ ]
you know
alexander miller thank you for the 4.99
by the way
let's see
uh alex jones how do you feel about noam
chomsky his overall views his views from
on the boston genocide and maybe uh
maybe if i know anything uh about
his issues in linguistics so chomsky was
like a
um he was actually a basis of of like i
mean he kind of invented linguistics in
a sense
uh but yeah we we dealt a lot with his
views i i don't keep up with him
nowadays but i mean he's still there as
far as i know he's still very much
uh
he's still very much um uh
active i would say in the political
sphere or wait is he even alive
i think so i don't know like i don't
follow him but i mean he strikes me as a
genuine dude who is actually very
um he's actually very knowledgeable
about things very intelligent
uh but you know like the problem is that
he's like 500 years old so you know
we might need some younger activists
there too so you know you tell like is
like you know norm chomsky bernie
sanders etc it helps if you're if you're
if your political flagship candidates
won't be dead in like you know two weeks
uh nd vhs499 thank you very much um
you should definitely plan out what you
would do uh with a city sometime i'd
like to see some of your ideas and see
this kind of video eventually oh yeah uh
that's a there's a good point actually i
have a second channel
it's linked on my main channel i think
in the banner there's a link it's adam
something else
i think i might actually clip parts of
this uh stream and just start uploading
it so so we'll have some content uh
basically everything that will not go on
the main channel will go there
uh so um yeah that's that's that's what
i'm planning
um
uh yes it's gonna be more more like a
very variety channel also for my like
also for myself
because um
because um
this is like kind of like a safeguard to
protect me from burning out basically
uh which i of course don't want it would
be a shame if i did
um
but yes
it's entirely possible unfortunately
that you know if after a while uh
after a while you just like you just
feel like oh [ __ ] dude like you you
can't even find the energy to
to do anything
because you know you you i mean you you
do need variety so uh
so um
i think that's that's what the second
channel will be about it's gonna be like
this creative refresher
uh this uh for me mostly
so as you can see by the way the um and
so what's going on here
uh oh
shimmer
i don't know i don't know what he said
about that i have no [ __ ] idea really
uh but if he denied genocide then that's
obviously pretty bad
um
reminds me of those [ __ ] tankies
um
you know with the people who have these
like funny ideas about the ogre genocide
and whatnot
anyway so oh we got 500 viewers cool uh
welcome people so
i guess the i guess people kind of um
i guess people kind of uh
circulated a bit and what we're doing
here just to repeat is that we are
building a horrifying american suburb uh
it's [ __ ] terrible etc and then we're
gonna fix it we're gonna make it
walkable and we're gonna make it nicer
and the idea is that
the idea is that
we're going to
just try to not modify the road
structure as much as we can
but we're going to work with what we
have and with that
um
and we're also going to build a european
suburb next to it and
once i'm done with the road layout and
we have the suburb up and running we are
going to vote whether i should start
fixing it right now or should i whether
i should build
the european suburb on most likely here
on the other side
um
heckland can can't get clip chimped if
you clip chimp yourself oh hell yeah
that's that's uh that's my
that's some backwards 4dhs
uh power move there
uh
oh god i cannot reach cyrillic uh that
well
uni
did that they'll be kind of thing is
this softener so that would be
nailed it
700 rupees thank you very much been
watching since before you've exploded
with dubai bid since i'm russian i would
be interested if you ever cover our
hellish urbanism of soviet and modern
era especially since you've praised the
concept of coming vlogs oh yeah
i would think about coming bla i think
about uh coming docs of course is
there's a right way and there's a
there's a right way and the of course
the wrong way of doing it i guess this
is this applies to everything of course
like duh
uh thing is though
uh with russia um like i actually i'm
actually planning on covering something
something similar
uh i'm gonna be planning uh
some of kiev's urban planning actually
kiev to be correct
um
because that's that's actually a very
interesting case study
of
a city which was like kind of set up
correctly
but then
of course
uh but then of course uh
late like what happened to it was
basically after after the the uh
follow the soviet union and the years
ensuing afterwards
um
it's the it's real estate meme but in
real life so real estate developers
basically just like
bought off everyone in the uh
in the city hall and they're just like
building whatever the [ __ ]
now now there is like a push back
against it so now the
the uh
the building inspectorate was reformed
uh before the building inspector it was
performed it was like it's pretty uh
it was pretty funny like this is in
ukraine um
before it was uh reformed so there was
like okay
uh
the new inspector will work from like
uh from like the next day and the old
one is valid until like midnight
the old one
which was
essentially like
one of the most corrupt uh one of the
most corrupt [ __ ]
um
institutions in the whole country like
everyone agreed
um
the old one started issuing a record
number of permits
well into midnight
so yeah you can you can kind of imagine
what went down there
so
yeah and so it was basically the uh it's
real estate meme a bunch of developers
paid off [ __ ] everyone
and they just build whatever
and uh the problem with that is those
projects risk of risk becoming slums
essentially because you know you build
something there are no public
communities
um
you know the developer is not obligated
to build out stuff like schools and
other public services
with the
with those um
with those [ __ ]
uh
developments
and then you know and then the state has
to so the taxpayers basically have to
essentially subsidize
uh
the those [ __ ] development projects
um so and so we have these coming block
neighborhoods
with um
basically with um um just
which are well built and then on top of
this comes this
[ __ ] giant
uh new developing new development
you know a
district with sometimes with like
questionable questionable materials of
course they're they're not all bad
and
let's still we have a kitty
kitty
we have a cat ladies and gentlemen
uh
he's also very interested in urbanism
so
he's going to join our efforts to
to
build to fix the suburb
how are you doing kitty
he actually uh
he can't close his mouth properly
uh he has some um
he has some
issues with his teeth we're gonna take
him to the uh to the dentist
to the uh
vet soon enough he's gonna get his teeth
fixed
yeah he was he was actually raised by
humans so that's why he is so uh
he's so contacting i would say
he was fed with a syringe etc because
he's also from a shelter
uh we actually currently we have four
cats in the household by the way the two
furries were like i mean the furry cats
don't get the wrong impression
um
we have um four of them because the
local cat shelter was in trouble uh they
found i don't know like uh
they were already pretty uh swamped and
then then there was like a find of like
i don't know
like 10 cats or something uh or 15 and
they took them all in
and they were in trouble and so we were
like okay how many cats can we take in
uh
like feasibly like how many of them can
we take care of
and it was like okay well about
four i guess we were there two so we
talked about okay
do we do we want
like can we handle do we want
two more and yeah we decided yes and it
worked out so like it's it's uh
it's actually pretty uh doable
uh do the cats
uh
yeah four cats and two furries no no no
no no
uh wait i think i missed the super chat
here um wrong.give in ben voice
um uh so social is all up again based
but uh will there be still cute rifle uh
gotcha games to sing my life-saving into
yeah
ah don't worry about it
daniel uh
motherland
thank you for the peruvian
um currency
uh greens from peru i wish peruvian
mayor uh
mayors uh watched your videos and plan
your city planner cities properly
instead of trying to copy the horrible
us cities oh yeah that's a trend i
actually noticed but then hey didn't uh
like the didn't some like really leftist
left-leaning guy win the the election in
peru so that's good
um
the previous one was this like
everyone's [ __ ] nightmare this is
like
you know
wasn't this like lady wait
peru
or was it chili
oh no it was chilly sorry uh yeah
uh in chile there was this like i don't
know
[ __ ]
what no no no roundabouts you know this
is the urgent america damn it
yeah guys so the theme uh just to
reiterate is
that we are building a horrible car
centric suburb now and uh
then we're gonna fix it
so yeah it was it was chilly
bacteria topic and yes in chile there
was this uh yeah this like
horrible [ __ ] neoliberal etc u.s
propped up and whatever uh conservative
leader
uh just like every that's like
everyone everyone's nightmare
if you're not a boomer and uh they got
eated and um
now it's uh now it's a more left leaning
which is good hey that's that's that's
what we're all about here
uh so
roundabout no no no no no this is this
is not these are another don't ignore it
ignore it don't don't tell people
because you know they're gonna
come out with the [ __ ]
guns and then they're like oh my god
they're they're doing this
now the roundabout and two months gonna
be stuck
i don't tolerate none of that around
race birds mother to the wood
i was like what what's your probably
around about this little combination
okay whatever
[ __ ] hogs man
so
um
anyway
yeah did you know the cars kills cats
absolutely
um can talk can you talk more about the
ussr its main problems and how it hurts
socialism oh [ __ ] yeah dude that's uh
that's um
uh pretty
it's a topic close to my heart like i
basically one could if i want to if i
wanted to be dramatic
i could say that i um oh no wait this is
this this is too walkable here
um
if i wanted to be um uh
dramatic you know
um
oh you know i grew up on the ruins of
the ussr which i kind of did of course
hungary wasn't part of the ussr it was
like a satellite state
but uh
but uh still like um the ussr was
basically
um
the i would say the motto of the ussr
should have been
on paper
of like
everything they said everything like
everything good they said
about anything of like oh equality of
people world peace etc
just put on paper afterwards and then
you basically got the whole gist of the
gist of the system
um
okay look we have uh we have our layout
it's [ __ ] horrifying
but
the kitty is inside his little uh tunnel
we got him this uh this um
this little um
you know this like this
what is it called this i don't know look
it look it's kind of like a bag with
like wires inside so it's like it's like
hell but it's like a little cat tube and
now he's
now he's inside
enjoying his life
so
let's see um
what was i saying oh yes the ussr so the
ussr the thing about the ussr
is that um
it was um
like everything the ussr
claimed to be
uh let's put on some shopping centers
around here
and some parking lots too so everything
the ussr claimed to be now we need a
bigger parking lot for that
the
they just like failed at it so
hilariously
uh it was actually pretty concerning
so you know freedom
global peace etc you know except if you
speak ill of the regime because then
it's then you're then you're [ __ ]
um
and then you know you're gonna have some
like
evening visit from evening visit from
from some
you know
gentlemen in the black car and then
you're gonna be gone for some reason
yeah so like state terror was uh
in like this so-called in like in uh
domestic sort of
internal um
counter ops that like they really
they're really really
uh
like they were all about that basically
maybe this is a bit too much um
and uh yeah it was it was a totalitarian
dictatorship while also espousing uh
leftist views so the problem was that uh
like everything they did
everything they claimed to stand for
the u.s was actually kind of doing it
better of course minus all the racism
and uh
and everything
but like
the us really was a just a standing
[ __ ] just like a complete
uh refutation of everything the ussr
ever stood for
how how are all the cute cats called
well
we got
garfello we got
friedrich carl fry hair
and we got furry butt 1 and 3.2
so
yeah so hmm
the um
let's let's put some commercial stuff
here we're gonna do a strip mall
because
[ __ ] it and we might as well
we're gonna do the most horrible things
you can so we're gonna have the strip
mall
and we're also going to have well not
here maybe
we're also going to have
um
sports fields really separated
uh but first i'm gonna do the the these
like public amenities
for we also need a police station
because
oh yeah
i love the snapping in this game
uh
[ __ ] it okay
um
let's see
this needs a lot more pocket let's see
well look i'm i'm european okay i i can
only place so many parking lots
without having a stroke
um
let's see let's uh [ __ ]
how are the how are these police hqs
usually uh
situated um
ah let's have it like this whatever
uh
yeah we're playing on like infinite
money uh
mode
let's see
um
let me look at the chat i don't want to
neglect you guys
let's see
yeah okay so um back to the uh
back to the ussr stuff actually
um
because it's a very interesting topic uh
to me
is um
basically the ussr was the uh
like what whatever they claimed to stand
for it was like sort of a wisdom
shared by this like
former like hungarian comedian who's
like actually pretty famous
and well liked i liked him to
fabri although he became pro-urban a bit
or i don't know complacent uh he's not
explicitly pro or bamboo still he was
he was uh saying
everything
in
during the uh
during the uh
communist era helpfully named socialism
you know
as if that was anything even approaching
socialism
that was like everything they told us
the opposite was true
so
when we were told that the uh so when
xyz comrade got on tv and said there is
no
anti-semitism in the soviet union then
we already knew that our
friends
were
at home packing
their bags
but yeah
essentially
essentially everything that they claim
to stand for you know freedom of peoples
world peace etc like it was just it was
just all front like it was all [ __ ]
um
they of course did the uh
invasion into afghanistan like they were
the first to try and then boy did it
work out well for the us
and uh if you spoke ill
of uh
of anyone in the in the uh
like if you spoke out against the regime
then you were either like
fined imprisoned or disappear depending
on the country
i think the most severe
cats can't behave
the most severe
version of this was
was in russia obviously
and
also like but also in hungary uh post
1956 it got a bit better during the
so-called uh
goulash communism
and it's so [ __ ] actually that these
these are all um
like
gets going insane so it's so it's so uh
insane though that uh that actually
uh during uh like during these times
it's called
the socialism you know like the system
and it's um
it's not really helpful because that i
mean
and
okay so it's it's this already it it
thought a thought-stopping cliche right
you know
that's not socialism and then you know
right-wingers are like haha he said the
thing ha ha that's not social ha ha
flipkart owned like
but like
but the thing is it really kind of
wasn't
you know because socialism is
the what is it like the the collective
ownership of the means of production
meaning workplace democracy
um
and um
and uh
police stations in the suburbs are
usually placed near uh other city
buildings the er libraries uh or the
city centers which are near businesses
openland are not housing
open land not housing uh we're getting
there
um
yeah so
the
thing thing was that oh [ __ ] i'm looking
at the suburb
satellite picture i need a
much more parking lots holy [ __ ] okay so
um
the thing about that is like what what
is socialism it's collective ownership
of the means of production i.e workplace
democracy of some form
um
you know it's it's um
it's a
it's that basically and communism is uh
is the uh
uh
essentially like
that's like a long way
uh
long way from us to what the [ __ ] is
happening here um but like for example
the complete decommodification of uh of
uh
of uh things like
okay and complete decommodification okay
let's let's look at an official
definition because i'm okay
i don't want to uh i don't deal with
like the ideology um
uh that often and i don't want to just
if i don't want to say the wrong things
at the top of my head a theory or system
of social organization in which all
property is is owned by the community
and each person contributes and receives
according to their ability and needs
yeah okay
so i would say this this would include
decommodification and all that now we
are that is not but we're pretty far
away from that i think we can all agree
now
the thing is though uh
this
uh
thing is though like the soviet union
was not that obvious like the state the
soviet union was stage capitalist and
since since it was state capitalist i
mean
uh it worked just like any other
um
it worked just like any other um you
know
um
just like i was a traditional capitalist
system just only that we had the red
paint on everything and also
the um
and also the the [ __ ]
um the the power was not consolidated by
you know business owners etc but
by party officials through these
communally owned like these commonly
owned
uh um
factories and the like and um
the big the the big idea was that okay
uh you know workers of the world workers
of the world rise up uh we're going to
like we we we all own this factories the
people's factory and the people are in
this sort of uh in this workers union
and but the workers union was kind of
controlled by the state so see the
do you see the [ __ ]
uh
so that was the idea that like okay
it's it's all yours
but we control it
and i think this was the motto uh this
could could be the motto of the soviet
union pretty much at this point
um and um
this of course meant that
people just like
did not give a [ __ ] about uh
about uh
basically uh the the all this ideology
all these these lofty ideologies and the
and the work they did et cetera because
like whatever they weren't composited
fairly
uh
some [ __ ] party official swallowed uh
most of it anyway
and uh
by the way right now i'm just building
[ __ ] i'm just i'm just approximating
um
the uh area as far as as best as i can
so yeah
back then there was this there was this
phenomenon of like okay
um
just like workers stealing whatever the
[ __ ] they can from from uh
yeah this is how it's supposed to look
like
just workers stealing from factories
like whatever they can
um
[ __ ]
uh
saying like the saying
went hey
if if if everything is
ours then it's also mine
and um
yeah a great example is a great example
is the uh the um
uh if you bought a car
then usually first off you have to wait
for it for like five years
and when you did when you got the car
you have to usually you have to usually
go to a friendly mechanic so a mechanic
you knew and trusted
you know
so that's already like well
uh i just need to
reset this area um
you went to a friendly mechanic whom you
knew
and you paid money some additional money
so that he can
fix everything in the car which was
either broken or didn't work or it was
stolen out
in the factory
by the workers there so it wasn't a
well-functioning system to to
to um
to uh you know
anyway it was opportunistic everyone was
stealing
people knew that like people weren't in
control of that
and uh like nothing uh it was
everything was done through party
officials
and um
and um
oh there we go country church and um
yeah we're gonna where should we put the
church
uh we're gonna put it
here
um
so
everything was uh
under the control of these [ __ ]
essentially this like oligarchical class
and um
uh everything like the fact that you
know stuff like oh the workers
uh
you know rule here what other then no no
no the party officials did
and no one else
oh let's put in a traffic park because
[ __ ] it
oh god now i need to place all the all
these
no no no not that
uh all these parking strips anyway um
one sec let me look at the chat real
quick we have 500 viewers still that's
very nice
yes i have dlcs
uh
yeah no no education yeah i need to put
up put down some high schools and i'm
just school yes do the ketty freeway 18
lanes of wine highway oh yeah i might
um
first i want to um
get this thing done right here
all this [ __ ]
there we go
and then we're gonna fill this up with
most like commercial and stuff like that
um yeah
so um
have you heard of our world federalism
and so what is your opinion i mean world
federalism like
okay
maybe in some distant future i don't
know what it would entail exactly
but hey i mean if it's nice if it works
then whatever cool first i want like
european federation federalism going and
that's already difficult enough now
imagine within the entire world
like europeans are already like
99
similar to each other
in
most of everything and even there it's
like super duper difficult so
i don't think the world federation is uh
i mean we can talk about it but
it's uh
you know it's it's still like in in the
future i would say
um yeah
let's see here we're gonna place this
because you know black friday parking
uh
[ __ ] parking videos man
no it's too big [ __ ]
okay um
what do i think about australia hmm
australia well i heard i heard that the
the
the prime minister is kind of a
conservative dumb [ __ ]
like that's literally all i know about
it
that uh there's some like dumb stuff
going on in terms of that otherwise
otherwise it's uh i hear it's like a
decent place melbourne i think or sydney
anyway one of those places like they
they
i hear they are very livable
and uh so you know that's nice
so uh
yeah but the problem is once again
conservatism so
like they tend to
they tend to ruin uh things for us
um
oh my god
there we go
[ __ ] mods man there we go so
yeah uh anyway so strya is um
yeah
like uh the my exposure to australia is
just basically a
like loud drunk
uh stack partiers you know these like i
don't know these like fred bros buff
whatever they're going
strong you might okay i can't do an
australian accent
but um
you know i in budapest moves like these
guys from england and from from austria
they come in and it's like
yeah boy bro
and it's like ah [ __ ]
one of these one of these
like there was groups
anyway uh
[ __ ]
one thing i noticed like i don't think
i've ever seen
um
maybe this is like maybe this is like uh
like uh
um
like post empire
disorder
but
some of the most stories i've read about
some of the most entitled [ __ ] people
have to be the brits
like uh there is a story where this this
british grandma went to this spanish
resort for uh for uh her holiday
and then she complained afterwards in
the press
that it was very nice but there were too
many spanish people and why can't they
go elsewhere
it's like okay
we have a super chat
tom jackson
the australian pm
shot himself in a mcdonald's
that's
actually i think that's a great
representation of
modern
neoconservative politics economic
policies
shooting yourself in mcdonald's
yeah well i guess
good luck to him
uh
all right yes the stream is indeed uh
sergeant hyun
brain dead nice
that's what it means
good luck with your breakfast and yes
indeed it is very early in the morning
but hey we're chill we're just chilling
uh
feel free to tune out and then back in
anytime you want i'll be here for a
while i'll be here for what the [ __ ] is
it i'll be here for uh
uh i would say a good eight hours
six and a half hours actually
uh
use parking lot snapping mod
uh i cannot uh i cannot download any new
mods now i would need to leave the game
i'm not going to do that
but
what is this american hotel looks nice
but i don't think i can use it yeah um
thanks for the tip
i'm not going to download any mods now i
think because it's
not
i don't want to take away
time from our
beautiful time together um
i'm looking for something like big ass
like big dumb commercial thingy
um
yeah let's see
oh we're gonna do the sports complex in
a bit
i got a bunch of also like some like
ussr assets
uh lying around what is this
a medium football stadium ah we can
actually um should should the uh for
what
what is this
anyway
should the football and sports just
what what is this
oh my okay
okay good oh nice um okay
so no suburb is complete without a
soccer mom
an army of soccer moms oh wait first we
need to fill this out with some
commercial stuff here
because
we we we want it
i don't want it
she is my queen oh [ __ ] season 8 i'm
still i'm still traumatized
by season 8
[ __ ] you dnd uh
how should we handle this
okay whatever okay and so city skylines
is not really flexible when it comes to
like uh
road placement and stuff like that so
we're going to take some liberties here
uh the point is that like we're we're
capturing the spirit
of a of a suburb here
so uh oh so see this kind of should be
really be updated like this like how old
is this game jesus [ __ ]
uh like it was came out in like
2004 i think
and sir dude for an update a tiny wooden
tree 20 euros thank you very much
greetings from vienna neighborino
well greetings to you
austrianino
uh long live the monarchy
uh
yeah so i'm actually actually in germany
but then again we are wait yeah yeah we
do have a common border even here in
germany so oh yeah what can you do
uh we're gonna put some commercial here
because
why not
oh
oh god i should have slept more but
whatever the show was going hey we have
some space here
yeah i think is i don't want to make it
too dense
like i instinctively want to make it
like okay let's let's use this space
uh let's use this space properly but
like no no
we should
drag things out a bit around the parking
lots i do want to cluster a bunch of
a bunch of
commercial
because okay i think this is
so far so good whatever like once again
this is just an illustration so don't
like don't add me i did not graduate as
a city planner
but uh
uh we're we're all about like we're all
about um the idea you know of uh
making it more
of a suburb oh [ __ ] now i have to
oh wait i can use uh-huh
i'm gonna just zone this whole [ __ ]
thing out for for uh
for residential
back then i had no idea i could do this
so back then i used to have this brush
and just like
just do everything like that
um
it was pretty bad anyway
so um
if you have a if this is also a q a
session as i said so if you want to ask
me something then just add me okay
uh we need to put down some
utilities though
so that our city will function happily
uh
but where should we do that
oh here okay this is gonna be just like
temporary
and next to no no next roads i will not
have i will not have residential because
fog density for now
uh yes
so
all right so once again if any questions
you might have then just either super
chat or at me so i'll see it
otherwise i'm concentrating on the game
and
i'll be done in a moment
and at that point we're gonna have the
poll
which uh
to like as in like should we fix it
right away or should i should i first
build the european suburb next to it and
so we can compare
um
so something opinion on turkey joining
the eu in the near future i think it
would benefit
all it's just a matter of whether turkey
can keep its democracy and he wants to
be a christian club yeah
uh the fact that like you know turkey is
muslim so you and then that's that's
that's a very much that's a very
conservative bent in in the eu i think
turkey like yeah i mean as soon as we
get rid of air we get rid of erdogan and
there's like some like
meaningful democratic safeguards in the
country then sure why not
um
yeah do you have roads without sidewalks
i don't think city skylines like i don't
i didn't download mods for that
uh
but bear with me this is this is a very
progressive suburb we have [ __ ]
sidewalks here
yeah
and um
you know this is just a power plant just
whatever place there so it will provide
arrived in no wires mode
we're going to arrange things
a bit later
this is also not nice i don't like this
ew density
super chat zoox
20 here in california usa cities like
san francisco have barely any parking
slash great walkability but people hate
these types of cities do you think this
is a symptom of the usa's obsession with
cars or are even these cities flood well
okay so san francisco
barely have any parking slash great
walkability
so they barely have any parking parking
and but they are very walkable um yeah
uh
depends on depends on how it's set up
you know like if you don't like if the
rest of the city is super car centric
everyone's gonna use cars
then of course everyone's gonna grumble
about like you know okay it's walkable
but you don't really use it as walkable
because you drive everywhere else so if
one neighborhood is very nicely walkable
but there's no parking spots then the
pressure coming from the other areas
which are very car centric i mean that's
gonna of course affect your area because
in those areas like everyone would want
to drive so they come into your
neighborhood
from the car centric areas and it's like
oh look there's no parking spots it's
walkable but but like your life is most
of most people's people's lives there
are not centered by walkability i would
imagine so that might be the problem
people actually like if if if
walkability is an alternative then then
people will very much
uh start walking
like you know they're gonna be walking
there
and but
otherwise i would say
just if it's it should be comprehensive
is what i'm saying
you know
uh let's see
more oh but a lot of people adding at me
if you don't mind where is the majority
of your audience from uh it's i think
the us obviously is number one in the uk
australia canada
germany even
sizable chunk of the audience
and yeah
you need a line of strip shops and big
box supermarkets and fast food
restaurants yes that's that's in the
works
do you have enough handicapped parking
to be ada compliant oh yes
uh
not yet adam what do you uh what do you
need to talk about why what did you do
in the checkerboard weekend why did you
move out
um
let's see well i
was i was just working in an office uh
mostly
uh i moved there because of my partner
and now we are also in germany because
uh
because of work mostly
uh yeah but like you know germany like
we're not like at the end of the world
like we are actually near the czech
border so we just like we can just like
go back whenever um
so
there's not much functional difference
between
our current
lifestyle and uh and living back in the
czech republic i can just you know take
a train and be there in an hour
uh let's see
how long do how long do you spend on
cities kind hands a day do you
and any other city uh
do you end any other cities kind of
youtubers well i don't spend that much
time nowadays uh i already have like i
think like a thousand four hundred hours
in the skylines nowadays i i've been
playing other stuff like surviving mars
that's super good i think except for the
end game like they probably should fix
the end game because this just doesn't
exist
um but um
yeah i've been playing that star sector
too like star sectors just niche
little but very nice very complex game
uh
done by like four people i think
uh yeah
so that's that's what i that's how i
spend my
epic gamer
dude bra time
uh see
no
whole bunch of people asking me jesus
christ um
so and something
in marin
county
north of san francisco we have a smart
train designed specifically for
commuters but it
stops before it gets close to san
francisco lol yeah
uh when you hear [ __ ] like
you know oh we have this smart train you
have this smart vehicle and it's like oh
okay
so then let's look at why it's [ __ ] all
right um
smart is usually just like uh
it's it's a euphemism basically for like
it's [ __ ] but
we're trying to make it look cool but
it's pretty [ __ ]
nonetheless
uh yeah
so uh
yeah careful with that
it might not be what you would expect
um let's see a bunch of ads uh do you
favor nuclear energy future energy
source to replace fossil fuels and the
renewables
um
nuclear i think should replace uh
fossils let's that's uh you know
it's an easy call to make i don't have
anything against uh
i don't think any i don't have anything
against nuclear i think it's safe uh as
long as you maintain it properly and
after fukushima there's plenty of
hysteria regarding nuclear i don't agree
with that i think nuclear should be part
of our
energy mix
under all circumstances
um yeah
but then again you know politicians will
politic and then you know
if shutting off nuclear power is
politically beneficial then they're
gonna do it usually
um in the past you mentioned writing
fiction and interest in writing about a
world that's made the changes you want
hours to do you think fiction plays a
role in achieving that change oh
that's a it's a
thank you that's uh i do actually
i'm meddling in fiction writing
currently i'm just like practicing and
whatever
um and like putting together
the outline and everything now
uh regarding that
i
uh what i would want to see actually
is um
is basically uh oh let's have a row
commercial here uh what i want to see
basically uh what
actually would be pretty cool is if
someone wrote they wrote a book
which is like
um
it's like it doesn't have to be like all
uh you know
all political
i don't really like that to use the term
in this context
but
it could be something like you know this
this book about this murder mystery
and it's like you know sherlock holmes
or whatever but it's it's just set in a
world where
for example socialism has been achieved
or you know in like a communist state or
something like a
like a like a
a state which fits the academic
definition
and uh
i think that would be awesome
if that we could we could uh
have that like the focus wouldn't be on
that it's just it's just um
it would be
basically
the backdrop of it and it's treated as
like a normal thing because right now
like we can't really imagine anything
beyond our current system i would say or
at least very very few people can so i
think the popularized popularized um
these these like left-leaning economic
ideas that would be very helpful uh wait
super chat from pranav uh
thank you very much what if anything
uh what if anything are you optimistic
about so what am i up to
um
i'm optimistic about um
a couple of things
actually lots of things like i think
i think about european rail in general
like i think i'm gonna have this video
at some point about like international
european rail which kind of sucks right
now but there's progress
uh i think
the i think left-leaning ideas will gain
more and more traction as time goes on
that's very nice
[Music]
and currently
there's an uptick in like far right
activity and stuff like that but that's
gonna that's gonna sort of
go down as time goes on i think that's
that's very nice
otherwise
yeah otherwise
i think the world will start moving into
the right direction soon
uh borg coitus
nice
nice name uh five dollars thank you very
much i paused my night of being drunk
and listening to princess chelsea for
this
here's some of my money well thank you i
hope
i
congratulate you on your sacrifice and i
hope it won't be in vain in the end
we need a what we need here by the way
is a
high school or elementary school i think
i have a suburban oh there we go
suburban elementary school oh it's so
[ __ ] horrible
uh let's put it
here does your partner share your views
on religious beliefs
i don't actually have religious beliefs
got me haha you little
you little whippersnapper
um
let's see although my my religion is is
basically you know decongestion so i
guess that's that's on me
uh
what do you think of about malaysian
rail i
don't i'm not familiar with malaysia i'm
sorry
um
am i weird for viewing the german empire
in a positive light well
uh i mean that's that's uh that's a
rather that's a broad statement you know
uh
viewing the german empire in a positive
light like i mean of course it had its
own like it had its positives obviously
as everything but i don't know like i'm
generally not a big fan of imperialism
you know so
what can you do
uh
like this oh yes
i think this parking lot might be a bit
small still but
uh we'll get we'll we'll get on it
uh let's see what's your take on the
outcome of the german election i think
it's better than it was
orban btfo would indirectly etc
so i'm actually happy about that um
i know something is part of the
cat cult religion oh that's true so i
believe in cats
and something what do you think on a
universal basic income would it be
feasible on a european level yeah i
think it would actually
uh what you need to pay attention to is
that it should not
replace
it should not uh replace
existing uh
should it be like this it should not
whatever it should not replace existing
uh
uh subsidies so what andrew yang wanted
for example is to like oh we're gonna
have this [ __ ] uh ubi and then it's
gonna
actually
uh it's gonna actually uh like uh
like so it's gonna be that and uh but
minus all your your your your assistant
social assistance that you get currently
which i think is dumb uh dietrich 30
bucks thank you are you familiar with
alden's number
oh yeah dude we're
we're all familiar with alden's number
uh that's what's my favorite number uh
there it is
yeah
fellow bosh vince here actually
i i don't know if i don't know uh
yeah yeah for him it's like me maybe
he's streaming actually
um
maybe he'll show up actually rm transit
said he would show up
uh hopefully he will
will be fun
um
oh no this this is too this is too
accessible no no um yeah and um
yeah actually walsh was my was was the
the i would say the main inspiration uh
to uh to start my channel actually or
like yeah him do not eat people like
this i was like yeah if they can do it i
can do it whatever
and i remember like i was on a train
where where else obviously and uh
and i was i was uh watching it was it
was at night i was going home
and i was watching
vasha's video about
how to get started on youtube
i did not have my channel back then i
was like hi okay
i'm gonna be a video essay as then
because he was talking about like you
know the different you know
how what video essays need to do etc was
like okay i'm gonna be a video essay
it's cool
and so a few months
later i started my channel a few weeks
actually and yeah it blew up uh once
again let me wait let me catch up on the
super chats
psychologic
hey ed i'm glad to catch
your stream and she is from france
sasha hey uh cheers back to you
my friend
cheers back i like the tjv
actually
the wall of trains you see behind me
is going to be supplemented rather soon
by
the og
orange dejeve a full dejeve set well
maybe not not full because i can only um
i don't know if if you can see it um
three four five six seven yeah it can
only accommodate like
uh eight cars plus a locomotive or
yeah um it's i i i built that shelf
actually myself
for it uh the idea is that like i had a
czech railways rail jet
uh like uh i wanted to together like a
full uh
set
that means one locomotive and eight cars
and for that i
i had to like uh
so the this shelf is designed around
that basically
but that's good because uh that means uh
like this that that most trains fit then
uh i i think actually i'm going to do a
train
uh train um
um
you know a train tour at some point
maybe on the second channel most likely
um
i have some trains
which i'm proud of actually wait you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna
uh
[Music]
resize obs for you so you can so you can
see the trains behind me a bit better
so i don't know if you can wait
which direction should i go
yeah i'm gonna just i'm gonna just do
this
so
as you can see i have a
bunch of
uh trains there like from mostly from
germany and from
some steam locomotives as you can see
and uh some old like electric logos
the big like the big chungus the the
gray one
in the top right corner is the
barish british one next to the lufthansa
express which is no longer in service
though below the below the gray one
that's that's something i'm proud of
actually that's a
czechoslovakian railways i think yes
what was it oh [ __ ] i forget
yes 400 something
uh and next to it is the hungarian
railways v63
uh that's that's my favorite like that
was like a super uh it was actually
pretty expensive but i think it's worth
it and below that is of course the rail
jet at some point i'm going to have a
full on
uh
train tour
so stay tuned for that i'm going to
resize myself
from
for now like this
uh right
but back to the back to the uh
hellscape construction over here
let's see
yeah i also use trains as a as this uh
essentially
like some people buy gold
and the idea is of course to uh to uh
you know to keep their money from
devaluing i buy trains
because these actually these actually
also don't devalue there's only a
there's only a limited amount of of uh
trains of a certain model and size are
made
so-called in so-called
epochs
and if you do if you do buy that then
then it's and then you basically got
something which is like limit in limited
supply already like will be
and uh
it will either keep its value or or
appreciate uh of course i'm not going to
sell them
only if i'm like okay if i either i
either i sell it or i starve
okay in that situation okay fine but uh
otherwise no
okay we have a suburban
elementary school here
wait let me catch up on the chat uh
we have time
yes
adam something is something a common
surname in europe
uh yeah um
when americans hear european surnames
they're like what was that
something
it's very common
um
let's see actually actually uh to share
some trivia with you i don't know are
there any polish viewers in in the chat
anyone from poland let me hear
let me hear the
polls
anyone
they don't seem to have any poll hacks
that's true too bad
or maybe the chat is just super delayed
anyway
to share some trivia with you
it's um
my like our
historical
family surname
um
used to be
which means
of course pancake in polish like my my
family uh part of my family is actually
from the the it's from today's ukraine
actually this is ancient like this is a
uh early
late 19th century basically
and um
that's where they're from
[ __ ] i'm trying to place this elementary
school some oh yeah here we go i'm gonna
put it here um yeah
so um there this is called
goran
people like gora which i think means
like mountain or like hill
they're from the mountains of the
carpathians
and uh anyway so that's that's that's
the family pancake
anyway
so um
boiler though of course
like always um
let's see uh once again let me keep up
with super chat
oh super chat now i'm sorry regular chat
but hey feel free to send super chats if
you want me to give you priority
uh how do you go about making an
efficient public transport system in an
archaeological arch
archipelago of city
like such as auckland which owners
requires multiple islands which makes
subway constantly expensive
uh
right well i don't have it in front of
me right now the whole city
you don't have to do
subways necessarily
um yeah but even if the city is divided
into like different satellites i think
this is also doable with like something
cheaper like just like a rapid bus
system on light rail or something
um
okay
what do you think of trams or light rail
well there are trains and they are based
as a result
uh what i meant was does your partner
agree with you or not you're not having
religious beliefs or do they think
otherwise
so how do you make it work
i mean where if you
refer to like traditional religion
religious beliefs like we're not
religious so you know
what do you think of trims like i
covered this already um oh we get two
super chats popping in one second
um
oh wait there's an interesting question
about it actually which which i'd like
to uh
um
respond you said in your community post
that you won't be directly responding to
videos debunking your quote unquote
can you respond to their points a little
in this stream it'll be super fun
uh i think
respond to the points sure um i am not
familiar with their points off the top
of my head although it's i mean it's
like an npc dialogue tree so it's not
you know it's not
too difficult to imagine but i just
don't want to misrepresent their points
um but sure hey if someone
someone asked me with with like
what they were saying
then and like summarizes it for me then
i'll be happy to respond actually i just
can't take the time right now like i i
don't really care
about about them like making the videos
like me iphone whatever
but um
but um
i cannot and i cannot really go from
this stream to be like okay let's let's
check out their videos and uh
respond to their points one by one i
think i think that would be waste of
time plus i think that would be an
irresponsible use of my platform to like
you know basically advertising their
channels on mine this would have worked
when i was uh when i was like a 30 000
subscriber channel
but then i made the dubai video and then
things changed
yeah so at this point like that's why i
made that post because like i do like i
have a huge reach at this point like not
huge but pretty big
and you know
if i
bump up like if i like uh
like these little channels of people
what lots of people don't don't
understand is that they are really
really like they they crave publicity
they crave the attention and then if you
give it to them then well they're going
to use it for bad outcomes or like bad
things such as proselytizing their
little [ __ ]
let me catch up on the super chats real
quick
let's see
um akislav 1990.
hi adam have you considered skopje
2014 that turned the city into
disneyland it combines your distaste for
nationalism better urbanism and even
orban
yeah scorpio that's macedonia oh yeah
yeah i know that oh [ __ ] didn't like
people like protesters then walk around
and like throw paint on
all that
[ __ ]
uh like that was built uh
the inner city was rebuilt it is like
historicist whatever
[ __ ] nightmare
and there's like a huge statue of
alexander the great yeah it's
nationalistic waving basically and it's
pretty stupid
oh
mkd so that's macedonian currency okay i
get it okay
okay panorama uh five australian dollars
like
a i think that's australian dollars or
whatever dollars whatever thank you
do you like the band cake and what car
do you own if you do own one
i never heard of the band cake and i i
don't own a car actually i don't
actually i don't need one
and
and uh
yeah so
uh i don't own a car and i don't need a
car at this point
uh
like at some point we at some point
though like i mean it's i guess it's
fine to own a car just don't overuse it
right so like i can i can fully
understand like if someone has one cool
just
it's it's very different you if you use
a car for
a daily commute
and it's also different if you uh
if you uh
like use it for like emergencies like if
you have children and you know it's you
know 3am countryside and they get sick
or something and you have to just haul
them to the doctor or something then
it's you know whatever i can i get it
uh like i'm i'm not like 100
full-on car absolutist whatever but it's
you know
oh let's have a track and field for this
goddamn school
um
yeah so
so yeah i'm i'm not like a car
absolutist so don't worry um more super
chats
um joshua bateman have you ever heard of
christian identity if not you should see
it's absolutely crazy
christian identity like is it is it one
of those like
i identity
europa types you know the
identity
of europa like i keep seeing those
[ __ ] ah they're pretty cringe
if it's that then um then um yeah it's
pretty dumb
oh baseball field that's what we need
um
so yeah
i if that's what you're referring to
then i have heard of it i guess that
it's dumb
but uh
if not then feel free to feel free to
follow follow up on that
let's see out back red uh thank you for
wait did i miss anything
yeah no okay good so i'll be right thank
you for the six bucks hello i don't
watching from australia so there is
australian that was good
uh
i found you from i found you from your
dubai finally someone who hates it as
much as i do keep up the great trains
for life well thank you uh indeed i
agree
um
let's see wait adam something
were you the guy making those videos in
cities skylines building like american
settlements and forts with the history
behind it or am i mixing everything um
i did something similar but you might
also be mixing me up with do not eat
like do not eat was
this
i think i think most people you know do
not eat from here but yeah
wait let's first let let me just uh
do this sports complex now
yeah so do not eat was the one was the
og who actually started the the uh
the um
this like serious skyline serious stuff
when he talks about politics and
planning he was also like a major
inspiration so like
my
inspirations to start what i do was
basically like doing a teeth wash
um
yeah
people like them
let's see
do you know california city never heard
of it
see what do you think of the sp uis and
how
how can i make good highway
infrastructure because
mine keeps backing up at the diamond
intersections i think it's too dense
i don't know about that unfortunately
don't forget the mega church on a second
oh yeah that's coming what do you think
of
no that's covered it
okay uh obama news
spuis what's what's an spui though i
think i'm not really well versed on
these like american
i mean i assume american
abbreviations
uh
let's see
we need
to build
a
horrifying
sports complex monstrosity like this
and it's gonna be like it's gonna look
like this
uh let's see we're gonna have like
four baseball fields here because [ __ ]
it
uh
hey yeah that's that's how that's how
this looks right um
yeah now we're going to do this like fan
motive of like going like this this this
okay
is this is this line like you know well
uh-huh
no there we go
and um
v what do you think about the v4 uh it's
hopefully it'll be dead soon that's the
vicious for that like i i believe i
assume that's what you're referring to
that's the smooth brain smooth brain
alliance between like poland hungary
slovakia and uh
the czech republic now the czech
republic is out now which is nice
um
but um
poland and hungary are still going
strong unfortunately it's this like you
know at no nationalist you know blood
and soil union of like european
politicians
uh which ah yeah i [ __ ] hate it
okay let's let's have some additional
we're just gonna we're just gonna like
uh with little regard to like actual
placement we're just gonna
put some [ __ ] here
um
i know something do you want to know the
worst part of the lack of trains used
for public transportation in america we
have the base for infrastructure yes you
do actually i think in in the in the u.s
the u.s has i think better
freight
rail statistics than europe
so the us
has actually
yeah
they move more wares
on the road on the on railroads like on
on rail than europe
uh if i if i remember correctly you can
correct me you could correct me uh if
i'm wrong on that
yeah
okay this needs parking lots
yeah
yeah so i think i think it's it comes
down to financing i don't know how the
as far as i know the us doesn't have
this like european style
finance oh that's nice european-style
financing for their public transit
systems the thing about that um
that's actually um
that would be super important
to uh
to get that going
because financing like uh
what did what do i think of death
penalty i oppose it
uh
actually a very very important aspect
of public transit is public financing
people forget that often like you cannot
really do
a good
for-profit public transit system right
like it's just not really possible
and
and
so the european financing model
right now is that
a city orders a public transit service
from a proper provider usually state
could be private and the point is that
they are paid after passenger kilometers
so for example
uh you have a
you have a uh
you know a line and you say okay i want
i want to run x amount of uh
trains on this like so you right so you
announce the competition and then you
say okay for each passenger kilometer
i'm offering
to pay i don't know
like 10 euros or something and just just
turn into a number and so passenger
kilometer means a kilometer traveled by
the uh the uh
kilometers traveled by
the uh
the rolling stock in passenger service
as far as i know
like i'm i'm not a financing expert i
just know i'm just aware of how these
things work and um
that way actually that it's that's why
actually the investors etc or providers
can
can
really
can really uh um
plan with this
like plan around it like uh because like
of course getting rolling stock
um
and uh
and uh you know sort of planning for
this et cetera i mean it's pretty
difficult so with this system in place
you can kind of just uh
help providers plan out their service
it's gonna be more comprehensive it's
going to be better it's going to work
better
because they know what to expect from
you financially
and it's a it's a done deal
and
the thing is though like in the us it's
very often for-profit
which is not you know like public
transportation should not be for-profit
i would say just like how healthcare
shouldn't be for-profit
uh so
i think
because i mean i think
uh just like healthcare and housing
and access to water and food and
whatever like those are those should be
basic human rights and i think access to
transportation
should also be a basic human right
because i mean it's without
transportation you're [ __ ] like what
are you gonna do like without
transportation you're basically living
in the middle ages
uh you can
visit the
areas where
which you can reach and like that's it
like on photo or by horse or something
or by bike anyway you're severely
limited
and actually this is something that
capitalists should also be
on board with because uh
because like a workforce which is
healthy
mobile
and uh
that that's just a more productive
workforce you know
but of course that's not the case
they're not really favorite david cat is
thank you for the thousand foreign
hungary uniforms do you think we will
ever get rid of orban or we'll have to
wait till we die till he dies and we die
we'll see
no um i think there's a good chance of
uh marquis oy the new opposition
candidate defeating orban
in uh in next spring we'll see
um it would be nice uh
if not then
i guess not
but uh there's significant sort of voter
fatigue with urban at this point which
is good plus it's pretty hard like you
know they've been in power for what
how long
um
since 2010 so it's been 11 years of war
bond so the problem is like
everything they say now
everything they accuse the opposition of
now
like i think they accuse them with it's
like
like yeah if they point like they can't
really point at stuff and say see it
didn't doesn't work
you know
this is opposition it's like dude you've
been in power for [ __ ] 12 years like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
what do you mean is the opposition's
fault like who's been in power since
2010
and uh yeah
that's a big difficulty and like also
the problem is that in hungary right now
the political elite it has been sort of
has sort of changed a bit so
within fides within urban's party
because back in the day you know there
was a team which won
so that team you know people sometimes
just want to catch a break and they they
sort of rotate in and out of power and
at that point it was that of like
the original team is out
and uh there's this new team now
but their problem is they're so the good
thing for us is that they're so [ __ ]
incompetent and the problem is even
within fida circles there's grumbling
that like okay this is not good like the
new people they actually believe the
[ __ ]
like uh with infidels everyone like it's
it's this within higher circles this is
an unspoken rule that like yeah okay
we
fee we we give people the [ __ ] but
but like yeah well i mean of course of
course without [ __ ] kidding me of
course like george soros took over the
european commission like whatever
but the new
guys who are in charge of the propaganda
outlets everything they many of them
actually believe this [ __ ]
which is which is an issue see because
um
like their craziness is actually a
detriment of their competence
and um
oh god that like a very good
illustration of this is this new [ __ ]
billboard campaign because in hungary
there's always [ __ ] billboard
campaigns
uh
and the
latest like we had stuff like
uh
you should also know about the shorosh
plan how george soros
is planning to take over europe through
it which is which is just a jewish
question you know just with more word
um
and you know people know george george
is jewish and hungary so like you know
that's that's like an easy dog whistle
but like the latest billboard campaign
is
like hungary goes forward
not backwards
i'm i'm i'm not kidding like this this
is it
uh that really is it
let me show you first of the
uh
first of the george george billboard it
was pretty pretty [ __ ] disturbing
actually
um
there we go
and there we go it's uh
don't let shorosh have the last laugh
and someone helpfully already
like
wrote a [ __ ] david star there
here we go this stinking jew in
hungarian
uh
there's some
now i do surely
with some with some uh strategic some
2017. this is some strategic
some strategic uh editing
um
we shouldn't let there be aq on the
toilet
yeah so
anyway
yeah so this this was this short
campaign this is the uh
national consultation about the shorosh
plan
let's
not leave it unsaid or like i don't know
how it's a let's say something about it
you know
i know here's oh here's oh this is fun
the uh
the um
jean-claude juncker the old i think was
the european commissioner uh you also
have the right to know what brussels is
preparing
it's uh
it's pretty [ __ ] disturbing actually
like these billboards were all over the
place like seriously
um
every single [ __ ] place
uh because of course every everyone
everything is owned by
also in the subway like
in 2017 is [ __ ] nuts like
everywhere where these [ __ ]
billboards non-stop you you you drove
down the highway it's [ __ ]
dietrich twenty dollars
well that's how his name is pronounced
george soros would be of course the
i don't think oh here's here's the
billboard of like with all the
opposition heads
uh
they would
they would uh
demolish the border wall together
whatever
so
oh yeah did this stop the
stop shot or shot is the stop sorrows
uh campaign
would
uh settle
in millions from africa and from the
middle east
stop sorrows
yeah so which is i mean this is this is
the jewish question like um
because the the normal
the normal uh uh uh
like normal the usual
uh stuff is that like oh you know uh the
jews want to
or you know hey wait okay for this topic
i'm gonna i'm gonna get on my pewdiepie
accent to be like you know to be
authentic
these juice
so uh nazi said like these jews
they want
to
settle in
arabs and brown people from the middle
east and africa and it's not epic
for the revenge
against
for the holocaust
subscribe to pewdiepie
and of course this is exactly the same
thing in hungary like the [ __ ]
shorosh plan the stop servers like yeah
except
the leadership knows it's [ __ ]
everyone knows it is
however the problem is that
the problem is that any thoughts on
elden ring i
looks good i have not played not not
really that i will i think
so the thing is
people in the previous hungarian
leadership used to not believe this book
i was like yeah okay i mean of course
we're just [ __ ] like
producing some like militarized grandmas
here
uh who yeah who they don't go on to
[ __ ] social media to comment about
how we should [ __ ]
uh
murder immigrants and like
machine gun them machine gun their boats
into the sea and everything and it's
pretty disturbing but yeah but they were
like yeah dude of course it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] they're kidding me
and then but then there's the new
guardian with infidestry in oregon's
party who actually does believe this
[ __ ] which is kind of concerning
and that's why you have the uh
that's why you have these new uh
beautiful billboards in hungary
of um
one sec
uh
let me just look it up for you guys
so this is the this is the
latest
um
wait where is it [ __ ] where's the
billboard um
oh there we go there we go wait
let's
there we go
um okay
so this is the uh
this is the um the billboard this
picture has like five pixels nice
can i open the image in youtube yeah
okay now
[ __ ] it's a facebook whatever no here it
is here it is
why do these
okay better uh okay so this billboard
hungary goes forward
not backwards like
okay
hungary goes forward
forwards not backwards
nice
oh soy clap you know uh
but the thing is though
um
in hungary in hungarian no and not are
the same words
and people actually have been
vandalizing these billboards to like
they put a comma next to like after the
no here
and then uh
then the billboard becomes hungry goes
forward no backwards
so
and this is this is the [ __ ]
this is the [ __ ] uh uh um
you know nivo right now on which the the
hungarian leadership operates which is
pretty [ __ ] sad but it's also good
it's also good because um
because uh like this is sort of
i mean
the the least competent they are we
would argue like the the better
the opposition's chances are and this is
not about like left versus right at this
point this is just like
far right versus everyone who will
oppose it
um let's see
uh i know something what music do you
like and
as per your single point urban
intersections are okay what music do i
like uh i like uh smash mouth like
basically i listen to the shrek osd
non-stop for 20 hours a day
the there's hunger there's the hungarian
two-tailed dog party which frequently
vandalizes government
sort of propaganda
propaganda
i guess billboards and everything
they're funny i like them although i
don't really like them in a sense that
uh
that they have been
oh look at this placement city skylines
damn um i don't really like them now
like i don't really appreciate their
activism now because now that there's a
now that there's a chance for the
opposition to actually [ __ ] win
uh
they did not withdraw their candidates
so and the two-tailed party it's joke
party obviously like not a serious
another serious thing the problem is
that they might actually capture the
disaffected youth
vote
um
in the country which is no that's that's
not good like the we
the whole strength
of uh
like what we basically need is is is
less
like is all the disaffected people
voting for for the opposition
uh
but and not like peace and their votes
not be siphoned away
by
uh
this joke party because hey i mean if
the joke party hell like okay we're
we're anti orban we're anti old
political lead
but even the old political elite is
better than orban so like
if if you
if you uh
if through your activism we are we are
left with warba once again for four more
years and i mean
then i'm sorry like it's it's not it's
not so [ __ ] funny anymore you know uh
super chat d trick 20 uh dollars again
thank you very much plus one for smash
mouth astrologe was the best album
i think shrek was the best album
actually
yeah but
but yeah i
i listen to them on enough actually
uh i'll be right back i need to take a
break uh to the toilet and i also need
to turn on the heating is freezing here
uh so be right back you guys i'm gonna
maybe i'll find a cat well you know what
i'm gonna i'm gonna leave you with the
cat here so she'll entertain you while
i'm gone
wait was the kitty visible at all
[Music]
yeah she was good
all right
jesus christ it's 9 30 and they're
already whining at me holy [ __ ]
they're hungry
no
kitty kitty
oh
double kitty
hell yeah
how are you guys doing
what's up kitties
um
all right it's time to
time to continue but my hands are full
unfortunately
all right if you go
youtube is my mic on it should be on
alright
so
uh
hello to all you newcomers
uh people are tuning in and out of
course the time zones
uh as the time zones shift people are
waking up people are
falling asleep what are they what are
the kitties names uh
george orlando and garfello
hmm
all right
oh [ __ ] god made man i like it
all right so what we're gonna what we're
doing here
is um
we are uh building a suburb
an american suburb with all the worst
practices there are like little like
we're
we're building we're reconstructing hell
right now
and then we're going to fix it
start to finish
and the idea is that
a city actually i'm going to put up a
second highway here
a city is situated somewhere here and
i'm going to put him put in some like
more road connections and everything so
it will be more apparent
um
uh yes and uh adam you should know that
you're very handsome good night oh thank
you again good night to you too my
equally handsome friend
uh so
um
right there's gonna be a little
bit of a lull period in the stream i
would say in terms of viewers i think
because as americans go to sleep
and as europeans wake up
so you know
i'm afraid like as as this as this
process goes on there's going to be like
a winning round about here uh as this
process goes on like i don't know
i'm actually a bit worried that like
when the one like european audience
wakes up and like it's they realize that
it's like
there's
a like
they see that this is about like ngos
helping roma and everything but
um i'm low-key where i'm low-key worried
about that there's gonna be a lot of
like blood and soil [ __ ] going on
uh
i don't i don't want to underestimate my
fellow fellow europeans in this
uh did you see have you seen the george
shine show propaganda ads
like
why would you ask me that
of course i [ __ ] saw them they're
everywhere oh my god like if you're
hungarian
and you have your your setup has
anything to do with hungary like
uh
you know you had hunger and localization
or like you you use a hungarian mobile
internet uh
thinking then then like
you're just [ __ ] bombarded by these
advertisements by the [ __ ] hungarian
government
uh
it's like it's pretty it's pretty insane
actually i [ __ ] like i go back to
hungary to visit my parents i open
youtube and every [ __ ] advertisement
is that it's just like pro-government
[ __ ] and like oh
my my brain hurts
oh batu unlu thank you for the turkish
lira i believe check out california city
in google images
uh
california city
like do you mean like california or
is it something in turkey or something
or what's the
california city oh i see like a pictures
of a [ __ ] ghost town
i see
huh well
yeah i mean we pretty much have
california city here for now just only
only like uh
uh
only with like less grass basically
i'm getting these [ __ ] german
in california city the drip grew
californians lived combined
yeah
anyway yeah i mean utopian visions but
like the road layout is kind of sassy
already so i think they just wanted a
[ __ ] suburb
um
anyway
back to the
city building
yeah around about how american uh
yakupromets thank you for a thousand
crowns i really appreciate it
uh let's see david gorman
uh i'm from ireland living in north but
applies everywhere
no if you're living look david i'm going
to share something with you if you live
in northern ireland
you are living in ireland
so
stay mad boris
where is johnson anyway um
i'm from ireland living north but
everywhere and public transport and
urban sprawl are so bad here for a
european country dublin's first metro
line still in planning stage since 2000
uh
yeah wait so do you live in you use
british pounds there so i assume it is
northern ireland okay yeah yeah i mean
what can you do
yeah
yeah i should probably look look at it i
i'm very distrustful of like
anglo-oriented urban planning in general
uh but like uh
so you know
stuff that like like inside europe stuff
that stuff is going on in like the uk
and whatnot like i'm generally skeptical
there have been some good measures in
london you know the
in london there have been some pretty
cool initiatives by the mayor sadiq khan
uh who's probably a short agent and he's
just kidding um
and um yeah
i really like those
otherwise
hmm we should probably need some kind of
like
i don't know
something here we'll we'll we'll get on
it
yeah anyway uh brit mongers um skeptical
about their urban planning especially
since stature
the country that gave us margaret
thatcher because [ __ ] me um
so joshua bateman 999 thank you very
much i live in the united states and
it's 3 40 where i'm at i'm sacrificing
sleep just to watch this law well thank
you very much
you don't have to by the way if you want
to you can feel free to go to sleep i'm
going to put this stream
uh up on my youtube channel
and actually i'm going to clip this
maybe if there's something like some
like workable segment uh
[Music]
if some workable segment comes out of
this and i'm gonna put it on my on my
secondary channel
remove that roundabout immediately yeah
uh we're we're european now now actually
some some american cities also do
roundabouts there's i've heard this one
city where there's like the mayor has
this [ __ ] ground about fetish
where it's like everything is just
[ __ ] round about
yeah anyway
boomers what can you do
uh
okay let's do the double
how does this work
same as selected
wait
like
this um
let's see
okay good we're gonna have it like this
uh but i need to like
change the uh
and i'll need to change the uh the
directions but that's okay
okay
and okay so we're gonna have this road
here
connect
oh that's some that's some nice
uh okay we're gonna fix the fix set in a
bit in a moment
and i don't know if we can do a
does it connect
no
uh i'm gonna add some outside notes
there or something or have these two
rows converge here um
okay
uh
australia has lots of roundabouts yeah i
mean i can imagine
you are more european
oriented i would say afterwards after
all
like this
like this and like this uh yeah
uh what the [ __ ] is this oh no no okay
uh
something like this yeah
yeah love to love to take a 25 degree
[ __ ] uh
slope uh
jacob young man 20 thank you very much
where are the
intrusive off-ramps
soon these are just strodes for now so
there's no need for off-ramps
so yeah
for now nope uh i mean there's we got
some interchanges here for now i think
that's you know
but uh
wait let me just see um
i got i got a i get a
uh suburb open on my other uh screen
yeah this doesn't seem to have any again
it has of course the clover leaf and
everything uh here and there
but um
oh wait they actually [ __ ]
i might have to
i might have to uh
scratch that no no like
okay anyway i'll i'll try to get on it
in a moment but i have a couple of
interchanges here
uh and the problem is i don't want to do
too much because then then
it would take a long time to fix okay i
think actually but i think uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna put up one more and what i'm
trying to accomplish here i'm gonna put
up one more
uh sort of commercial district here
and uh
which is this
which is going to be this area like uh
you know like this this is also this
also happens in europe which i really
[ __ ] hate
it's like uh you have this you have a
city and then next to the city is this
there's this like big [ __ ]
uh
like
uh
commercial area
with like you know everything like media
marks tesco whatever and like it's next
to the city
this big [ __ ]
essentially like a huge strip mall
kind of thing with a gigantic parking
lot
uh ikea and whatever is that oh yeah i
should do an ikea ikea is there and what
not and um
it's just incentivizes people so hard
to to
to this like car centric lifestyle
because
everything you buy there everything you
get there you i mean you can forget
[ __ ] public transit dude like
if you go that far you're gonna buy a
lot to buy lots of things already
because you're making the effort already
but uh
if um
but like that's that's uh
and that's that's cars right like
there's oh wait no that's not good um
and you know you're gonna be using cars
like if you go to the you go to the edge
of town
and uh and um
you know because there's this big
[ __ ] compound
uh
then
you are not going to just
let's see yeah so um at that point like
if you if you buy something there from
like a year or something then you know
you have to have your car because what
like are you gonna buy like transport
your [ __ ] furniture
uh back on the bus where you won't even
fit like come on
uh
ideally ideally there should be like a
delivery service i heard vienna did a
very nice project like like the
ikea in vienna that uh
the whole the whole concept of the story
is that you go there on foot you arrive
on foot
and uh and uh like the whole delivery
service is already set up it's handled
for you
and uh you don't need a car to shop in
this ikea which i think i think that
like that should be done i can't
i want it's so [ __ ] bad because
because it's it's a i as much as i like
ikea
it's a pain in the ass to shop there
yeah that's how that's how bridges are
done right
um
it's a [ __ ] pain in the ass to shop
there because
if you get something then then you also
have like the old shopping experience is
also like tainted by this okay like how
the [ __ ] am i going to
how the [ __ ] am i going to uh
um you know
transport all this [ __ ] home basically
and well
you know i actually have done the public
transit way you know just like get on
the tram get on a train and then they
they think take thing things home with
that
but it's it's i mean
you know if i'm some kind of car centric
person or like even if i have like a
fleeting
um
idea of like huh maybe i should be more
environmentally conscious with that
amount of logistics that that whole
requires i mean that's that's where my
that's where my my environmentalist
ideas end
basically because it's so [ __ ]
just annoying
um
to do those things
and
which you know i i'll i'll do it because
i mean i don't know i don't own a car i
don't want to like for me actually
uh
arranging a car
delivery like privately would be much
more hassle
but uh
yeah
uh but but i i can certainly see why
like people look at their car owners who
have everything at the disposal
and then they go nope i'm i'm i'm not
[ __ ] thinking what are you crazy i'm
[ __ ] taking the bus with a tram like
what so i can just get so i get to like
stand around with [ __ ] furniture
among passengers like whatever
so yeah
this and this is what we're recreating
now
uh
yeah actually prague also has these
things if you can believe that like
prague is generally thought to be very
very very like an archery arch european
city
um
and even they have this like gigantic
[ __ ] like strip mall
uh
next to the strip malls next to next to
the city and actually i can show it to
you
let's see
um
actually one i went to uh when i went to
is is the uh
wait satellite
frog
so here there's a map of prague
and um for example yeah the the the when
you find the [ __ ] ikeas then you're
you're you see the
uh yeah so this thing
like okay so here's the city there's
some like
residential areas here
uh that's the inner city and you go out
all the way here to the side
and here's the highway the program road
and
here's the [ __ ]
zlichin metropole thingy
um which is just part of it actually
uh here's the
the globe was the ikea like
yeah it's just this i mean it's it
doesn't have quite as many parking lots
as in the us
as you can see but it's still pretty bad
and uh to walk here like there's
actually a metro stop here here this is
lychee metro stop
uh which i uh which i took
because i wanted to go to ikea
and to get from this [ __ ] thing
to ikea
like it was okay i'm gonna demonstrate
the the
i'm going to show you what i did
there's
there's [ __ ] um
street view here okay so
what i did was what you do
is uh
where was it [ __ ]
so here's your um
okay that's ikea
uh you get off the metro
oh we're going
2 meters per
hour nice um so you get off the metro
and what you do is
you go
here so that's the metro you go kind of
under this and you go out and you go
there like is this there's the
metropolis
and pole means i think fields so you
know it's like a play on words and um
i i thought first that okay i'm gonna
cross here i went through this sidewalk
i crossed there to the mall because ikea
is
there kind of
so i was like okay i'm gonna go there
and i went
so basically here i came through here
and i started walking and i
came here
here and i was like [ __ ]
like this this is a dead end
um
and then i so like once again i wanted
to get in here
like on foot this is like this would be
like five to ten minutes maximum and so
uh i walked here
no not here
but here i was like okay this is a dead
end what the [ __ ] do i do okay i went
back
and then i went double back all the way
here
and then i took this
foot bath i guess
and i and here so i was i actually had
to like do this like whole uterine or
whatever the [ __ ]
uh to walk
uh here on on this [ __ ]
sidewalk here
and uh
i went
i crossed here
which is like what how many [ __ ]
crosswalks was this
like i saw ikea there right uh so
here it was
i crossed
uh
one two three
four five six crosswalks
most of them with their individual
traffic lights which you have to push
and yeah it's nice oh nice it has the
[ __ ] bike lane thingies yeah like if
you feel like dying feel free to cycle
here
so hey
so i um
walked here
okay so let's let's go ikea i walk down
here
here
across the bridge
and
and
and
[ __ ]
the the cyborg just [ __ ] ends right
and this this is a highway uh
interchange so
so uh
we this is what i really find
interesting about prague you have all
this
uh
pretty good infrastructure uh
generally but sometimes just like it
just [ __ ] ends and it's like
okay what do i do here
so my options was like
actually like why do you have the
this built out here
if it just doesn't lead anywhere you
know
uh so
i was stuck here like okay what do i do
here i hear my
and
this is where i want to go
and this is a four no actually yeah it's
a four lane highway interchange right
so what i did was what people here do
apparently
um
you
walk here in the dirt actually let's
switch sides
you walk here in the dirt kind of
you stop here
this might actually be from people
standing here this spot
and when you don't see any cars coming
there's the there's the uh
the barrier ends here
and then
you sprint across that there's even like
a little footpath here and as you can
see here too because people have been
using this as a [ __ ]
escape route and you end up in the
mcdonald's parking lot here
they drive through from where you kind
of like walk through the drive through
and then you
and then there is [ __ ] ikea and with
the prog bus
and then there's [ __ ] ikea and then
from here from the mcdonald's you have
to
also
like since you're here you're going to
go back there so you're going to
cross these like three lanes
here and then just like cross through
the parking lot
diagonally and then
and then there's ikea
so
it this is this is [ __ ]
yeah
so the
these [ __ ] strip malls at the edges
of cities are literally the worst and
especially if the local city leadership
doesn't doesn't give a [ __ ] oh actually
i i i can show you something else if
since we're doing uh the prague trip
already
a place i used to live in
uh
i used to live in here in in atapi
there's this big
residential area i used to live in a
comic block here somewhere
and
this [ __ ] like
just just just to top it off with a
quick sidewalk watch episode
uh
you know i was i was walking down oh
yeah beautiful
arterial road
because you know [ __ ] it
and
[ __ ] the truck anyway i was walking down
here because i went to the gas station
because there's like this post pickup
thingy and then the sidewalk ends there
it's like what do you do
um see if we can take a look yeah like
there's this sidewalk which like i
wanted to go here
but the sidewalk kind of ends
here-ish
so you have to like go [ __ ] jungle
diving uh to reach your destination
uh but at least hey i'm glad there is
like
like i don't know how much how much is
this like uh you know
five lanes of [ __ ] traffic there to
accommodate the driver
anyway
probably sometimes funny and yeah
it really matches the theme you know rib
walk ability
so
yeah
anyway it's it's uh it's ass obviously
and
and we're going to replicate this exact
thing now and then we are going to fix
it so
um
unfortunately this kind of doesn't
really
doesn't really let you manage how uh
manage sidewalks like that and plus i
think it will be too small so we need to
really zoom in to
keep track of what we're doing so uh
anyway
okay club mate done
i really [ __ ] like club mate it's a
i don't it's a german thing as far as i
can tell it's super good it's a ton of
caffeine in it
and lord knows i need it right now
so let's get that strip mall going let's
rev up those strip malls
actually i'm going to
turn this into a strode for now because
to like
allow like a
yeah to allow like a more uh
smooth transition into
our little strip mall our little
whatever
oh you're i'm super early my family is
mostly bohemian which is czechia so it's
that's cool oh yeah it is cool i don't
know if you can hear the kitty is
chasing
this little
toy ball
on the ground now
i hope it's not too disturbing otherwise
i can i can discipline the kitty no i'm
just kidding
uh let's see
so here we have this thing
uh
that's the high school
uh yeah so this kind of only lets you
play place these things once but that's
what
people made this thing for
there we go
uh i'm just gonna put it here for now
and we are going to get into
hmm
lucas 82 pounds they aren't all banned
look at the trafford center
um
okay one sec
trafford center i mean uh sure and not
all all of these like
uh centers are bad obviously
uh my problem is that they are usually
situated at the edge of the [ __ ] city
and there's not much
like how do you reach that you know i
like car most likely
oh uh jacob beer thank you very much for
the uh hundred dollar donation run
across five lanes of traffic you'll
figure it out
uh at least it's better than than the
states see you later love yeah oh well
love you too uh yeah i mean of course
this is european problems strictly like
uh
um in the in the us i would be running
across like a 25 lane freeway and then
die halfway through so you know
yeah but
of course but of course like your our
problems are always always
[Music]
curious our problems are like the
perception of our problems always depend
on uh on our personal situation so what
might be oh damn city skylines look at
this beautiful
uh
anyway uh so uh the perception of your
problems always depends on your like
your subjective situation so for example
uh
a a an american might look at prog and
be like oh my god this is transient
heaven and i might look at prague and be
like oh there's still lots of things to
do
you know
uh in terms of like
building a livable city there
um
let's see i do have an ikea actually i
think i think i had one
yeah
it's a little baby ikea that's fine um
i i accept it i accept
um
can this can i
ah
kind of works no i need to move this a
little bit
uh okay
oh hang on a second
what are you doing
kitty
how are you
what is all this noising huh
i'm not mad i'm just disappointed
nah it's like actually
she's a good kitty
she's one of the most well behaved she's
also very intelligent she actually
learned how to
open all my drawers
uh
just like that like within within days
so or weeks or other
yeah
so this is a this is actually a
norwegian forest cat uh
so uh kitty calm down i know you want to
play go
yeah they have some yeah like it's it's
there apparently there was some kind of
like norwegian forest cats
out there in the uh
in the wilds in the czech republic and
then
you know uh it's reproduced with like a
with like a uh
normal sort of domestic kit
and then we have these then these two
like there was like i think like four of
them originally but two of them died or
well maybe something like that
and um
yeah
too bad
and um
yeah
but they're actually pretty rare like a
rare breed
but they were of course strays so they
came from a
kitty shelter
yeah
let's let's put down that that small
ikea now because yeah
i i had like a proper big ikea i don't
know it's uh you know it's so [ __ ]
big
um
i don't know where it is i think it was
the manheim ikea anyway little scenic
tiny small
smells
like here let's let's have another thing
too the other uh
building
this one right here
and we're gonna
well rip snapping i guess
uh yeah
figure out in a moment
okay
uh in my hometown they once had trolley
buses when i was about five then they
replaced with natural gas for no good
reason now they replaced them with
battery powered ones oh the battery
powered saga off [ __ ] thank you for
reminding me no i i will
i will actually uh
put out the response video at some point
for that
um it's uh
yeah it's in the works
uh first i'm gonna do the the egyptian
stuff uh
where i'm going or i am going to be
walking like an egyptian
uh
but yeah the electric bus thing uh the
electric bosses are not
bad per se like i still favor them over
cars
uh my my problem with that
with them really is that uh um
the problem with that with them is that
like we have better or better
alternatives and so we're we're once
again trying to reinvent the wheel
and uh you know
try to uh
like it's basically it's battery totally
buses like there are just
essentially
um
um electric buses with more like
overhead charging and smaller batteries
which i do believe is
is the future like they they
because of their setup they don't
they are not plagued by all those
problems
electric bosses are played with like you
know if
the weather gets cold
then suddenly your fleet can run since
like okay
um
that's that's not good probably uh
and when it gets too hot you know when
you turn on the ac
when you turn on the heating because of
course your uh your uh
your uh heating will have to run from
something or run off of something and
it's most likely going to be
um
like the battery life what else you know
um
in budapest there were there used to be
some like small electric buses
here and there uh usually moving to the
castle now they they and of course and
they were [ __ ] and they were
decommissioned after like a year or two
years or something
but um
the way they solved the [ __ ]
heating problem meaning that like the
battery needs to like heat up the entire
into interior plus run the bus which is
the way they sold it was that the buses
had an oil radiator in them or like a
little little uh oil stove i think
and so the bus was like [ __ ] smoking
in winter like it was
you're like [ __ ] stupid
but yeah i mean this this really
demonstrates the uh
the problem with these with these uh
electric buses namely that like
okay so now you cause yourself
wait isn't it commercial
like now you you've caused yourself all
these problems for no reason
congratulations and now you're now you
have to solve them in a dumb way
uh
instead of
just what like building out some
overhead wires
to the buddha castle
uh which didn't happen back then that
was the plan actually but the bus lobby
ironically was too strong
and uh
and uh then it became like okay we're
just gonna we're just gonna do what
buses because [ __ ] it
um of course the bosses the the those
those uh the so-called midi busses
meaning like the eight meter long buses
eight to nine meters the regular buses
are like 12 meters long and then the
articulator is 18 um usually
the midi buses were [ __ ]
unreliable broke down
and they looked like [ __ ] death
already after like i don't know how many
years of service it was bad all around
people are like okay [ __ ] it let's let's
do something else and they were like oh
what do we do well electric bosses and
then okay whatever it it sucked it was
bad
f
no one misses them
and uh
yeah but i mean of course there are some
good electric buses
here and there uh but the thing is
like even those good electric buses uh
it's once again like this is once again
this this like uh uh occam's razor
situation where like okay we can do this
ultra complicated [ __ ]
uh
[ __ ] uh
uh
okay we're gonna have to design the
batteries so that you know we're gonna
have to come up with engineering
solutions so that the battery doesn't
run out in the cold way in cold so it's
cold resistant heat resistant it can run
the heating it can run the and the the
ac
it'll
it'll you know operate on a on a sort of
re at a reasonable
um
you know
efficiency even in in case of like highs
like steep slopes heavy passenger load
etc etc plus we have to factor in you
know buses these buses don't always just
run um
uh with passengers so you know if you if
and and uh
so if the bus needs suddenly charging on
the route and but you don't have time
how do you figure how do you do that you
need additional buses
and
all the the thing is they're like this
can be like once again as with every
gadget bond these problems can largely
be figured out
the problem is like why why would you
want to
sort of
why would you want to try
why do you want to try if there are
better solutions like hey
what if we we made the [ __ ] battery
smaller
and then we just
and then we just
you know
have more overhead wires
like
whatever
like yeah
why let's do that huh
uh but i feel like lots of people are
have this like
weird
emotional attachment i guess to electric
buses
like for example like like eev blog i
mean i i like the dude
i've never really talked to him in
person or privately
but uh i think he has some sort of like
emotional attachment to these to these
things
uh and i mean his
youtube channel is called the eev blog
so you know but um
i think people
sometimes cannot see the forest from the
trees
uh in these situations and uh they
make an emotional decision to like okay
electric but we're gonna do
electric buses
because they are electric buses and it's
like well why not truly possess no
that's heresy like
that's that's not how that's not how
really
urban
traffic transit works you know
anyway
uh yeah so electric bus video response
will be coming out soon
and uh
yeah for your
consideration and enjoyment
uh yeah but actually i was actually
rather impressed about how
polite everyone was about the
disagreement like lots of people
disagreed um
the video got a huge traction uh no no
pun intended yeah so
i think it was i think it was nice
uh yeah plus like since i since i met a
little more in planning i think you guys
are like a more much more quality
audience than a say a politics streamer
or something oh [ __ ] can you imagine
people screeching at me actually uh
after the latest video the the the
energy vault then appealed to a that
appealed to a much larger audience
uh
than usual like uh you know based on and
based on analytics that video had like a
huge sort of outsized reach
and it was like okay uh
i got
so many [ __ ]
uh well not so many but like significant
like more than usual
more than usual
messages about like people people going
like
i
like your urban planning takes
but i
disagree with your politics takes i
think your politics takes our [ __ ] and
it's like okay i don't know but um
there's like some due to cabinets like
start like screeching at me in the
emails like whatever
but um
thing was the only thing is that uh
i think i tapped into this uh
skeptic
gamer bro i don't know like this this
skeptic
community uh
energy which is and those communities
are pretty firmly right-wing i would say
now i mean if if skeptic orcs such as i
don't know
uh thunderfoot can tell you anything
actually i don't know about thunderf00t
i think he's kind of reformed at this
point once again i i think he believes
he lives in prague
uh i mean i i watch his stuff
he's good he just has this like weird
anti-sjw arc
back in the day which i didn't really
appreciate i mean that did a lot of
damage uh he was he became part of this
like alt-right pipeline to to uh
uh
uh
radicalize people
uh
plus his videos about anita sarkeesia
and sometimes were kind of disingenuous
like he would uh
clip things out of it and whatever
otherwise i think he's fine so whatever
i'm i'm not like a drama monger
nor do i want to be
let's look
at some chats uh back to you guys now
right i wrote some cool e-bosses in
minsk as well but i still don't get
their point yeah i mean
uh once again that this this is like
this
with electric buses the [ __ ] factor
is a huge
uh is a huge thing about it so like
you know it's oh my goodness it's big
it's shiny it's electric it's oh it's
future it's like okay
um
it's it's just dumb i would say
um
oh yeah we need a stadium area as well
um
yeah but so anyway um electric bosses
are like you know
uh
they they are actually very close to to
uh to uh
like [ __ ] like the loop you know
um
the [ __ ] loop is like actually we're
going to do the stadiums here uh oh [ __ ]
we're going in a lot of parking lots um
so the loop
and stuff like that is is uh
yeah rip walkability indeed um so stuff
like the loop
and uh
and you know the hyperloop whatever
you pitch it to you pitch it to [ __ ]
as do not it said if you pitch it to
enough desperate local governments then
eventually someone will bite i think
electric buses
are
very similar to that so you know it's
like oh hey
do you want to be environmentally
conscious and be epic bacon 420
uh
keanu reeves thanos
[ __ ]
green city
to
so you'll be able to you know like put
the check mark next to yes we're a green
city and then so all the all those like
cocked environmentalists will stop
[ __ ] with you they're bothering you
yeah
here's our electric buses you can just
plug them in like buy them and they're
good good to go
and uh yeah i mean that's that's not not
the case actually
uh
electric buses also need a ton of
infrastructure very costly
infrastructure infrastructure in fact
and uh
and uh like all the charging stuff that
they need that's actually
as costly to build out as the trolleybus
contact network so uh so that's actually
something i'll cover in the video
uh and something that ev blog was wrong
about
and that like trolley trolley uh
infrastructure
looks
uh
much more
like i mean it just feels more expensive
i guess because
it's just this big [ __ ] like tango
level wires etc and then it's it's you
know
it just just looks it looks uh expensive
on an emotional level i guess uh
meanwhile it's not really like it's not
i mean of course it it is expensive but
uh
but the electric buses
have the exact same
uh
like
it's we're not talking about different
orders of magnitude is what i'm saying
uh
and um yeah i'm going to cover this in
the video
and
one second
to do some heresy here there we go uh
yeah
yeah so if if um so like if you want to
well this looks about right
uh if you want to uh like if you have a
city for which you need public transit
then
uh dude like uh
first you should of course
uh consider
uh
uh you know
like rail based transit like uh trams or
you know uh s-bond
heavy rail etc
if that doesn't work then
then uh
then you should go on to different uh
methods like if if there's like if you
get like high like a high steep slopes
uh or like and or lack of funds then
then you go with trolleybuses
instead of trams or buses instead of
trams they work just as well what you
don't go with is electric buses because
they're [ __ ] expensive
and they are of course long-term cheaper
to maintain but when i what i actually
alluded to in my original video and what
i do want to also cover in the next
video
is that uh
is that uh
those
like they might have a higher like a a
higher cost and then lower maintenance
cost the electric buses
but the problem is that like there's a
lots of
sort of invisible costs associated with
with uh
with those things like
you know the socio can the socioeconomic
costs that i that i've alluded to um
what no uh and uh
so like if you
like you have a finite budget and you
use it to buy x amount of rolling stock
if you buy
a small a smaller amount of rolling
stock than you could have because you
have to buy the electric bus not the
diesel bus which is cheaper
then you are incurring actually lots of
losses invisible losses uh
socio-economical losses
because you're depriving people of of uh
of uh working public transit now
obviously like what what
blog and uh pointed out that like well
if you have if you have a system like a
public transit system you can just like
augment it with electric buses and then
that's going to be it and then
eventually you replace everything yeah
cool but you're supposing that the place
even has a
public transit system
so
uh because many cities just many places
just don't
like there your first priority is to
just get a [ __ ] system up and running
as soon as you can
you know
and um
you know
it's just
like that's that like period that's
that's your number one number one
priority and
um
like there's nothing to augment and you
need capacity and you will not get that
capacity with
electric buses because you can buy less
because
because uh
you know they cost more obviously and
the fact that they cost
more more to buy but cost less to
maintain and that's a hey that's uh hey
then we can buy them now and reap the
benefits later no no no
that's i think that's a flawed way of of
looking at it because
uh fundamentally you're building public
transit for the people
and not for spreadsheets right and not
for like the [ __ ] accountants
um
and even if even if uh like a public
transit system can be
so
well so good financially that you know
any accountant would just like
they'll just like like pass out from the
joy like their hearts can't handle it
like ah this is so beautiful and then
they just pass out on the floor cool but
you that's not the point of a public
transit system you have to serve people
with it you have to make people's lives
easier
uh you have to uh essentially provide a
social service to people
which is not going to be uh
not necessarily going to achieve by you
know having your system look pretty on
spreadsheets so and and this is actually
a wider criticism i have of this this
like
uh it's like the the urbanism equivalent
of tech bros
of these tech bro culture
uh
kind of people because
they for example these [ __ ]
construction construction channels
of like like the b1m et cetera and like
i don't know the guy
this is like this is not a criticism of
him personally it is the type of content
um
he produces because it's like
it's like their takes on urbanism begin
and end
with
oh look at big building
big number
but it's it's like it's like you you
could just like sit down in front of a
like
these videos could be made with like
donald trump narrating them in his style
and then and then they they wouldn't use
they wouldn't lose any
almost no information in the process
like
he's just like a big shiny showcase of
like
big pretty buildings you know and like
and it's like
yeah i i could actually do that like i
was gonna download one of the one of
these like
urbanism channels videos and like
just mute it put it put in some like
stock music under it and then i do the
donald trump like look i know big
buildings over here you see
the new administrative capital of egypt
look i've known administrative capitals
i've known them i like them i like
administrative capitals some of my
friends are administrative capitals now
this is bigly bigly the biggest big
big big
look at the octagon and the the the
[ __ ]
the world's tallest skyscrapers the
world best the world's biggest the big
big flagpole big flagpole big big flag
on it and then the audience just like
slow collapse
i think this is like irresponsible to
some extent because as i will describe
like i will actually like describe in
the video like the whole background of
this
project who finances it who is it for
and i i think that they're really that's
what that's what these people miss most
often
um
like they they focus on the buildings on
the concrete and glass and like oh look
look how nice it looks big big building
big big building and uh
and uh
it's just
yeah okay dude but like a building
a building without a
purpose a building but not a goal and
without knowing
uh who will
use them or who will use it and what for
it's like
it's just [ __ ]
i mean it's just a pile of bricks and
concrete and steel and glass and
there's nothing more to it like what
gives what gives buildings meaning
is what they are used for whom they are
formed that they serve
and this aspect is almost completely
missing from these types of uh these
types of videos and and
and that's a problem because
i mean this this is like because these
channels basically
give you like the caveman takes of
urbanism but like they [ __ ] like they
they they just like jangle some keys in
front of a baby
and it's like oh look look at the pretty
bill oh big building big big building
and it's like people are like oh nice
and they they never think about their
built environment
uh
in any other way beyond like beyond like
look
big
and it's like
yeah there's a bit more to urbanism than
that dude like i'm sorry to say
uh yeah so
anyway we need one more stadium here and
then i think we're done and then i'm
gonna launch the poll
about uh
what we should do next so one second let
me find another stadium because [ __ ] it
uh we need one
why isn't this unlocked i'm all of
moderation i would need that
oh wait do we have a
mall
okay so i cannot really
put it down with with the with the
finder okay whatever so um
stadium
[Music]
we are going to get some stadiums up in
here
uh one more in fact
where the hell was that though
i was showing you this is this i'm like
the i'm looking for the og stadium like
the the uh
the
original
vanilla
city skylines thingy
uh
no
goddamn i saw it oh wait no it's in
landmarks okay whatever
there we go
so we're gonna put it here because [ __ ]
it
uh
yeah where should we put it we're gonna
put it here
and there are some other
sports establishments as well because we
all like them
uh
[Music]
city skylines is oh my god like the
organization of assets is so [ __ ] bad
i really hate it um wait it was some was
it like
medical no
anyway
as i
thrash around helplessly in city
skylines
um feel free to
uh let's see if anyone edit me yes
uh in their difference their channels
was dedicated to oh yeah so this we're
talking about like b1m and theirs in
their defense uh the channel is mostly
dedicated to new technologies used in
construction which is applicable to our
construction yes but i would argue that
uh
even in that case still i think it would
be the responsible
uh thing
to do to uh
to actually oh there we go to actually
uh uh um
to
consider other factors other than
uh oh [ __ ] sorry uh to consider factors
other than you know
like this is just like this this caveman
[ __ ] you know
um
because i feel like very often that that
is that is just the case
like it's just like whoa
so huge and it's like okay
plus i don't know if they actually uh uh
don't know if they actually uh
sort of cover the feasibility of those
new technologies like okay it's fine to
have it's fine it's nice to have new
technologies but like
is that is that going to help anyone or
are we going to be
are you going to be better off with it
or like is is it some kind of like
vaporware you know we're just like oh
there's this new technology and then
wow how cool is that and then like two
weeks later everyone forgets it and it's
never brought up because it was just
like this whatever half-baked concept
um
i i'm actually really cautious
when it comes to these projects
if you couldn't tell already
and also also those channels because
they're just like
why don't you have a road connection
um
yeah so oh there we go
so yeah um
that looks like ass
now yeah so anyway uh once again this is
not like against them i don't know them
i wish them well
like creators like that i just i just
don't like the fact that uh
i i suppose they they contribute to the
to the collective dumbing down of
discourse
uh with regards to uh to to urbanism
because which is just something i don't
like anyway if you couldn't tell uh yeah
so
anyway no super chats so far
do you think you will ever make a video
about australia
uh
i don't know
if australia does does some dumb [ __ ] or
or if they do something interesting then
hell yeah
[ __ ] one second
so cold here in hawaii eating zone
um
let's see
she's whining
she's whining
it's 10 30 am here i guess she's getting
hungry
but you're only gonna get fed until noon
as usual
i would have trained them to like no no
crying i want to train them to like not
whine at me until like lunch time
because if it was up to the kitties
then then uh they would like they would
be having lunch every two hours like
they would be having like five lunches
and then in a short while they would be
like
just like rolling around the floor
like little furry
balls of fat
so you know
we need to put them on a strict diet
um
or at least like you know only only feed
them
uh
periodically kitty
she has nothing to say
all right
go now and stop whining i'm gonna i'm
gonna actually i'm gonna have a lunch
break around noon
i'm gonna go and feed them uh in the
meantime oh
any checks in the audience
i just water uh
i got some
kofola oh yeah
i got so i i got some like uh like uh
like i think for christmas
i got 24 liters of kofola as a gift so
now i have like a
supply for at least two weeks
alex severe five years thank you cat i
agree
let's see
when is the food reveal coming that's
gonna be uh that's gonna be an only fans
uh event i'm afraid
and something have you heard of uh that
one big city called
uh magnathanti which is a choked
cyberpunk hell hole with maximum
capacity wall to wall and how intimate
it was i have not heard of that actually
but it sounds great
i guess
the way you put it
this place needs some more parking lots
still
actually you know what i'm gonna put in
put up the poll
so
uh
european suburb
first
or fixing
the american
and there's eu and there is us
can you see the pole
yeah there we go
all right
so uh yeah feel free to vote so the
question is
whether
uh so you can vote now in the chat the
question is whether
i should start fixing this suburb first
oh yeah i should probably put it on the
uh put on the uh
like start the time so it will grow out
in front of us maybe it'll wreck my
computer maybe it won't who knows
um
and uh
yeah i'm just gonna
temporary solution i'm just gonna put in
everything here
the the
i'm just going to put in the uh the uh
very haphazardly going to place the uh
utilities so that i can actually start
this city up
actually fun fact um while i'm doing
this
i used to believe you know there's that
song like
we build this city we build this city
and like the song goes
we built this city on rock and roll
and for some reason i have no idea why
i
what i believed
like i thought i genuinely thought
that that song
went like
we built this city on broken bones
like i have no
freaking idea why but that's what i
believed so it's like a fun bit of
trivia for you
oh i think i know why actually because
uh because um oh yeah let's next to the
sewage plant there let's do
a uh
cemetery
so we can like i don't know if it gets
too full they can i guess like dissolve
the dead
there
um yeah so
yeah i think i think i think the reason
why i thought that it was we built the
city on broken bones because like i was
very familiar with like
saint petersburg you know the city
it was built on bones
because it was like so dangerous and was
built on a swamp that like a bunch of
people died
building it
uh okay so this is ignore this this is
just temporary [ __ ]
uh
and uh we're gonna put up some
incinerators too um
i would say here
all right about here uh just so like
this is this is i'm gonna maybe
integrate it into the whole city later
but this is just like because the
simulation needs of course
uh
to keep going
okay
so let's see
oh wait uh
something important i need to s
oh rip frame rate
i'm going to you put this
as uh
international so this is this will have
the the burger houses
okay that's not fair the american
suburban homes
i feel like the city skylines the
paradox interactive leadership is kind
of like a
like i don't know like a suburb stand or
like they're like very american
in terms of their design philosophy and
everything because like
the new dlc coming out for [ __ ]
cities skylines is airports
like
really like that's what the game needed
like
no
the game needed [ __ ]
what like
the game needed uh [ __ ]
like how about a train dlc like please
and like now we have airports which will
probably just do nothing that i mean
airports are like the most boring aspect
of this game they just like [ __ ] sit
there
and like yeah planes flying
yeah like it's just like a
external entry point
oh god this frame rate i haven't i have
an rtx 3060 by the way
so this [ __ ] thing
anyway
we're gonna wait until the whole city
grows out a bit
um
i have the mod which is
i have the mod which distributes
electricity evenly
what is this
evenly
through through the entire uh map like
no need for wires it's easier for the
for creative mode
and uh
yeah but the game game logic still
thinks that it has to be connected
all over the place so it's gonna take
some time oh wait
yeah we're going to just max out
everything
and we're going to fix the value
there we go
explosion and
prepare for the powerpoint frame rates
oh actually no
bro there's a train deals yet no no no
no
look i know that i if you mean the
stations dlc like no no no no
that's that's nice
i like it
but
but like
it's it's just you know it's it's just
like a few like what do you what you
mean is like the yeah the mass transit
dlc yes i have that and that's good but
what i mean but the mass transit is a
bit like surface level kind of
uh i like it though it's very nice
only that what i mean is like a
full-fledged like a train system like
okay you have different
uh you have different sort of uh uh you
know train systems you have high speed
rail you have to you have all this
infrastructure associated with
signaling et cetera that'll be nice but
but right now it's like put down the
track put down the station the train
train go okay
fine i guess but um
okay we need
uh okay this is not growing because i
don't think it's connected with
electricity
i'm gonna let's it's uh
we do have a high school here
elementary school
high school okay good
uh yeah
no power we need to add more power
yeah so the series kindness doesn't have
doesn't right rdp does not have this is
temporary ignore it um
city skylines doesn't have
a [ __ ]
uh trains dlc like don't don't kid
yourselves that that is not trains they
don't see what they have uh it's nice
like i like it
the problem is that
hang on let me put up put down some
playgrounds
and stuff uh the problem is that it's
just shallow
and
it's way too shallow in fact
for my taste anyway my
supremely developed tastes
and um
and uh
let's see
oh [ __ ] no later um so
a trained dlc in my opinion would be
like okay
adding adding a whole bunch of stations
new varieties
um high speed rail finally
um
something more work like something which
is which which actually is more than
just like
here's the station connect the station
to the track and then the truck
yeah
whatever
anyway
okay
muse
[ __ ] dude
okay let's try it now
wait i'm gonna listen to the stream
okay
okay let's try it now
i'm gonna listen to the stream it does
sound a bit robot
it's like a weird echo
i'm gonna kill myself
okay um i'm gonna talk for a bit so i
can uh
so um
okay let's try it now
i'm gonna listen to the stream
it does sound a bit robot
it's like a weird echo
i'm gonna kill myself
yeah um i can hear what the issue is
the problem is i've okay um i'm going to
talk for a bit so i can uh
it's
i'm going to listen to the stream
yeah okay uh
it's the robot arc i'm a transformer now
um
can i just mute and unmute myself uh in
youtube i [ __ ] hate youtube listening
holy like the person who came up with
this like they deserve to be shot
in minecraft
okay maybe not i'm being hyperbolic
yeah they deserve to be shot by this
audio in the ear
now okay can i just mute and unmute
myself uh in youtube i [ __ ] hate
youtube last year holy like the person
who came up with this like they deserve
to be shot
in minecraft okay i'm gonna google you
maybe not i'm being happy
okay
is is there like a business
to be shot by this audio in the ear
okay there's a video have you ever had
this happen to you
for this you can call me the derp
meister i
should have known better but i did it
anyways i have three usb 3.0
ports and if you have eight million
things that you need to use for your
stream but these guys need these okay so
the problem is most likely that i have
too many things plugged in okay so one
second i'm gonna replug my microphone
which one is my microphone jesus christ
so so many things back here
this
all right so now i hope it's better
uh let me check real quick
ah i hate
i just went at the grill dude
oh no crime
okay
okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna refund the police
all right so now uh i hope it's better
okay no i still still check this real
quick pretty robotic i hate
i just wanted to grill dude
okay
oh no crime
okay i might need to restart the stream
because i'm gonna
i'm gonna refund the police
i might need to restart the stream
uh one sec
yeah by the way city skylines has
disliked has the crime system like based
on the length of streets so if you
put together this like [ __ ] suburb
it's like literally like the worst thing
for the game
so anyway i'm gonna just real quick is a
stopgap
i'm solution to put these things
together
wait so the stream is repeating
so like if i if i say something and then
you hear it back again
right
i'm going to put these things together
wait so the stream is repeating
no no the
oh wait it's obs [ __ ] up
oh god okay haha hang on a sec
yeah i think i think it's my obs
okay uh let's see
like i am streaming according to obs and
it's uh
i mean it's going
but like wait
display capture
video capture
okay one second let me let me restart
the thing
um
okay
yeah sorry for the difficulties i've
fine
let's see display capture browser
video capture device
now my camera is offline what the f
there we go
okay i'm gonna do the same thing with
the microphone actually
and
the audio input
okay this is now the
okay okay okay okay okay got it gotta
get it
now it's now it's fine
okay and now my audio should sound
better
i know what the issue was okay so it
wasn't it wasn't the input
it was the [ __ ]
it was the [ __ ] uh
i don't know
because this is now the okay good good
okay okay okay okay okay okay got it
gotta get it yeah my webcam restarted
it's fine and then with that
okay and now my audio should sound my
webcam restarted like reset for some
reason and with that the webkinz
microphone turned on
and uh
yeah i mean
predictable results and then there was
like both both of them were like
recording my voice but the webcam was
recording anything like a shitty way
all right
so let's get some police stations up in
here so they can racially profile black
youth for no reason
and thus contribute to their
socioeconomic downfall so that's so that
rich suburbanites can
have discussions about their skull
shapes in private afterwards
wait is the echo back both of them were
like recording my voice but the webcam
was recording it in like a shitty way
all right
so let's get some
police stations up in here so they can
racially profile black youth for no
reason
and thus contribute to their
socioeconomic downfall so that's so that
rich suburbanites can
and the audio is good [ __ ] all of you
anyway
okay so like what was repeating okay
this you might have to okay if i think
it might be the with your connection
it's like if you place
if you plus press f5 or something like
if to reload the stream it should be
good
really
i'm gonna [ __ ] kill myself
it's repeating for you anyway
okay can you refresh the stream and see
if it's there okay so like what was
repeating okay this you might have to
okay if i think it might
oh yeah oh [ __ ] okay i'm i'm an idiot
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry the stream
was repeating because i mean on my end
i'm checking the [ __ ] fine sorry that
was on me
um no
on my end i'm checking the the the
[ __ ]
uh uh um
my mind i'm checking the the audio and
um
like obs only records like one screen
and i intuitively thought that okay
we're recording this thing and this
output
but then the the audio the audio output
is of course the whole system and it's
what i do on the second screen you can
also hear it so yeah sorry
and that was me
i am
i've been uh reported and
uh cocked and
liberals owned so
uh
let's get back to the paul uh that you
say that if you first i should uh first
i should put up put out uh particularly
the
european suburb next to this yes
uh i'm gonna do that first i need to
stabilize this thing because holy [ __ ]
uh this is not good
uh
okay
yeah like
you people are telling me like oh
best placement ever
you people are telling me like oh you
know it's it's repeating it's reading
and i'm like i'm i go into my youtube
studio
and i check i start start like and turn
turn the audio on
to see if it's repeating but that's
what's that's what caused it to repeat
so
um
okay quickly i'm gonna put this down so
like i don't want the city to die while
i'm working on the european
uh
version
so
so real quick anyway uh in the meantime
feel free to keep rolling
with the uh
questions and yes in silicon as you kind
of do need to build like 25 000 police
stations because like
the game was not designed to accommodate
this sort of uh
this sort of uh uh
city planning
but anyway
i'm just gonna for now he's gonna put
down the public service building so that
the things won't collapse
all right uh let's look at this
water we'll need some more water yay
okay anyway i think i'm gonna pause the
vid pause the uh the uh
there we go
i can hear the cats they're going insane
my cats are insane
okay so anyway the
the crime thing will get sorted out okay
now i'm gonna pause this
actually
actually i need to
i don't know
uh we need to connect this with like
playgrounds and [ __ ] so that the um
the ai
the building placement ai
uh
and there we go see
it's spreading we're sprawling
we're sprawling
brother
there we go
all right so uh show us the kitties
uh
yeah well they're running around i can't
catch them now like i'm i'm i'm kind of
bogged down with this [ __ ] thing
called city skyline
okay
yeah so it's gonna
one more police station because like
police station effectiveness decreases
with like
road length in serious islands for some
reason
so uh
oh nice
the traffic jam of the century
and there's a there's a traffic light i
need to
take out
okay
okay
here we go just so that the good people
of
[ __ ] my life will can get to
their
beautiful suburban homes which totally
do not
uh
incentivize them to kill themselves you
know suburbs have like a much higher
suicide rate because of the lack of
social contact and alienation
oh my god okay
budget
up
communism
literally
1884 what's going on here
there we go
so as also very importantly we do we do
not have any workable public transit at
the moment it's it's all
it's all dog [ __ ]
and i have a
goddammit one second
look look at the pretty cars look at the
nice cars i'll be right back
[Music]
[ __ ] dhl
all right uh
the city seems to have stabilized
nothing is collapsing still at a [ __ ]
police station here
thanks peridot there it is
what's the problem well maybe they're
too busy
in other places
all right
um
the moment time whatever moment i
stabilize this thing then we go
we go sicko mode
on the
european suburb
all right
so
let's see
okay it's building here
[ __ ] cities
yeah for that for the for the full
unrealistic
um
you know public services etc i would
need i would need some like really heavy
loading
uh
yeah and the game runs
runs bad enough already so
and we need some more garbage into
anyway this all this can be very nicely
integrated into the uh
into the city yeah next to this yeah
some
some larger scale crematoriums anyway
so um
yeah
i would need some super heavy [ __ ]
modding to to get this thing uh
really to uh to be a
full-on realism etc which is possible
and at some point i will do it it's just
that
i always like
get a whole bunch of mods
and then the game runs like [ __ ]
the game
the game
plays really well
but it runs like [ __ ] and then i'm like
okay this is yeah i miss i miss my at
least 20 frame rate
so i
uh
purge my mod library and then i just
build it back up and thus the cycle
repeats
okay this is this is uh
okay it's garbage yeah okay so actually
this is this is something interesting
though because now we can
kinda sort of see
a problem with with uh suburbia in this
in this sense that like
the distances are so [ __ ] huge
that uh
you basically need to uh
like it it's really difficult to uh
extend all these public services
everywhere and i think hey maybe this is
some kind of like backwards for dhs uh
move from paradox
because because uh it shows you how like
how much more expensive your
public services have to be and
everything oh we're pretty car centric
now
uh
probably because of all the traffic
lights i have here for
no good reason for now yeah for the
times when people are just like getting
into your city it's better to disable
them
later i'm gonna put them back
at this sort of heavy traffic areas like
here there's no need for two
all right so uh let's go
europe
i've ended the poll goodbye that was it
never again
you should do a video on the um
on the uh housing situation in new
zealand and australia
uh i don't know much about the housing
situation oh
rip
run run that's what you're here for
anyway uh
i don't know much about the housing
situation in new zealand or
australia but
i mean
if it's uh
if it's worth worth looking into then
hell yeah
um
okay here this one too
okay
there you go
all right so uh europe we europe now
uh it's gonna be
here so nicely delineated by our
highways this shall represent the
european countryside nice little
village uh suburb next to a highway
which goes onto a city oh bar and ash
thank you for the 600 uh
600 hungarian pesos
um
yeah
so this so this what we write here what
we have right here is [ __ ] horrible
like this is this is why
hell exists well like this is hell and
you know god is dead and uh
and uh yeah
it's it's
this is this is
i guess in this case i guess in this
game i am kind of like god you know just
like
ordaining everything into existence
and so this is my my punishment for the
human race in this in this instance
how nice
okay it's doing that good all right so
uh european
settlement
incoming so the thing about european
settlements is that usually like
european
neighborhoods etc
very often
especially uh
oh this is newer settlements very often
they
uh formed
around like they had this like
traditional little core
from the middle ages et cetera next to
roads and then
as radio escaping they kind of like
formed around that
um
so here we're gonna have a central we're
gonna stop the game
and
we'll actually start building it out
from
a train station
and
which train station should we build not
a city station but like a a rather
simple
one
i don't have any of those like little
old school stations unfortunately i got
some black blocks because why not
um
let's see
okay well it's simple enough little
teeny tiny baby station
uh yes
all right so now we have a
station
dramatic music that mp3
uh
oh yeah the game is just like [ __ ]
finally
okay
so we have a station and in front of
that station
there's going to be
a road
because why not
once again how serious kindness handles
great differences is just beautiful
uh
so you know paradox called out
and uh actually i'm going to level this
whole thing because like it's annoying
uh
oh [ __ ]
there we go
i'm just gonna level it out
and then smoothen it
smoothing it until it looks like
i don't know
dennis breger's brain
actually he's uh he's not a dumb man
like he he knows he knows what he's
doing he's just like you know he's just
lying
like he's just like or actually with
people like dennis prager i don't know
if i don't know if
i would call them like
liars necessarily
there might be a grift element to their
content but otherwise i think i think
they're one of those people who like who
just like believe this [ __ ] you know
uh
plus he's like
i think he's like also financed by like
brothers like the one that's remaining
at this point
uh but um
yeah uh it is the it's the like the it's
like the problem with orban and
kaczynski you know like it's like
kaczynski is genuinely crazy
urban is just opportunistic but as time
goes on
like orban of course hungary is prime
minister and kaczynski is like the de
facto leader of poland uh
like you don't really know
to what extent they're gifting and to
what extent they actually believe that
[ __ ] same same people like charlie kirk
for example
uh you have no [ __ ] idea because
like they it's e at this point it's
equally plausible
that uh
that they are actually
just like not all there
and that they're just like drifting and
like saying whatever the hell the
highest better demands
but i don't want to
i don't want to neglect the chat
uh have you have you played workers and
resources soviet republic uh i bought it
i tried it i'm gonna play some more i'm
that through the tutorial now so do you
believe in intelligent life in other
planets and it's a that's a good
question actually oh that's a
that's something i want to cover on my
second channel at some point uh i don't
want to go the the the uh
the armored skeptic route i think i
think didn't he become like an alien
truth or something
oh well
uh
so
the thing is that uh with alien life
uh what you have to take into account is
that
is that okay
even if they do exist like the earth is
billions of years old
the universe has been around for like 14
billion years
it's
the question is like
it very well might be that there that
there was some kind of intelligent life
on the planet
but uh like in in the universe but
there's no guarantee
that they are they that they exist at
this point i should say
um
because imagine if imagine if instead of
the dinosaurs
uh
humans evolved first you know
like that's that's millions of years ago
and imagine that you know
we
deleted ourselves out of existence uh
since that that since then like some
kind of horrible catastrophe befell
civilization that he collapsed et cetera
and so um
imagine that like imagine that
and then and then so human civilization
began
you know
10 million years ago and then ended nine
million years ago
and then here we are uh
and then here's some other civilization
in the present going
are there an alien civilization that
there's like sure they were but there
were but like
there was the humans but they're now
gone
uh because i mean right now we kind of
like were once again like 14 billion
years after the after the formation of
the universe so
uh
and habitable planets have been around
much
uh earlier than that so it stands to
reason that uh
that there could have been some
some civilization or they could be now
it's just that a they're
they're they're way too far away and b
they are um they have already gone
extinct so
universe is pretty big
but uh
now we're gonna do something some of
these are beautiful highway interchanges
but uh
but uh like it could be that they exist
or they did exist
i think it's at this point it's not
really a relevant question but the thing
is though
oh the game is too loud uh the thing is
though
is that uh
the thing is though is that um
[ __ ] alien truthers
whenever there's some kind of like weird
light in the sky
whatever you got people
going ah aliens
i knew it and it's like
wait like dude
like like those those navy uh footage of
footages of like oh look there's a
there's a navy ship
and the [ __ ]
unidentified object
is just there and it's it's it's flying
around and oh it must be the aliens
analyzing our ships
it's like okay let's think about this
logically okay
we have
a species
which have which has mastered
[ __ ]
interstellar travel
right
so they can
they can get go through because like
they can travel between solar solar
systems that's that's how advanced their
technology is
right
so
you mean to tell me
that this [ __ ] civilization
members of it at least
came to earth they they flew to earth
right because for some reason they are
interested in our
you know stone age technology
competitors anyway
and their their first thought was hey
dude
you see that floating tub of
of steel on the water
that these people that these humans call
ships
quick let's let's let's fly real close
to it and just like just
just like i don't know look at it
like we already have satellites
uh
we already have satellites which are
capable of like of like
you know photographing you from like
orbit
uh in in good detail right
now imagine what technology a
[ __ ]
interstellar civilization would have
right
like this is this is not
uh
this just doesn't make sense uh
no matter how you put it
uh
and so
one sec let me just arrange my windows
here and so um
and so all these ufo truthers like
they
they it's just they just fail to
consider this they just they just don't
understand like
okay
wha what would the aliens even want from
us
like it would for us for for them maybe
would be like a fun little zoo exhibit i
guess like oh look the the the uh the
primitive civilization that kind of you
know is trying hard etc
but
aside from some kind of like
uh i guess
anthropological uh
curiosity why would the aliens want to
even [ __ ] like talk with us or like
communicate with us like there's no
reason
i mean beyond just like zoology
essential like or the equivalent of
zoology
owen taylor fully animated space
communism oh yes hell yeah
so
the thing is though
uh it's just
makes very little sense to me
when we when we all have these footages
of like oh you know this is alien ships
like
no like
that's okay you don't know what it is
and even if it was aliens then they are
pretty
lame like they're like pretty
underwhelming and don't you think
if their first reaction is like
quick let's look at that floating type
of steel down there because [ __ ] it you
know because
that's super interesting for like nah
even if if aliens exist then then uh
cool
for now it's just not
not a such a
important slash uh
relevant subject adam your cia handler
is pleased with how you've been hiding
the truth about aliens on earth keep up
the great work
thank you i expect as a reward my
new brain drivers be transmitted to my
head through the government satellites
let's put down a church
because no european
[Music]
settlement is completely a church
obviously
yeah let's put it here for now yeah
anyway so yeah it's pretty dumb
uh please don't believe in aliens
well i can't film whatever feel free to
believe in aliens whatever it's just
that
our current idea of aliens is just
[ __ ]
uh for the most part
and um
yeah it would be nice if you if you if
you just like you know
didn't
get so agitated
uh if there are any alien truthers in
chat like yeah look i'm i'm not
disputing that there might be some
aliens
out there but like
yeah uh we can return to this subject
when we mastered interstellar travel and
we can actually look around the cosmos
and see what the [ __ ] is going on
it could also be that we're completely
alone in the cosmos like uh
that's fine i guess
um
yeah so
okay so like the difference between
aliens and ufos
like ufos are just like you unidentified
flying objects right
and uh
it's uh
you know
it's not much else to do it
it's like you look at it and it's like
you have no [ __ ] idea what it is
period
and um
and uh
some people say oh look it's like it's
it's aliens and like
whatever you don't know
okay so by the way we're now building uh
so the the different key difference
between a european uh
suburb and an american one is that the
european one as you will see is much
more compact so
uh
i'm building it kind of in a silly way
but but it's it's to illustrate the
point
so uh there are usually one or two
definite centers of the place like here
there's like the
the church the cemetery uh well actually
the cemetery could go somewhere else
like here
um
there's there's the church there's the
cemetery there's like usually like a big
park in the center something like that a
big main street and then there's the
train station that's usually the second
uh the second uh area around the town or
like the village
where there's things
uh you know and it's also
pretty densely built out like there's
streets like like there's of course the
historic center which is a bit like
squiggly and all over the place
uh courtesy of the basically
just like the old planning
and uh
then there's the newly built areas which
are actually zoned out
which have been zoned out quite recently
uh no dead ends actually so like
what you what you can see
already uh
from the from the to uh from the
comparison is that
uh instead of this like big drawn out
you know lots of dead ends etc
everyone's going around
um
here everything is it's a grid it's a
big grid i'm going to put up some water
so if people can
go to the toilet
and so it's
it's much more healthy because
a european suburb
of course
is uh like it incentivizes
uh
social interactions and all that uh much
more this will become much more apparent
as soon as i start zoning things out i
will not i won't just like be painting
it over
um
with a brush like i did in the other
suburb and there's a good reason for it
we'll get to that in a
moment all right in the meantime if you
have any questions you want to ask me
feel free this is this is a
part of this video is of course the
fundraiser
which is i mean this is just an excuse
for me to play city skylines but i also
want to
donate to
some hunger and hunger and ngos that i
think are doing important work i already
donated to donate in the past but i was
but i also wanted
to involve more people in it
i donated a couple of thousand to them
euros
i'm gonna do
more with this though
okay so
uh if you want to ask a question either
super chat actually that would be
preferable because
after all i mean we actually actually
have collected quite a lot of money
already
let me just convert it
to dollars i mean burgers i'm sorry
so
we already collected
around
300 burgers
which is very nice
otherwise if you have a
otherwise if you have a question
uh feel free to add me either in the
super chat or
i mean at me at the normal chat or or
just put it in the super chat
okay
all this piping around
uh lots of adding
have you heard that they're planning to
connect kellenfield to daily and you've
got the underground do you think they're
everyone gonna finish it oh yeah there's
this rail tunnel in budapest uh it would
be nice if that happened uh i think it
will happen honestly
yeah good luck to them i guess
and uh thoughts on esperanto
me no habla esperanto i'm sorry
uh it's a you know nice little hobby
language as far as i'm concerned about
one seriously speaks it
as far as i know i might be wrong
uh
i'm gonna cover this area and then i'm
gonna go back to questions of it
[Music]
what is your day job how did you get
into infrastructure discussions
at this point i do youtube full time
uh i did have a job i was usually
working in like offices uh through my
entire life uh my working life that is
uh yeah it was it was
you know
paid reasonably well but otherwise it
was it was kind of bad
i mean the fact that like
you know if he says
oh god then i i really want to talk
about this as well
[ __ ] open plan offices
uh i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna talk about
that in a bit
damn dude was it a big was there a bit
dis big disconnect like uh
we went from like
600 viewers to like
to like uh
100 in like one second anyway
uh people are coming back back now um
probably youtube so
so uh let's see i'm gonna cover the the
whole uh um
open plan offices because that's also
another stone which i need to
like
another weight which i need to get off
my chest
discord and discordant on here
okay if you're a discord mod and you
won't want to mod here then just feel
free to dm me on discord
um
how long does it take to make a video
well to make a video
to make a video is uh
usually it really varies
okay yeah so it was youtube
uh good never mind so um the uh how long
how long does it take to for me to make
to make a youtube video
is usually varies
um sometimes i just like have an idea i
sit down i write a script i record it
i i put it together and i upload it
within one day so like
i'm sorry that's morning till evening
and i'm done
which is super nice um however sometimes
i just like sit on a topic i move mo
over it for like days
and uh then i
start writing it out
and then you know rewrites and then
reorganizations and reshoots and
whatever like it really varies
my favorite is
uh my favorite is uh of course the kind
of video which just which just like
slides out which is like
there we go
um
uh those are super nice actually
wait one of my videos was like that
which one was it um
anyway it's irrelevant now
um
but that ended up being one of my
oh yeah i know it is the energy vault
basically i think i think that was it
like
i just like
like
like that put it out had the idea in my
head
boom and then it was out just out
it was just done
and
that ended up being a hugely popular
video i thought that i thought that i'll
get some criticism for like
for like oh it's a bit like haphazardly
put together or whatever and then i put
it out and everyone's like yeah i'm like
cool
it was it was actually uh
that video actually blew up and that was
actually why i got a whole bunch of new
viewers because
uh
they like it it appealed to this like
debunk sphere which as far as i know
it's only a thunder foot at this point
uh maybe some other people i'm being
unfair here
uh super chat i can see from the corner
of my i know okay there we go
mayhem five years thank you very much
since we are neighbors i have to ask if
there was any coverage in hungary about
the claims that orban funds right-wing
media and parties
in slovenia uh yeah and they do own
something there that i know that i know
that much
they do own
some kind of
i think
some kind of tv channel like some
hungarian like oligarch or
whatever uh uh
like company with ties to oligarchs et
cetera like they uh they bought they
bought
shares into and there were some used
news stories in hungary about that i'm
not familiar with it but like i wouldn't
be surprised because this is definitely
definitely not out of character
uh
in uh uh of four for uh for orban i mean
they've been doing this
some
some uh company with like some like
hungary and background
actually bought bought into euro news
now
so
i don't know what to think about that
i'm looking for that [ __ ] building
where is it
yeah so um it's pretty
concerning i would say
but there's definitely like if like
they are doing this sort of
buying into other media companies and
then
slowly turning it into their propaganda
piece so that's that's the
uh
taxa [ __ ] you
okay oh
xyz gopath 200 crowns thank you very
much
i guess that means vaccinate yourself
yes
dracula 50 crowns thank you adam
something one what scale are your model
trains they are h0
uh two car enthusiasts do you think
uh there are arguments for walkable
cities for those folks as well uh sure
absolutely uh now the idea is that um
like the the reason why a walkable city
would make much more sense for even car
enthusiasts
is because like if you're a car
enthusiast
you don't want cars to be this like
[ __ ] chore right you don't want you
don't want cars to be just this like
just like just like [ __ ]
necessity for people uh they have to get
in the morning like oh [ __ ] like
drive to work and drive back and so
basically your car just becomes this
this tool in your
in your in your uh
soul killing commute or whatever and
i think car enthusiasts
think car enthusiasts are
uh would be much better off if they're
if the subject of their enthusiasm
wasn't
this just like this soul killing
everyday tool which they have to use for
to get the [ __ ] work and
like it's it's not good so i think car
enthusiasts would absolutely
uh benefit
from from uh uh walkable areas like
finally their toy their their their the
object of their interest would have some
sort of
um
would have some sort of uh
value
beyond you know everyone has it it's
needed you getting it you drive to
[ __ ] you know
uh
uh work and then back and then repeat
and i did it
yeah
uh let's see so yeah
pineapple on pizza yes or no um i think
oh yeah oh god i'm gonna get dog piled
for this but
um
pineapple pizza
is like
okay why do you hate pizza on pineapple
in
like if we are honest with ourselves
then
the reason why you hate pineapple on
pizza is because other people told you
that it's bad right
like no one no one wakes up the morning
like [ __ ] pineapple pizza ah no it's i
think this is cultural influence
actually
uh people are like
like you've seen too many memes about
pizza and pineapple and now you don't
like it because people on the because
it's it's cool not to like it so that's
my hot take on pineapple pizza
uh meme kaiser
uh
20 swiss francs have a great day adam
thank you well you have a great day too
uh meme kaiser
may your memes be always dang
what do you think about english-speaking
countries copying the u.s all the time
well in in what sense though if in
urbanism then of course that's bad
but uh
i haven't really heard any i haven't
really like you know seen any
english-speaking countries like just
like copying the us
i don't know don't know in what sense do
you mean that
if urbanism then [ __ ] yeah it's bad but
that's i think i think when it's
urbanism then it's the same like
neocon boomer energy which which you see
in the us of like oh yeah
we're gonna have this beautiful
neighborhood here
for like
the for like uh uh suburban moms and
dads with one house two cars two and a
half children
uh hashtag gas deport you know stuff
like that
let's see um
[ __ ] jumping around so
uh
let's see
is this video going to remain on the
channel i hope so i'm planning on
watching it for later yes uh this this
stream will i'll put it up on the on the
main channel so uh
so uh
uh feel free to like if you if you are
an american like for you it's like i
don't know it's
well past midnight now
so uh
if you
uh are too tired feel free to to go get
some sleep and then check back tomorrow
well because
uh or today
because it's going to be on the channel
so yeah but hey as long as you're here
feel free to ask me questions because
i'm here for you
i'm here for you i'm here with you
tell me get in here give me a hug
hug
my audience i like them um
let's see i'm sorry if you already
addressed this because i had to leave
but on the american suburbs the streets
in the neighborhoods are almost never
that far apart but are still windy as uh
still in hell
uh
well
actually
yeah this is a bit like yeah wait i'm
gonna actually fill out this space
that's a good point
[ __ ] water
do we have enough we should okay good uh
yeah um
i actually took this they took this from
like the suburbs of baltimore where
there's like
water like little lakes between them and
like swamps and stuff
um actually i looked at what what the
area of grover house
uh looks like so i was like yeah okay
i'm i'm doing that we're we're meeming
now we're doing the thing
uh
it will
look better as soon as we put in some
forest so like in in the baltimore area
uh the way of the way i saw it there's
like be like where i'm putting these
forests there's also like a whole bunch
of uh
swamps and like these little water
bodies
and uh that's why they're so far apart
but then again i i also look at other
suburbs and
but they also tend to be like
they like really drag things out
uh so
[Music]
i don't know it doesn't want to put any
trees there oh well that's gonna be the
no tree zone
wait are we have we oh
okay
okay we reached the the limit for trees
okay
in that case
let's let's let's go let's go boys
goodbye
yeah like i had this [ __ ] mod like
the the no tree limit
like the no upper limit for trees
there we go there we go
we do we do industrial era england now
where the english
government was just like or the british
government was like
nice forest you got there
delete
anyway so yeah it's you know we gave our
map a little trim
so now let's i'm gonna just quickly uh
tree in this area yeah i should get the
the unlimited trees mod
uh not to like behind with the super
chats
uh let's see adam something uh hey
what's your opinion on nuclear power i
don't hear you mention it much in your
videos yeah um yes i actually had
questions like this before like on this
stream um
with nuclear power
uh i think like i think it's fine
i think the nuclear scare is mostly just
uh it's just very scare
i think if if we want to sort of uh
i think nuclear power should can and
should play
a role in combating climate change
because it's just clean energy
and we largely have nuclear power
figured out like storage and of course
power as well
um yeah so i think most much of it has
to do with this character fukushima but
that's just i think feels overreals and
nuclear power is like a very
simple and convenient uh simple but like
it's a accessible somewhat accessible
but very effective way
to uh to uh
effect change so i think i would say i'm
pro nuclear
just like don't don't do it your novel
and that's my only
request some more super chats
do you likes uh
do you like skoda uh city elephant no
wait no yes um
i do like skoda city elephants this
question is from one second
yes skoda city elephants are pretty
based actually those are the
double-decker trains of the czech
railways
yeah and they are pretty nice
okay
do you think it's better to have an
existing de facto international language
like english or a fabricated one like
esperanto uh pre-existing because i mean
it's already pretty hard to get people
to learn new languages
uh
imagine if like
imagine if you had to learn a new one
and then you just say but yeah but like
why why bother with that we already have
english and it's like well yeah
uh plus like yeah good good luck
teaching good luck trying to get
americans to learn a new foreign
language like
i think i think english is uh english is
english all the way
j gum
for 100
swedish crowns
what do you think of european cities
building neighborhoods in the same style
of u.s suburbs they're pretty cringe
they should not do that their ass
so
i don't like them i i want to
uh destroy them in minecraft
uh preferably preferably not with their
occupants in them uh i think they need
to be like i think i think like
this this is like
once again like once again like like
baby's first urbanism adventure like
today baby and by baby i mean the
[ __ ] boomer who authorized that
baby to baby we'll learn about induced
demand yay
the more own the more car
wow like you know it's gonna be that
experience
uh but like i would prefer if we didn't
have to do that you know
i would prefer if we just like
not had to
learn this lesson all over again
that would be pretty nice but oh well we
we don't live in the
good timeline always
a dudeist priest
don't like the name uh five dollars
thank you very much people are people
already complain about windmills how do
you think we can change perception on
having a nearby reactor
uh okay so ryan reactors and windmills
are a bit different like depends on like
what country you're talking about where
people complain about windmills uh it's
usually i mean in germany there are they
are everywhere and
and
they are not really
people aren't really bothered by them
in the czech republic it's a bit
different people are
sometimes you're like
look as bad and like whatever
shut up boomer
uh
but um you know
it's uh
like with react i mean i mean you don't
really put reactors that close to two
people right
so i don't think that that's an issue
it's usually like within a safe distance
as it should be
from human settlements
uh yes
uh i didn't think rhodes would be that
far apart just someone my perspective is
from california who grew up in the
suburbs yeah i mean suburbs very um
place to place some suburbs are actually
very
it's actually funny because like they
look pretty dense because the houses are
pretty densely placed
but like they are not really because
because it's like a low density area and
and you cannot access areas with [ __ ]
uh
with with like public transit or
pedestrian
thing what i'm doing here is actually
going to be dense as hell
uh well as far as you know villages go
because you do note that it's like a
more it's like more like a grid
and actually i'm gonna uh i'm just going
to uh wait
let's see we don't need to build in all
of this
but uh this is actually
like so the thing about european
settlements is that they are
uh
at the end of the day
little like
like just like european neighborhoods
within cities
at the end of the day they are just
they're just uh
like little uh uh little centers on
their own so they this is very important
they stand on the road
uh usually
so if you so this neighborhood as soon
as i and this once again will start
becoming pretty apparent as soon as i
start zoning it out
why
uh
right okay i think we're almost done i'm
not going to
fill out this entire area because i
don't need to i don't think
and uh yeah this is this is not if not
professional awareness by the way i'm
not an official urban planner but like
hey i'm i'm trying out here
um
this is more like an illustration for
you too to further red build you on the
idea of
walkable neighborhoods plus of course
the uh
i i
i selflessly play video games for you so
that you know
for so that i can get donations uh for
the right causes
okay
almost done
let's
take this off
here we go
i see a super chat
what is it about
levantaborga 5000 friends thank you do
you think it's possible to successfully
integrate minorities in hungary with the
current political situation and mindset
of the people if not what would be the
solution thank you this is exactly what
i wanted to talk about
i'm going to
quickly
go and
relieve myself of
my existential agony and then continue
uh answering that question because
that's actually that's actually what i
wanted to transition so yeah thank you
for reading my mind but for toriyanville
two pounds
could could you do it george is in
practice simulation oh god i have to
look into it so
once i can be right back
all right hello hello
i'm back with my assistant
kitty
is so scary
i'm all right
uh yeah he has a single core cpu in his
head so if anything can overload him
basically
wait is the chest
[ __ ] okay ma so my stream preview
actually crashed
nice
never mind
uh
the main thing is
that we can see each other
good
through my obs
say hi kitty
kitty
kitty
anyway
so
to answer that question
um before
it's actually an extra thick kitty it's
actually pretty skinny
i think i think it's the teeth so we're
gonna have it fixed so uh the question
was from
la ventavorga which i wanted to
cover
uh
alex very cat cat five years thank you
very much
is um
do you think it's possible to
successfully integrate minorities in
hungary with the current political
situation and mindset of the people if
not what would be the solution well with
the current political mindset
not really
of course the current political mindset
towards roma in hungary is basically
they are
um
i mean what you do is you just like you
know
uh
essentially
uh use them as like a voting machine
every four
years and then
when
that's gone like you know you just like
give them some sexy potatoes or whatever
and um
and when that's done like when the
election day is done then
that was it right so that was the end of
it you no longer
give a [ __ ]
the aroma
the roma situation is now off the table
completely and you're free to not give a
[ __ ] about them for four more years so
that's the
so that's the uh
that's the essence of the situation in
hungary
which is pretty bad obviously um yeah
and so since the roma population has
always been basically segregated against
like there's this case pretty via a very
pretty uh
resident case of like school segregation
of like roma kids were like put in like
one class and the
and the other
uh like in into the bad class i guess
where the teacher just came like yeah
whatever just do whatever i i don't give
a [ __ ]
and uh a bunch of roma kids because of
that you don't get a good education to
which usually these like
bunch of boomers and like honorary
boomers come out of the woodwork saying
have you studied together with like roma
gypsies before
yeah liberal your views would change if
you yeah okay
um
okay that's that's [ __ ] because uh
yeah like there will be more problematic
roma students uh
obviously because of the socioeconomic
status but the thing is
the thing is though that uh
with like
why why do you segregate based on
uh
why do you segregate based on
uh
skin color then then if if the problem
is that you know some kids are
problematic which they will be
of course
uh why don't you
um
segregate based on
who's problematic and who isn't you know
like isn't that the logical solution
like hey why don't we have not like
the the the the the
the white
cli the white elementary school class
and the the uh the the aroma class you
know
why don't we have the
problematic and then non-problematic
right
um
but
because if you segregate people if you
segregate people based on their [ __ ]
uh skin color like kids
then what you'll end up with is two
classes
in both of which
the
sort of
the bad kids are still there
because they're there are bad kids in
both
uh in both
like within both within roma and
and
non-roma uh children right so what
you're doing is you're leaving
you you're leaving both uh
the roma and
non-normal children together
uh like among
each other's
midst i guess but you're still not
solving the problem of problematic
children
now roman children will be
will be more problematic
injury like problematic among from among
problematic children roman kids might i
can imagine why they would be more
problematic right so once again
socioeconomics
but
it just makes no sense i don't want to
to to segregate themselves based on skin
color
no matter how you flip it it's just it's
just pointless uh it doesn't solve
anything it makes things it makes things
actively worse in fact so
and there was this big lawsuit
uh in hungary of i don't know which
school it was but basically the problem
was that parents got together and like
filed the equivalent of a class-action
lawsuit
against the government against the
school school uh because they segregated
their kids and because of that their
kids
just didn't get an education essentially
and ended up as uh
ended up as as uh
essentially as a
kitty
shut up uh they ended up as like a local
like
essentially the equivalent of
street swipers basically
because they don't because they just
didn't uh
amount to anything because they couldn't
because they didn't get any education
and no one could give them an education
beyond beyond the school
which was unwilling to do so
and so the result is there for everyone
to see
um
and so
this is
of uh this is of course bad
and uh
the response to this
was that
of course like the parents won the
lawsuit actually in the end so that was
very nice
however
uh later on they're like from like
higher government circles
what was it like orban actually reached
down
and like instructed
like some hiring high-ranking politician
reached down and instructed
to stop the payout of the damages
and like why
so
so under the current political
establishment i think roman integration
is not really possible because the
current in the current
administration orban
etc
they just don't give a [ __ ]
and
and um
you know
if you don't give a [ __ ] about the
people whom you're
who you're trying to sort of get out of
poverty
then
what's
like what are you going to do about it
and of course the answer is nothing
you're not going to do anything because
you don't give a [ __ ] because hey
they're because they are gypsies you
know like
okay
and
i see and and that really is
a huge problem of mine like lots of
people seem to be interested in just
like
just like
as i wrote in the [ __ ] under the
under my community post just like
crossing their arms and going like but
that's some nice big
fluffy three words you have there
liberal but
here's my retort
gypsies are bad
like
that that
like okay
cool you you got that off your chest
nice but like
whom does that help and the question the
answer is [ __ ] nobody like
it's just it's just
as i said lots of people seem to be
interested in just like crossing their
arms declaring that you know
declaring that gypsy bad
and then do the dream then do the
[ __ ] dreamworks face at you right
so
it's uh
it's stupid but anyway
did i is the stream okay
yes good okay it's fine
okay so
the thing is though
uh so so like that really is my biggest
biggest issue with these people like far
writers usually
and like
also when it comes to roma uh europeans
are really really [ __ ] racist like
seriously
uh and it's this like
everyday nonchalant
racism too which is i think even worse
um
thing is though
[Music]
i
want solutions to our problems right
i see the situation with the roma and i
go
that's bad
that's
that's double plus on good you know
literally 1884 i know um
that's not nice right that's a bad
situation how do we solve it
uh and so
people who
uh uh people who are like who get like
the most mad about roma
they don't they don't give a [ __ ] about
they don't give a flying [ __ ] about
solutions to this problem if you ask
them
like they they'll be so happy to tell
you
[Music]
but then it's like dude
okay what's your solution then
what solution well to the issue of roman
integration everything
yeah and and then you get the
the then they tell you how the [ __ ]
school shape is different you know it's
dumb
it's completely pointless it's dumb it's
it's it's not
uh not solving anything whereas i i'm
interested in solutions so
yeah but i i i find it funny though how
uh whenever the
subject of rubber integration comes up
like my europe the european part of my
audience
you know they they they i assume they
they they nod along
with uh with all my progressive
positions as i as i uh mentioned them
and then when it comes to roma it's like
oh blood and soil
you know
i think you don't want to know their
solutions no uh they
they legitimate i don't think that they
legit legitimately care about solutions
now they're
now those people who are
i don't think they have uh
legit solutions really
like solutions that they themselves
uh believe
i think
the of course the the logical conclusion
of their
views of roma
is either a
deporting them to some kind of like i
don't know
some kind of like
you know
uninhabited island and the sea or
something or kill them
it's you know
it's holocaust never deported them like
this like there's no other
alternative in their view
of course i
and you hopefully also know that there
is an alternative which is
uh
which is integration right
now
but
the
other like but the people who are the
loudest about this they don't they don't
give a [ __ ] about integration they just
they just don't like roma and like
that's the end of it they have some bad
experiences etc and and they let those
bad experiences sort of color their
wider understanding of the of of the
ethnicity
um which of course which is of course uh
deeply unfair you know because
uh imagine that you like do do you
remember the uh oh adam kira thank you
very much for 2000 foreign
you are in fact a king
and as all men are uh wow nice
damn the it's a [ __ ] traffic jam here
so okay i'm gonna take out this traffic
light for now um so
what was i saying
anyway so
the solution to our problems
let's see one second
right so so the the the solution to the
problem with the roma is
i mean it's a it's complicated
and b
it will not be solved through any of
these [ __ ] intuitive like
oh you know we're just gonna we're just
gonna do this or that and like you know
just like one
big
swing of the hand and that problem is
gone like no no no no no
uh
wait i'm trying to i'm trying to
remember what i want to say about this
regarding this
it doesn't come to mind unfortunately
anyway uh the thing is i i have so many
thoughts floating around in my head
right now it's hard to keep track okay
now we can enable the normal european
theme so that the [ __ ]
commercial things can grow
okay good
okay so
uh i'm interested i'm interested about
solutions to the problems and not to
just like whine about it or just like
act smug about it
uh
and this actually triggers a lot of
people you know
for some reason
uh
yeah yeah your stadium is right here
uh and so
and so people let their
once again their bad experiences color
their understanding or some some
next level traffic ai you're saying here
so people that people that bad
experiences color their understanding
and oh yeah i remember what i wanted to
say it's so [ __ ] unfair that for
example
uh in like if you are
a white person
a
western member of the hawaii
civilization
um
you go
to a country right
and then you do some stupid [ __ ] like
for example
like
which one was that which one's those two
guys logan paul right
logan paul and his little [ __ ] japan
bit you know the the suicide forest and
whatever i don't know if you know
what what that was about if not then
good for you
basically dude
this is like it's like [ __ ] like
the ultimate like dude bro epic lol
youtuber
uh kind of like a fredro dumbass at
least that that's what he was like back
then
um
now we're on the now we're on the on the
uh
redemption arc ironically
and
so they went he dude went to japan
uh oh yeah train trains rights guys
trains rights thank you alex and thank
you for the five euros uh so dude went
to [ __ ]
japan
just like his video is just like
secondhand embarrassment
oh adam kira thank you for the thousand
more foreigns you are indeed a king
uh kira means king hungarian by the way
so that's the joke
um so
that dude went to japan
and just like if you watched that video
i watched like snippets in it i think
from like h3h3 or something
it's just he just like like i i got like
secondhand embarrassment from that it
was so [ __ ] like bad
dude was just like acting like a
complete like like a [ __ ] uh out of
control spoiled kid
just like a hooligan as he put it later
on it's like a complete [ __ ] dip [ __ ]
like just being rude to people
uh [ __ ] thrashing public property
uh
you know and and uh just just like
being a [ __ ] idiot
uh in general now the question is though
uh
like okay so imagine imagine if it was a
black person doing it or or the imagine
that this took place in europe and it
was a roma guy
do you think these
do you think the
reception of that might be a bit
different well different in the sa in
the sense that uh
different in the sense that
uh
it's like
that that uh okay how should i put this
it should it would be different in a
sense that with logan paul
people
did not call for the extermination of
the white race and they didn't launch
into lengthy discussions about white
people's skull shapes
and how it
affects their
[ __ ] behavior right
so if a
white person or in that case a non-roma
european does something which is
uh which is a
which is not socially acceptable like
this that doesn't contribute to this
huge social pressure
towards white people right whereas if a
if you're a black guy or if you're a
roma guy or whatever like a non-white
guy
does something dumb
then
then people immediately start discussing
this [ __ ] the [ __ ] skull shape right
uh and ironically enough oh amg thank
you for the 50 euros paydays tomorrow so
thought to toss a bit towards something
good thank you
it will indeed good
go to uh
good causes
so the thing is
this is what i find ultimately
the most unfair right
and what lots of people tend to just
completely ignore that
the social pressure against non-white
people in our society is very real right
like if you if you have a video where
it's like a white guy [ __ ] like i
don't know it's like kicking a dog or
something then people are like oh what
an [ __ ] if it's a black guy then the
comments like hey guy guys
guys
i'm i'm not racist but
and then the reply studios are like
n
i
g
g like the separate comments different
people n i g g e you know
and the same thing happens with roma
actually
uh if
if a roma person if if he why if a white
hungarian like a non-roma hungarian i
should say [ __ ] up then hey what a dumb
ass if a
roma person [ __ ] up then oh well let's
let's see how this how this how this uh
reflects on the roma community as a
whole because um are there is this
genetics or called hmm you know all
these
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] discussions uh
which are just not happening with with
uh with uh
with a
white folk you know
and this is actually the problem and
this this is what what people don't see
uh
from those people who go like blood and
soil you know when it comes to their own
issues
uh this is what people these people
don't see
uh
and they i believe they should consider
it at least because you know and uh the
way i read it actually uh discrimination
in society this is this is very
important uh
discrimination
in wider society
is one of the primary reasons
of the
for the uh
lack of success for the for roma kids
being unsuccessful at school
and uh
this really is uh
i mean this really is uh uh the case
because
society pressuring you
society putting pressure on you
society putting different pressures on
you
can hugely influence your relations to
society you know it might it might
um
it might uh
just
sort of make you give up uh after a
while basically you know no one's
supporting you no one gives a [ __ ] about
you in fact people actively
some people actively want to see your
life be worse right
if you're roma in europe then that that
can just like really
if this goes on for like
year after year after year or yeah ever
since you've been born that kind of that
kind of sucks away your motivation to be
a
part of part of society you know to
integrate because like at that point
what like what what the [ __ ] would you
integrate everyone [ __ ] hates you you
know um
at least that's your perception that is
not the case obviously i've heard this
article uh by the way currently we were
seeing the uh currently we're seeing the
uh the uh contrast between the european
and uh american suburb feel free to take
in the view as i
talk at you
so
the thing is
wait this is not this is not complete
yet
and there we go we need to
oops where are we
yay
i hope it will fit
there we go
so this is okay so
happens to me every time europe versus
um america right so
and so okay uh we're gonna we're gonna
go through the we're gonna go through
the the uh
uh
both neighborhoods what they're all
about etc and uh then we're going to uh
fix the american suburb and we're going
to start the simulation over here all
right so
the thing is
i've read this article about uh about
roma people looking for
apartments
in budapest and we are talking about
roma with with
like perfectly ordinary roman people
some graduated from university or
studying at university currently they
have stable jobs everything like the
their lives are in order
um
and um
basically like
it's incredibly hard even for them to
find a place to live in budapest because
lots of lots of property owners are just
like yeah yeah roma need not apply [ __ ]
you uh
they actually write it in the
description of like
i like
that flat this big this is their
features plus i do not expect
applications from roma
you know and um
and so
this is actually like this is you know
can we agree that this is not so good
for integration like if if society
reviles you
for no reason for no good reason but to
the point where you you can't even get a
[ __ ] roof over your head then
it's
and that kind of hinders integration
doesn't it um and of course people at
this point would say well then
if you know if if if well then if roma
don't want to integrate because of that
then that's on them well then well not
really because if you want to establish
a society which is a working society
which is functional cohesive
um
and just like doesn't go out of out of
its way to like [ __ ] with people
well then
the the majority society also has a
uh
a role in this like the
the majority society also has to
contribute
towards
uh towards uh the the integration uh
the integration uh
measures right and like and this is once
again like this is a big by the way this
is a big [ __ ] trigger a trigger word
for for lots of europeans
that like oh why well what do you mean i
should do something about robot
integration look they should fix their
own stuff like
sure they should fix their stuff but
society
majority society should also
uh
should also
you know help this process if have you
watched my video about personal
responsibility for example this is
exactly that like telling wrong people
to integrate is like ben shapiro pulling
up to the [ __ ] ghetto and saying
start the business
dorky okay maybe he wouldn't say that
but he would think that
so um
and so
right so it's it's a it's a two-player
game basically and but the first step i
believe needs to be taken by a majority
society we get a
super chat from darius 20 danish crowns
some government money for a light rail
in europe ha
yes uh we'll get to it in a moment
right so my uh so i think i think that's
my biggest grievance with people who are
just like yeah [ __ ] gypsy it's like okay
okay so you said that you get that off
your chest
what's next
i don't know [ __ ] gypsies double okay
whatever
uh yeah so uh the in the
the social the programs i plan to donate
the money that i collect today
will be
to uh to uh of course to uh uh civil
like uh ngos non-governmental
organizations that uh help for example
help finance the higher education costs
of roma youth and also those that that
that are um
sort of providing after school
activities and other programs for
children so they so they get so they
kind of get out from that home
environment uh that they are currently
in
and
and they get to they get to uh sort of
uh they'll have a better chance at life
basically a good anecdote
uh a good anecdote uh
from uh about this is from my grandma
actually who used to live in this
village called the borchod nadar in
hungary
uh
out in the east former industrial area
now it's very depressed lots of roma
folk um they had a neighbor again her
neighbors were all roma i mean they were
fine but there was like a family who's
like
parents are like parents weren't like
parents weren't you know
uh weren't exactly the upper class
and they
were then they themselves were rather
like
uneducated and they had a daughter who a
a little roma girl who
really sort of wanted to wanted to do
something you know she really wanted to
um
do something with her life and at school
you know at home her parents did not
motivate her at all right
uh i don't i don't know because they
didn't want to or probably also because
they didn't know how to
uh it takes some knowledge to properly
motivate your child obviously
and
in the end
so
the child like the girl didn't get any
motivation at school either because the
teacher was like yeah whatever just like
class is done whatever go home i'm going
going home as well then that's the end
of it and you know if you don't if you
don't understand
the blessing or something then well get
too bad so that was the attitude and so
the girl actually she actually showed up
to my grandma like because my grandma
knew now i need to go the girl actually
came to my grandma
and said hey uh
like excuse me
okay i need help but like she actually
went down went up to my grandma and like
asked for help
you know like
my grandma you know like she actually
sat down with her like she lives alone
my grandpa died like before i was even
born so she has plenty of time
she and she actually sat down with the
girl
and she
actually helped her helped her uh with
with her school stuff like this is like
she was like seven or eight years old
like they were talking about like how
basic calculus how to read how to write
because the school wasn't even [ __ ]
teaching on that right
or at least not properly and or at least
if a kid had trouble with that then the
school didn't like offer any additional
like any additional help they were just
like yeah okay whatever just good luck
and um
and so uh
basically and so
they did so the girl showed up to my
grandma like she kept coming but like
the fact that it was only the old lady
uh
next door who was like
actually spending time with her who was
motivating her
no one at home no one at school nothing
just the old lady eventually her
motivation started to sort of you know
fade right
and my grandma said that like she she
was showing up
she was showing up she was coming to you
know coming for like her their little
sessions you know she was and she was
actually doing well like my grandpa
grandma could see that the girl was
actually smart like it's just that no
one was [ __ ] doing anything with her
you know
and so
she she came you know she actually
learned how to write properly learned
how to count etc etc once again she was
seven or eight years old so you know
and uh
and but eventually after weeks or months
like the girl just came less and less
and then she stopped coming because
like
there was no motivation she didn't see
the the end to this like
okay i she really wanted to do this but
then she was like okay but like why like
why am i doing this like no one's no
one's
no one's helping me no one wants to do
anything with me just the old lady next
door like what am i what am i doing and
then
she stopped coming
and then
i and then no no one knows how she ended
up
and if you think about how many
thousands or even tens of thousands of
kids are there like this
and
to this like to answer to this problem
with like gypsy bad like
that
okay it's like that's that's that's my
caveman [ __ ] take like holy [ __ ]
anyway so integration is much more
complicated there's lots of different
factors
here i would say integration should
begin at school first and foremost have
and uh not by not by giving every kid
like this the exact same treatment
whatever sure i mean when it comes to
like their value etc like sure treat
them like they're equal
because they are
um otherwise
some additional measures need to be
taken to compensate for certain kids
disadvantaged social background right
um this is why i believe by the way
um uh good morning to you too we all
need this revenge um
this is why i believe
that uh
like this is why i support uh
some versions of affirmative action
uh this one is gonna be one of my other
perhaps semi-hot takes by the way so why
do i support uh certain versions of
affirmative action
it's simple if you take two kids right
say let's say say that we're in america
we have a black kid from the ghetto and
we have a white kid from the suburbs
right
so they both
uh achieved equal
uh equal test scores right so there's
there's one space
there's one spot left at college there's
a white applicant there's a black
applicant the white applicant comes from
a
you know your
copy-paste general you know
suburban family and the black kid comes
from a an impoverished you know family
single mother household etc
um
and
you know
they they uh reach the same uh
they reach the same result uh on their
entry test which one which one do you
hire so
the meritocratic view on this would
would uh
uh dictate that it should be random
right so you should just whatever 50 50.
they have the same result however if you
take into account
that very likely the black kid had to
work much harder to get there than the
white kid
then the merit the merit scale tilts
towards the black blackhead immediately
right because it's much easier to reach
that sort of uh that that high of a
score if you have a very solid very
affluent supporting background behind
you whereas if you don't have that well
guess what you have to you have to work
a [ __ ] off a lot harder to get there
so that's why i would say
uh we we would i would support
affirmative action programs which at
least take that into account right to a
certain extent that uh largely
a person from a disadvantaged background
uh
who who
ends up in a a uh
who ends up with a college where this
goal they
score they worked much harder
than chances are than
someone from an affluent background so
that's why i would say
um that's why i would support a version
of affirmative action of course i mean i
wouldn't support something like oh you
know you're black you're oh your skin is
black that means you're accepted like no
no no who does this you know
uh anyway
but like of course conservatives
uh like shouting men like ben shapiro
imagine these [ __ ] acceptance
uh like affirmative action acceptance is
like you know
black guy comes in like you know [ __ ]
head butts the secretary like spits on
the floor
like i'm not going to do the black voice
but like
but like just acts like a dip [ __ ] like
hey i'm [ __ ]
whatever
stereotypical black name jamal and i
know how to
shoot hoops and do crack and i
do carjack
like i
you know i steal cars in my free time
call me and then the white kid comes in
and it's like hi i'm i've been a good
christian boy ever since i was like one
year old and i donated all my money to
like charity and i got perfect sat
scores and i'm i'm just you know and
then you know
please let me know and then and then the
the [ __ ] the acceptance like the
person responsible for the acceptance is
like
you know like
you know which one should i choose like
no no no no that's just a just a
complete uh like conservative meme like
that just doesn't happen anyway so yeah
so that's my hot take towards uh that's
my hot day for uh
uh
for the support of certain forms of
affirmative affirmative action i would
say which i believe would be a
meritocratic uh principle in this case
anyway
i have a super chat
and uh
yeah i smoke crack and do carjacks adam
something 20 20 exactly
literally me
uh five dollar five euro super chat from
what where hire from velvedic that's
slovakia here in bratislava
the commies did car-brained [ __ ] were
only now beginning to fix demolishing
half of old town to build a motorway oh
yes
uh that's something that's uh something
which is funny that like all these all
these uh conservative
uh not conservative they were
conservative for their time all these
like
politicians during the soviet era they
just like mowed down
they had this hobby of like mowing down
uh
you know uh city centers and then
building freeways in the middle of them
because back then that was the symbol of
modernity
i'm sorry
but as you all know
it's uh it's uh uh oh it's not that
that isn't really the case
uh right
okay so this is the point
where
i'm opening paint
and i'm going to do a
i'm going to do a thing
i'm going to do
uh in the meantime wait let's see how
the city is doing
okay nothing catastrophic so this is the
point where i'm going to put on
cinematic mode
like this so you can observe the beauty
that is
there are these suburbs here
and i
am going to do something
this
all right
so uh be right back 10 minutes and uh
behave okay so have fun until then among
each other
man's gotta eat
all right hello
oh yes my my asphalt was delicious
mmm
all right now youtube is back online i
hope
um oh economics explained hello
are you here to explain some economics
you're just kidding let's see
uh
let's see
good
all right looks like we're up and
running youtube did [ __ ] itself
i'm sorry
me reload
okay good
so i believe we're back online
i'm here with you
jesus christ what happens here
everything's burning down
oh yeah because i have the
disaster nice
okay so it's time to put in some like
god like the [ __ ] disasters
oh and no no uh story nice
the uh disastrous dlc
for
city skylines was unitedly a disaster i
think
because it's it's so dumb uh
like it doesn't really add anything of
value to the game
and it's like okay if if this if this is
what you spend money on if this is what
you spent your [ __ ]
finite energy
and resources on then it's like
okay well
could have been
something better i guess
like the trains dlc please
will
494. thank you very much
thoughts on london mayor sadiq khan and
on london urban design in general too
what's your opinion on anarchism and
noam chomsky love your videos thank you
so let's answer that question
uh
um
so
um what my opinion is on sadiq khan
i heard some good things about him
actually
uh
for example
uh he instituted
measures such as
um
like if your office or like if you build
a new building which is near a uh
which is near good public transit links
then
then you you have to um
you have to
uh basically uh leave out um parking
spaces parking garages
from the project
because you have good access to public
transit so why would you so that's very
good actually uh one big recurring
problem is uh
in europe at least is that in historic
centers these new [ __ ] office
buildings are getting put up and uh
below them there's like this gigantic
parking lot and then like
dude like if you if you uh construct an
office building with like you know
eight 500 spots in it in the center then
that parking lot will be filled up you
know uh
by cars
who that that will come in to use that
parking spot
so
yeah okay so uh let's get down to
explaining
to explaining what is going on here
not here specifically
this i think we can safely disregard
there we go
there we go
so ignore that please uh just
okay yeah it looks like i don't know
uh
fires left and right all right um so
right so uh
hmm
so what's going on here
is that we have oh yeah that's my that's
my mug we're in germany
uh what's going on here is that as you
can see we have a uh
wow
oh look a rail jet nice
rip frame rate also
let's observe the rail jet
[Music]
it's an austrian one
uh right so there's no public transit
here yet so people are still taking
their cars here
uh but only it's so dumb because they
will spawn there at the door
anyway um so what's the difference
between
just [ __ ] crisis fire
uh
so what's the difference between these
two areas so of course one is rip
walkability and there is yay walkability
um these are two
suburbs which contain
i would say
similar amounts of people the european
one of course contains a bit less but if
i filled out this hole right here
then uh it would they would basically be
equivalent so the american suburb is
really dragged out and uh
and uh because this was built like
in the 50s 60s and 40s even something
like that
and
it there are roads going through it uh
everywhere so as you can see and as you
can see there are definite clusters here
like a sports uh thing ignore this as i
said uh commercial
also commercial here plus like also
stadiums uh they are really clustered in
one place uh we got like some schools
here with some gigantic parking lots
next to them of course because every kid
should take their car to school
obviously
uh [ __ ] real safety um
and the whole the street uh the street
design is just like this very relaxed
spread out just do whatever you want etc
uh and of course this makes the entire
area very very core centric and
of course there are lots of callers acts
from
um like if you if you live here for
example and your friend lives here then
you know you can't just like go over you
have to like get in your car and go like
all the way here
um it just incentivizes long travel
and
one has to wonder
one has to wonder whether
such layout is not just a secret handout
for the for the oil industry
right
almost um yeah so
and over here ignore the forest fire
that's just like that's just bad game
design it's okay um
so here in a european settlement like
usually these uh places have uh
oh the vanilla train yeah
um
usually settlements like this has have
uh
uh sort of more like grid or like more
clumped together uh uh
structure because uh usually what you'll
find is that there's this main road
going through the settlement and around
it there was like you know first just
houses along the street and then like
additional streets were added later on
like more systematic
uh
like a grid
but still the the uh village sort of all
these settlements sort of
uh self-replicated in the sense that
this type of ideally this type of
of of arrangement
was just like
multiplied uh
as you can see here so settlements like
this where the [ __ ] are my
there we go i hear a helicopter
there we go there it is
i'll go ahead and put out that
fire
symbolizing the the game design process
of the disasters dlc so
so over here uh
two major uh centers of this of this uh
of this area
uh
first off we have of course the the
traditional center you know with the
i don't know why there are houses here
it didn't mean
that
but there are um
all those things so we have of course
the traditional village center like town
center with the church and everything
uh
uh which
i would say that's the more historical
like for uh in in depending on how old
the village is
that is
what got there first
and then
sometimes the newer center
is around the train station which we
don't have any buses here and city
skylines is you know
has a very
smart traffic management system as you
can see
so uh
let's just let's just do a one-way road
here instead and
like a like a giant
roundabout
this is a jojo reference uh yeah so
uh and normally there's also buses uh in
this village so as you can see like the
two centers there's one or two centers
and the point is that uh
here in such a such a settlement you
don't actually need to use the car if
you don't have to if you don't want to
you can access everything perfectly well
with
walking or cycling
the sports fields are integrated into
the village
so um
they're essentially within which kids
can actually walk to soccer practice the
as far as i know the the soccer mom
uh the soccer mom term comes from the
fact that many mothers
in the suburb just basically have to act
like a non-stop uh shuttle service
uh for their children because you know
sports practice you know football
practice soccer practice etc etc because
otherwise the children will not be able
to you know get anywhere um
so yeah and this is what this is kinda
what we want
um
and uh as we can see here this is
absolutely not the case so like this is
this is a [ __ ] fest over here
just utter catastrophe car centric um
you know i want to kill myself etc etc
so how do we fix this the criteria
on which
we will execute this
this little plan
is
[Music]
is that um
we are going to
uh modify things
with the least possible intrusion to the
existing networks the road network for
example so we might no excuse me uh
we might um add to it we might add
additional roads but what what is
already here
we are not going to uh particularly like
we're not going to really mess with it
okay so the chief the main problems are
of course
this thing here
this thing here
and this thing here and to some extent
this
these are huge clusters far from
everything and if you if you go back to
the zoning as you can see
uh this is zoned in a way that like you
know blue is commercial and then and
then uh
green is residential it's all over the
place mixed et cetera here it's it's
only here it's it's clustered uh
right
i swear this fires
so
how do you fix this right
that's the question well first off
uh we're gonna set up some rudimentary
public transportation here okay
uh the city is this way so
in in this in this uh situation we are
both of these suburbs are a part of a
larger city there are satellites kind of
and the city is here kind of sort of
it's not on the map
um
and you want to get people from here to
there
um
right
and so
what the first thing we can do uh all
right first off let's fix the
walkability issue
a bit
and that we can achieve by
essentially connecting
the dots
here
some houses might need to get torn down
i swear to god not enough
not enough garbage processing
uh
okay once again ignore this this is just
i'm just circumventing the city skylines
engines bs
uh yeah it should work like this
right so
what you can do with these suburbs is
you look at them and
you provide basically
um
additional footpaths for people
uh like
this kind of
so to
connect
these cul-de-sacs somehow
um
that means it will be much more
accessible this whole thing for people
uh
okay here we'll have to tear down a
house but in real life you know it's it
should be much easier like you can see
this kind of doesn't have a mechanic
where
where where you can uh sort of
sort of uh you know
take away from a parcel to
then
turn it into a pedestrian road or
something
so
this this is of course this is this is
just what we're doing here is
essentially firefighting um where
this design is bad all around and we're
just doing our best to
to fix it at least
reasonably
nice no destruction there good
so we're just doing our best to
basically not
you know to get uh
to not make not not make things worse
but keep in mind that this is like this
this is still like this whole
neighborhood is just [ __ ]
um
right
and so when when we're done with this
so when we have a sort of uh
like what we're doing here is
essentially we're emulating the grid
structure
uh of a traditional european settlement
which
like those settlements i mean there's a
reason why they are like that right
uh because that's that's what that's
what walkable was back then
and that is also today walkable
uh but back then you know people didn't
have cars they had to walk so they built
everything walkable
this is something that we have to
emulate somehow and they vary here in a
very like a very easy way
is to uh
just like designate some some like foot
pads here and there to to kind of try to
close the grid
it's so far it's only pedestrian but
that's fine solar satan thank you for
the two pounds i don't wear cat ears as
your public demands [ __ ] you
uh well i'm just kidding i love you um
but still [ __ ] you
so um
nice so what we um
so once you connect the uh like connect
a suburb of course it's not gonna be
like like a full
reconnect oh there that
walk in the fire my children
uh
this is gonna i'm not gonna do every
single one i'll try to do as many as i
can
uh
because otherwise we'll be here until
midnight but
as you can see here it's uh
okay whatever
there we go
so yeah um so basically after you like
once you emulate the the grid structure
this is this is very non-intrusive
actually
so um
just where we have space once i can see
these skylines is not really flexible
when it comes to these things but in
real life it's absolutely possible to uh
in many places at least to do such thing
and
with this at least the whole area will
be a bit passable you can either do it
with like
rows that are traversable by cars if you
want to
but uh
that's the idea so once we connect these
all these areas with uh
pedestrian pads i mean
the problem is still that uh
even though you connect everything with
pedestrian
uh access
there is just not much to walk to right
so what do you do it's like oh it's it's
a house oh it's it's another house i go
to this house i go to that house you
know so the best case scenario that you
could be doing here is just like cut
down on some of the car trips if the
locals want to visit each other
basically
so
but that's that's already good i would
say
plus you're creating areas which are
like you know not just not just not just
for cars
uh so that's definitely a plus
uh once again in real life you wouldn't
be bulldozing houses like this but in
cities skylines is very rigid
in this case so i just i just need to no
regrow anyway
the destruction part comes later
and
[Music]
sure in the meantime if you have any
questions feel free to add me or do
super chats once again we are donating
uh we're collecting donations rather for
uh
for uh non-governmental organizations in
hungary
who
busy themselves with helping helping
disadvantaged youth mostly rumor
uh
right
so
a neighborhood which is interconnected
properly
like this
or like better interconnected i would
say
then
[Music]
that's already a big step forward as
cool the sex are
dumb
and i was pretty civil civil right now
cul-de-sacs are stupid they are they
serve no good purpose
uh they isolate you from people
and uh
and it's it's just it's just making your
trip
longer than it needs to be here there
you go now even access to a sidewalk
from there
how nice
um
right so
the next problem though we need to
tackle i would say
is these big
uh commercial fortresses that we have
all around so how do we do that
um
by rezoning obviously so those parking
lots there's there um there was this
uh short-lived
unfortunately short-lived twitter
hashtag
like trending thingy that um i hesitate
to call it movement
but like what is it like hashtag black
friday parking something like that
and um
which showed us parking lots on black
friday
this gigantic [ __ ] parking lots in
america
um
which were built because of parking
minimums
and
which are also uh but which were
not completely fully like half empty or
something even during
times like black friday when everyone is
at the store right
so
um
that was the idea really
that these parking spots are just way
too [ __ ] big
and i was like why are they there for
and
this is what we're going to correct in a
moment
let me just
lay down a few roads here
okay we're doing walkway stalling over
here we're relocating like we're
evicting people
because they are
in the way of our
communist utopia of having walkable nice
neighborhoods
oh
i don't want a bridge here uh bryce
mcmake even thank you for the 10
australian that was hell riding from
australia a land of formerly great
public transport now only decent dish
really question have you ever been here
if not would you like to i've never been
there but i i would like to actually
i want to see straw good ol girl
straya some like
spiders eating kangaroos or some [ __ ] uh
yeah but uh
no an acquaintance of mine has been
there recently and she said it was super
cool so i do everyone to be there as
well
at some point
plus australian cities are supposed to
be super walkable oh yeah look we have
created a sidewalk to nothing oh well
uh
yes australia generally nice
under your current pm a bit cringe
i'm forced to say
what is this
but uh it's not you it's your government
don't worry about it
all right
oh yeah the snapping [ __ ]
you know like i've used snapping so much
that like might it just like snapped my
breath snapped my brain
and i cannot really exist without
[ __ ]
snapping anymore it's just part of who i
am now
i'm i'm half man half
snapping
all right we do have a rail here which
is not used unfortunately how how
terrible
uh right so but here we can we can of
course connect areas with
regular roads as well
which i think is uh
also important
because of course ideally we would want
a completely car free utopia but
this
oh [ __ ]
feel free to clip me on that adam
something says [ __ ] rail
anyway
but it's also important that uh like
what you what you generally want to do
is uh cut down on car trips
or cut down on the number of car trips
and with that
and
for that you can actually create new
connections here
which will
basically have people drive less because
they don't need to you know
uh
they don't need to um
drive around in big circles around
cul-de-sacs all the time
oh he said sex call the sex
right
so this is uh right so this is something
which is uh
like of course once again like the idea
would be a car free society but until
then
you have to uh
you have to work with what you got so
we're just essentially uh at first we're
just connecting the dots here
um
no i don't want
solar satan five pounds thank you very
much how many lives will have to be
sacrificed for you to wear wear cat ears
well yours first and foremost
[Music]
thank you for 200 check rounds
uh
no actually i will not be wearing
carriers for now i
yeah i prefer your earphones
so
anyway for now that's that's decent
right
so
as you can see we are kind of sort of
emulating
a european-ish
area now you can actually drive around
and it doesn't make you want to kill
yourself
anymore and you that means you also
drive much less
because now you don't have to take
unnecessary detours just because you
know
harold and martha want their [ __ ]
nice view from their mac mansion
right
so as soon as we are done with the roads
connecting which is fun
uh we are going to
we're going to go on to reforming our
uh
commercial zones i should say this is
actually pretty okay like i mean as far
as american suburbs go
is there a discord server yes
the discord server if you go into my
channel
in the about section you'll find the
link i think i think that's where it is
right
so um
here too so yeah
the big problem is the first like the
most severe problem of course is the
cold decks
and i would i would even go so far as to
say that getting rid of the [ __ ]
golden sex is already half the battle
um
because now your your neighborhood is
actually passable
now this can go either way actually like
a passable neighborhood can mean [ __ ]
transit traffic but here what we're
talking about is like passable by the
inhabitants themselves
uh yeah so as you can see where here
we're coming around nicely this area i
won't bother for now
that's for later
and um
yeah
[ __ ] suburbs man
and also disclaimer i am not a
professional urbanist so if you notice
that i i do something wrong while i do
that
it's actually likely that i'm of course
like there's urbanism is very
complicated
like not not urbanism but like city
planning in general like professional
city planning um and here i would just
like to get a sort of a gist of it
what can be done but this is this is
though uh
this this also what i'm doing can also
be done largely in like a
like a city level uh like a small town
level
so i don't think there is anything
overtly
wrong with it because this is a very
simple stuff
all right
who knows maybe maybe i'm on just a
graph of you know the less you
understand something more the more
confident you are about it
right so let's connect these roads
due to city skylines weird
[ __ ] zoning system it like houses
keep disappearing which shouldn't
ideally but such is life
uh let's see
yeah so stuff like this this needs to be
bridged
[ __ ] circular cul-de-sacs no
gobi circular elsewhere
and uh yes there we go
dead ends
cul-de-sacs these weird-ass roundabouts
they all need to go
but this is only part of the problem
obviously so once we're done with the
i think it's uh i'm going to do this
part and then we're done with this
um
and i have a super chat
that's one second
i'll get to
so
uh currently it's
better
than it was
uh slightly
i'm gonna connect this as well here
and this as well
uh right
and i guess this is worldwide
[ __ ] it um right
so it's better than it was already so
like we're we're with all these like
what all these uh all these um
uh connections we're compensating for
the fact that it's all dragged out like
drawn out and there's no
um
there's no
uh
sort of this sort of packed dense great
structure uh once again one second let
me go through all these super chats
which
built up in the moment like in the
during these times that i was talking
yan yano sheikh your last video was
great during the entire video i thought
you would not mention pumped storage
hydraulicity
uh that all has but you didn't
uh awesome well thank you very much and
thank you for the donation oliver varko
good luck adam what are the charity
slash organizations i spent enough time
uh on the alpha the child to know how
underprivileged my children are yes uh
one of the one of the uh ngos will be
roma versus
that's the um
that's the uh that's the one that's
supporting roma youth
uh get higher education and the other
one like help them in their uh
sort of uh
like have them financially and and stuff
like that and uh i'll i'll explain it in
a community post and the other one is
the so-called invisible school so to
speak
to um
which is uh which which does similar
things but it's more more for like
children
to like basically getting children off
the streets and then having some
activities for them and to
take them out to take them out of their
home environment
which is usually uh very detrimental to
their development bryce mceven 20 or
australian dollars thank you australian
cbs are very walkable um
cbs are very walkable
the problem with one
i'm living in is half of it was built to
the old walkable suburbs with public
transport design and other half was
built in the same way as
the usa
uh yeah
right so
here we go
it's
mostly
okay
it's mo now it's it's it's it's kind of
sort of okayish here and there right
so this is the first step right here
um
now there now you can actually like
traverse through the neighborhood like
you can you can go from like one
street to another
without actually having to uh
uh drive
50 miles we're using burglary in islam
because this is very american damn it
urge murray brother why are we usually
[ __ ] gay ass metric [ __ ]
what are europeans who are whose
countries are superior and basically
every
important metric i'm just kidding
but they kind of work um
so yeah uh
great great great great
get that grid going
you know from well that's your problem
you know alice is all all about make it
more rigid
i'm like hey yeah make it more gritty
you're right uh super chat from
government governments explained five
dollars thank you very much
do you think there's any chance
jesus do you think there's any chance
u.s cities could have mini gardens city
estates replace suburban sprawl the land
certainly exists
um
mini mini garden mini garden city
estates
of
i mean it's possible uh
although i think this this would be
a
sort of uh
this would come later i feel like
uh like first we need to put out the
fire which is this thing it's a complete
trench fire
but um
i've actually never heard that much
about these little gardens seriously you
mean like combined
um
no no
if you could link me uh stuff about that
on discord i'd be grateful actually
uh i'm interested
okay
so we're connecting to this arterial
road which we'll get to don't worry
um
and uh
as you can see
it's looking a little bit better it's
still complete ass don't get me wrong
but uh
but uh we're slowly slowly slowly
getting
there so grid
grid grid grid
[Music]
and so
what you want to do here
after you're done with this and we're
pretty much i think done
is that
now we have to tackle the issue of okay
why do these people drive
well they drive because they want to go
to our
well the cats are having fun uh
so they drive they want to drive to this
area here which is our imaginary city as
i said
and uh oh by the way these black spots
are the forest fires thanks to this like
very well made
dlc which i really like except they
don't um
so
next up we have to
sort of eliminate these things right
here right
so and and uh we can do this by actually
swatting two flies at once
uh what we can do is uh
is uh
essentially
eliminate these parking lots
parallel to setting up some rudimentary
uh public transit slash bike
infrastructure
and uh using the all that leftover space
to for densification so we're going to
do that one second
there we go i'm now sufficiently
refreshed
and
filled up all these frame rates i dude i
love them
all right
so malls like this
like they they [ __ ] have to go
uh they need to be ideally they would i
would i would want to see them converted
into something useful
community spaces even a library etc
something like that but of course
this doesn't uh this cannot be on a city
skyline so we're gonna pretend as if
that happened um
so the fact that we have a bunch of
commercial uh buildings here is good is
the starters what we need to do now is
instead of these parking spots
we're going to do something else
okay if it worked but it doesn't
there we go
we need to delete them forever
uh
okay
i think it's a prop
or decal whatever decal
uh
there we go so parking spots btf owed
uh it's actually a huge problem like
parking spots take up a huge amount of
space
uh voso
uh fabulous trillion dollars thank you
very much i need to know the cat's names
they're so cute
as i said uh
friedrich carl
dries foreign
so
okay we're gonna
eat this out
uh this can actually stay so
for now anyway
so uh what we're doing here now is we're
converting like we're we're gonna take a
look at how much space we have left
after we get rid of these parking lots
uh
of course the game is doing some math
calculations now where to put all these
cars
uh
right
so let's connect this here
i don't know the police station is in
the way
they're snapping out no i don't have
action no snapping anyway like this
whatever
uh yes so
uh we are going to
now actually need snapping
we are going to
uh
do this so we're gonna basically zone
out this entire area now in real life
this would this would be much more
complicated slash creative
but city skylines doesn't like we have
to work within what we have
uh
and i don't have any of these advanced
mods that help you do just that uh
coopers thousand foreign thank you not
much to spare but i grew up in a small
village with higher population and i
strongly agree the increase that
actually needs to be taken for them
thank you
uh um i agree
as well
um
yes
so some more more connections well
that's why this stream is here for where
we're gonna
of course it's a small difference that
we can make with this but
otherwise
otherwise like of course the real
solution would be the systemic
solution to the problem but in the
meantime until
we get conservatives out of government
who actually don't give a [ __ ] about
then the situation then we can actually
make things better but a little bit
better not like this won't solve the
issue obviously
but
we can make things better uh
sort of incrementally marginally
and hey if if this stream will help
if your donations will help say i don't
know
10 20 30 kids get some get get like get
their life in order then that was
already worth it and all i had to do for
that is
play city skylines for eight hours
so
hell yeah
so um we have we have this big parking
lot area here
uh instead so what we got what we're now
getting into is the exciting part which
is densification
let me
uh
delete these
uh
here oh the game is just going nuts but
no because they cannot place all the
[ __ ] cars
uh
and as you can see oh there's the mall
this also has to go by the way big or
no you know what we're gonna leave it
[ __ ] it
um we're only gonna be that radical but
if it was up to me then i would i would
just convert those areas into some
something more useful like industrial or
warehouses uh because there was like the
big
big big
malls like this are very very much
detrimental to
uh
very much detrimental to cities
okay
so as you can see we are sort of we have
we have all this free space now that we
got rid of the
uh
parking spots
and um so what do we do with it well we
would need some some kind of like uh
zoning based
um
of course this commercial uh area cannot
stay so those those will have to uh
those will have to go at some point
um
and so
we're going to work some magic here
because
uh
first we're going to
zone this out okay first off uh one sec
i need to set up
the facts
where's
where's my zone
have you seen the it's called murica
there you go
didn't see the text so here we set the
policy
of uh
this is like cities skylines logic
circum
high rise ban where we don't want any
higher prices
of course we're going to encourage
biking
vip area
okay and electric cars whatever
they don't solve anything
anyway
sort of encouraging biking
etc
um
200 crowns thank you very much do you
think we should build more like what
european cities did at the end of the
19th century when city walls were
demolished and replaced by tenements is
this the right way to build local and
efficient cities well yes basically
because back then those cities those
cities are walkable by necessity by
almost by definition
because
uh
at the end of the day like back in the
day did not they did not have
any alternatives their cities had to be
walkable
because um
because uh like
otherwise how how the hell do you get to
get anywhere
um
motorization wasn't really a thing and
uh if we replicate that i think i think
we need to replicate a form of that
obviously we're not
we're no longer living in the uh
in the uh you know at the end of the
19th century however uh some elements
some elements of that
uh are nice and
all i'm saying is we should return to
monkey yeah
so
uh let's see oh this [ __ ] volume
okay so city skylines is pretty
particular about the volume like uh um
sound pollution
so we're gonna have to take some
shortcuts here because i i don't
normally normally this would not like
you could live next to this and we'll be
fine
but not according to city skylines
so what we're going to do is we're going
to disown these
oh this frame rate yeah the green game
is like re reorganizing all the uh
all the routes
right now
uh
okay
[Music]
there we go
so
uh let's see how our
volume looks okay so we're gonna what
we're gonna do is to insulate this thing
we're gonna down put down a park
because we all like parks they're nice
and
green and [ __ ] there is like trees or
whatever
um and what we're going to do is we're
going to emulate
a uh sort of
mid-rise area like we're going to
emulate here a european style city
center like town center rather
and that means we can
er we it's like in suburbs that are
built up
i would just like
just to do rezoning uh
you know buy out parcels properties etc
and uh
which i believe would be an investment
which would return itself because
suburbs are an economic drain
um
on uh on cities usually and uh however
if you densify etc then that will be a
jump in tax revenue so for for so f what
money
the city can spend
on um
on densification etc like that would
actually come back
i would say
of course this is armchair
accounting what i'm doing right here
uh right
okay so uh
and
the point is that over here
we
have uh all this
we have a larger influx of people here
of course people are moving in etc in a
bit
and that means
uh
the population will concentrate uh here
in this area in these areas i will get
into a second
but this anyway this this this city
skyline style uh sort of sound
volume
loudness system like i don't really
appreciate that it's very dumb
uh right
so okay so what we can do actually is uh
we have all these strodes here
so at first we the first step can be
that we
make them a bit more
uh
i should say
pedestrian friendly so this is a large
avenue with grass however there's only
one traffic lane and there's some happy
little trees
so
one thing which is important which not
many decision makers realize is that
induced demand works the other way
around
so if you put in if you put in lanes
you'll have
more traffic
and if you subtract lanes
you'll have less traffic
given that if there's an alternative
obviously
to which we're gonna get in a second
so
what we're doing here is uh essentially
making things less loud so like
uh and humanizing the environment a bit
so that
so that
people will be actually people will be
able to actually uh
survive
in this area
and the
noise pollution should go down a bit now
no god i did okay fine
uh right
and so
what we might want to do is uh we might
want we want to fill up all these gaps
here
once again i need to work around city
skylines
peculiarities such as
such as this
i'm going to just like put in a park
there just like plug the hole
yeah
because i mean normally this would not
work like
there could be mid-rises here and no one
wouldn't care but
city skyline says that people will uh
like be become deaf after living there
and then they're gonna die because
you know
they'll need to be taken to hospital
hospital because
uh
the mall was too loud you know next day
oh
well um so but i i
i would hope that everyone is getting
the sort of the the uh the spirit of
what i'm doing here
uh so
um
we have all these sort of big empty
areas what do we do with it
uh it's
we can actually concentrate the uh we
can actually concentrate
uh
commercial a bit like that's that's not
necessarily bad
uh as long as they are close to uh
close to residential
uh
[Music]
right because then we have we can have
this sort of like a bits
bit concentrated with convoluted
uh
center but that should be this should be
okay so we have the mid risers getting
built up right here
and um also here i'm gonna i'm gonna
fill out these so once again what we're
doing is we're emulating
a sort of european city core
it's imperfect it's
kind of man like janky
but
but nonetheless it will do its job so
um
make it more dense is the
yes and then
in a second we'll we'll get into public
transportation so that's gonna be the
whole fun bit
uh
there we go
everything is neatly zoned out
and
yeah like where i live there's this
there's this little um there's a smaller
village next to next to like this is
germany uh there's a smaller village
next to this this um
this uh
city i like not village but like a town
you know which is next to it and they
built in the middle of this town this
this big
uh
big uh like business center thingy and
like not business center but like a
shopping center like like a strip mall
basically but in the middle of a town
and it's ever since covered it failed so
[ __ ] hard it's unreal
there's just not enough people
there and um
the transportation is is like like
luster to say the least and i'm being
very polite there
so okay uh
we're going to start filling out this
area as well so once again
it's [ __ ] well
anyway um
i just have to of course as i said like
for the fifth time already like i'm also
battling city skylines here
so what i'm gonna do is i'm going to
place like roads with trees because that
actually cuts down on the noise
yes
and so
we have
a sort of basic rudimentary grid
structure
haphazard
of course because we have to work with
what we have
and
we're going to actually improve this
right now still the the residential and
the commercial are very much
separated from each other so we need to
do here
is to
mix them up a little bit
this is the ultimate armchair urbanism
stream holy [ __ ]
uh anyway we're having fun we're
enjoying
we're enjoying the trip
and so
uh
okay let's speed it up a bit
yes
and
we're also going to add some of that
here somehow
okay i need to correct this
since comments can be a bit unrest in uh
non-responsive sometimes all right
uh
yeah also hey you know what
jesus
believers
this is now george orlando's 1994.
goodbye
this is this is
i'm literally stalin
all right so um
[Music]
actually you know what [ __ ] it we're
gonna get rid of this
these structures aren't complicated
anyway they look big
they
you know
seem like they're important there we go
it's just usually just like a metal or
or [ __ ] wooden frame
and on it there's like a [ __ ] uh some
metal sheets and then and then that's
your that's your mall
um
or like whatever that was uh yeah i
guess it wasn't one right so
once again city skylines
some happy little trees because
otherwise people will die
um
right
and actually now we can
cut down a bit
on the commercial here
so
parts of this can go away
and then re
appear somewhere else
around here basically so we we want to
keep the commercial stuff close to
people
um
all right
here we go
mixed zoning
uh yes and but that's that's that's what
it's called by the way like that's the
technical term for it mixed zoning
uh in america it's very often uh
or like american style projects i should
say
very often the case is that uh
there's as i said before there's like
big blocks of light of just like uh like
a
singular type of of of uh
of building
and no one cares about uh
like you know proximity because everyone
has cars anyway so whatever
oh and i don't want to neglect you guys
let's look at the chat a bit
thoughts on hassan abi
i like him he's cool he covered some of
my videos i think
he's
doing good work as in being a a uh left
leftist streamer by the way we're doing
uh bike lanes now
they're they cost virtually nothing and
they're
they're at least they're gonna like
oh destroying a few houses you know but
like you know
the
bicycle god demands their sacrifice also
city skylines this shitty [ __ ]
uh
curve
oh yeah i think he's doing a good work
the left does need i think
uh
someone like him
just like is essentially like a a
a leftist ben shapiro but but
intelligent and has good points
uh that's that's my that's my take on
the song
like benshop you left
i i i say ben shapiro in the sense that
that uh
like he is like he's a like you know
like a youtube talking man
who uh
who is part of this like adjacent to
this like meme epic memer culture which
is which is i think important
uh we want to bring over as many people
as we can from from like the zoomers and
everyone
because uh they're gonna be like you
know
otherwise
otherwise they're gonna be preyed to the
far right and so
for like the the i'm sorry the alt right
the the the identitarians the christian
nationalists they are
[ __ ] know how they call themselves
[Music]
anyway so
the point is
that yeah i like hassan anyway uh next
question last little too much
i am literally stalling i know something
like yes
i am literally stalling adam something
2021 exactly
uh what's your one goddammit this
youtube chat
what's your opinion on llu potentially
closing down one of its lines due to
lack of funds brought on recovery what's
lu
uh
i'm wondering
if you could explain if you could fire
me uh if you could at me and explain
that would be nice
and on something are you wearing socks
yes oh dude it's [ __ ] cold here are
you kidding me
i know something trams or no trams you
can have both bike lanes and trams oh
you just wait [ __ ] just kidding
i love you i i don't i don't actually
think you're a [ __ ]
i don't know about your sexual
preferences
um
adam stalin yeah
um
okay
noise here is my biggest concern really
[ __ ] city skylines
but um
okay so as you can see this this this
center like we're getting somewhere
already
the hospital kinda sort of needs the
parking space for now
um but as we cut down on
um yeah
guigibo typical stalin still building
the dead road
yeah like with the bones of
these states enemies uh
okay so
this area right now in the middle is is
getting there right
there's uh there we go we got the
residential areas here some limited
immunities
uh hospital nearby this [ __ ] thing
this
what is this suburban energy school yeah
okay so but but this is still not like
this is half done right this is we
cannot stop here
um
so this area is already like this in
spite of everything being like uh 10 000
miles away from each other it's it's
okay ish
already like for if you live here you
can get to this place on your bike or
like uh yeah basically essentially on
your bike maybe even on foot within
reasonable within a reasonable a
reasonable
amount of time
so you don't need to be that car
dependent
now the problem comes when you
have to get to the city then you have to
get in your car and just drive there so
we're going to
uh remedy that
problem right now
am i going to build a train here you
might be asking well not really you'll
see
mikaloy jones 200 crimes thank you very
much
uh just sending a little bit of money to
help the cause it's not much but still
better than nothing hope you have a
great day well every bit helps thank you
very much
it's actually very nice uh
seriously like uh uh you sent 200 crowns
that's like
uh
what's that's
like a uh eight bucks that's very nice
already uh for eight bucks uh like on
the website they were detailing okay for
like
five five seven bucks like that's
already like a one
one english
uh like private lesson for our first
student uh who's struggling with it so
like like if you
uh donating
just a couple of dollars that's already
like one
um
one
like practice class for a student like
helping them
adjust et cetera and
work down there they're handicapped
every bit helps seriously
right so here we have this [ __ ]
interchange right
which is in the way of our project so
this is something like
as i said in the beginning i said that
like um
that certain things like i'll try to be
as as uh i'll try to not touch the
existing road structure as much as i can
this is
not the case here these [ __ ]
interchanges they need to go
there's no way that a suburb can abide
by like there's just absolutely no
uh chance of creating a a in the google
area with a highway internship
now this however
has to be coupled with something
we all like
not trains but something similar to
trains
and not electric buses either
this will be
this will be wait for it
trams
but these are serious scanners doesn't
have tram trains i would have said tram
trains if serious cannons had those but
unfortunately they don't
uh
so what we're going to do is here
where was it um
trams and we're going to build out a
trim line
now tramps can be pretty fast actually
now this will this will be that this is
a six foot six lane road we're gonna do
a lane reduction
so as you can see uh instead of six
lines we have two plus tram
uh we're going to do this
all throughout this area so the point
the idea is that the center like our new
center
is easily accessible with convenient
public transit
um
which takes you directly to the city so
the idea is that even if you go to the
city to and from you can just like
get down here get on the tram
and
get taken to the city
uh right
and this since the since our suburb
already has this layout of
uh everything
important is basically around the middle
we can
essentially just
drag out this this this this
trim line
drag it through the entire neighborhood
and this is actually how uh lots of
suburbs operate actually so most most
things are in the middle um next to this
like gigantic strode however if you put
in if you put some some work viral
public transit through there
then that's that's already [ __ ]
then that's already [ __ ] uh good
like
already [ __ ] good yes um
yeah
so one sec uh i got three super chats
thank you very much
um what in the american suburb is this
exactly
uh
uh so
do hundreds of crowns thank you and also
marcus thank you for 100 swedish crowns
uh do you think post sovereign countries
have an inverted sense of what is left
or right i mean in those countries the
left represented the old regime thus
making it more conservative better crows
like transforming currents thank you
very much
uh i do too so yaniroshi back to your
question um in soviet countries it's
actually a bit
in
it's okay
um so we differentiate between the
economy so left and right
usually go together in the u.s right
um
however well yes and however
in europe there is a big distinction
between
europe it's like it's like one more
dimension right there is
economic left and right and there is
political left and right and funny
enough in europe
uh
economic like uh
even parties that are there are there
are
the parties that are economically left
can be
like uh can be very very much right-wing
otherwise
um
so for example orban and in poland
kaczynski's government et cetera they
are real they're all about subsidies
uh welfare programs etc
and uh it's strange but hey that's
that's that's how they do it that's how
it'd be
um
and
so they're all about those all about
them welfare programs so are their
supporters
and um
it's uh
so in europe in europe the distinction
is not necessarily that clear like in
the us for example yeah like in the us
you know a [ __ ]
uh uh right-wing candidate will be like
you know
bootstraps hashtag gastepore no [ __ ]
uh welfare programs no nothing
just
yeah whatever in europe it's not so
clear-cut so
yeah
let me just go through some other super
chats but yeah but generally funny
enough though european far-right parties
in general
tend to lean left economically so you
know interesting
uh or so they say remember that the back
then in the
and i hate this because it's a thought
it's a thought-stopping cliche for
lots of people but the nazis also ran on
these huge economic platforms like these
very leftist economic platforms and then
the second they got to power they just
like whoop they just dropped it anyway
uh
i think so much trouble oh there we go
so um
other super chats
let's see uh kvivo five dollars thank
you i don't mind paying for another
lesson to explain why i was trying to be
sarcastic about the stallions very well
to nowhere thanks whatever it is okay
2d trash 5. thank you very much
existential horror of the american side
looking like a map of my hometown please
save us with trams and no more throats
well you can also save yourself my
friend or help your situation
um if you
if you have i i don't know about your
local
political situation
um what candidate what local candidates
you have and where etc
feel free to advocate for
for sensible
feel free to advocate for sensible
measures
locally like decongestion etc or just
like incremental reform such as hey
uh have a
cul-de-sac
connecting program you know so that
people will not
um be locked into these into these dead
ends you know
they have like a there's there's small
measures
you can advocate for which even the
local [ __ ] boomers would be like oh
it makes the thought you know so
i think that's something you can do like
take a look into it you know
what what can be done
okay so
we have okay this comes back here so
okay this is not of course an
engineering wise correct placement of
tram i'm just trying to put it through
here
i i gotta love this like almost perfect
90 degree angle um
right so
uh so our tram
and the point is that our tram actually
um
comes by oh you know what i don't know
we're gonna we're gonna do something
let's revert this [ __ ] uh our tram will
um
will go to the city but it will also uh
touch on
uh all the all the more important areas
here uh
but i'm getting a lot of super so one
second chris b twenty dollars again love
the content just woke up hello from the
west coast of the us well hello back to
you
and good morning
and thank you for 20
uh let's see [ __ ] youtube chat
okay good okay for now that's all the
supers uh
so we're going to get back to our
program here
uh here we have an intersection
uh which we can actually use later on
uh the tram
you just stay tuned for the rest
it's
this
abomination here is necessary i swear um
so
what we're gonna do here okay we'll
we'll get to this in a bit
um
right so here we have
we're gonna create a tram hook
right here
with some decongestion so public transit
measures have to go together with
decongestion
or like with lane reduction
ideally so here we're going to do
just just so it's just so we can set up
a very basic tram network for for
starters
what we are going to do here is we are
going to
create this hook
that's how is that right
yeah um
this is temporary uh this sort of trims
can turn around city skylines for for
some reason doesn't support like uh both
like trams that go both ways which is
pretty stupid
so
uh right
and
what we can do is we can continue our
densification here
so instead so since we have a trim line
which is about to start running
we can
uh cut back on the parking spots cutting
back on the parking spots the number of
parking spots is actually very important
either because
the more parking spots you have
the more
basically the more uh supplier you
provide for people who want to drive
which you want to generally avoid so
that's why we're doing it
so this is once again uh induced demand
but in reverse
uh and as soon as you provide the public
transit alternatives then then
you are uh
you're basically good to go
okay
so this goes through here okay i guess
i'll have to uh to do something about
this
um
yes so uh instead of parking lots what
we can do the following
um you know how in prague there's
barely any uh parking lots around even
the biggest stadiums
well that's because those places have
a good public transit
plus like parking spots for like buses
and stuff because people
football fans etc they usually get like
bust there to those to those events
um
although it's also true that in america
like uh these sports events are more
sort of everyday activities
in europe it's more for for like this
the the hardcore well it depends on the
country anyway but it's more more on the
more for these like hardcore
fans and neo-nazis quite often you know
happens happens
dumbass
people
okay of course we're gonna leave some
parking spots just much less and that's
that's the thing
uh if you leave much
if you if you decrease the number of
parking spots you're gonna have less
drivers
uh which is like well duh kind of uh
situation
but it's actually pretty interesting how
many decision makers don't realize this
you know
um
so this is why when you hear something
like
in the inner city in in x inner city
uh they're going to build underground
parking spots
uh
and then you you and then you you should
you can and should go
oh [ __ ]
because the problem with those is that
well those parking spots those three the
free capacity for the sake of drivers
what is it going to do is going to drag
in
more traffic
into the area
if you driving from the suburbs and you
know that inside the city there will be
a parking spot for you because there's
enough parking space then you will drive
in there
and so decreasing the parking capacity
in the
insa on the inside of the city
is actually something you want to do now
of course you will need parking spots i
mean obviously
some
at least but much less but here you know
since we're not living in like
you know a utopia we're gonna put up a
parking spot here
oh and uh the game helpfully deleted all
the concrete from uh
underneath the buildings
damn dude how do streamers stream for
like 12 hours and not have their voices
like you know go away i i already feel
like i feel it in my throat that my my
throat is complaining a bit that i've
been talking too much
but hey i'm talking to you guys so i'm
very happy about that so
i embrace the pre i embrace the pain and
burn it as fuel on my journey
all right
so
some parking spots here and we're going
to concrete this back because like you
know [ __ ] the environment
for boomers here uh there we go and plus
you know boomers like
why should they care you know they like
they won't they won't be alive for any
of the climate problems so
it's not their problem it's ours am i
right huh
okay boomer so
what we have here now is
yeah
some parking spots of course they are
still necessary if you are converting an
area from car centric to non-car
soundtrack then i mean it's not going to
go from like
one day
to another you know it's like it's not
going to be like a
it's not going to be a
short
process
and you will need to scale down
capacity for cars
over time
right
let's copy these things out and put them
here
i even forgot to put it here originally
nice
which is going like this
oh and it's all before of course thank
you citizens for simulating real life so
well
um
okay it goes like
this okay so the stadiums now have some
rudimentary parking much less than
before mind you
like seriously much much less than
before which is already very good
uh
so that means that if if there's an
alternative then people will take their
car like they won't take their cars in
fact
they will take public transit
um
so this place which will which we're
going to be setting up in a moment
uh there we go super chat 2d trash five
dollars thank you very much carry for
the throat with water milk honey tea or
something and stay hydrated for [ __ ]
sake like what do you think i'm doing
huh
pouring beer on myself that's what i'm
doing
all right so um
let's see
i'm gonna
now actually like my throat is fine i
just kind of feel it like a bit scratchy
uh but like yeah nothing serious don't
worry
oh okay nevermind
so with right click if you if you select
the like this thing
the clip with the right click you can
actually bring back the asphalt
i love mods
there we go now it looks much more
authentic
well as far as the skylines goes so
we've cut down on parking spaces because
what we're going to do here
is
dramatic music that mp3
uh we're going to get rid of this as
well
because we are going to have some next
level
galaxy brain
transit solutions
amazing
oops
well that's not what i wanted to do
amazing
there we go
so
as you can see here we have
a trim line coming in so what we're
going to do is what usually works with
usually work that we worked on in europe
well is that the truth
the trams
stop
immediately
within walking distance
from these areas
and the tram will have its own dedicated
lane because we're that generous
actually trims should like uh to see
trams get stuck in [ __ ] traffic jams
and everything i mean that's that's
pretty uh
that's like ah
that's that's it's pretty dumb planning
uh and i wish they didn't do that
where was this though i just saw it
not here not here
um
in the meantime uh
was it here no here yeah no
i'm gonna
oh it's in here okay so
uh right so uh i've seen pictures from
like america from detroit and [ __ ]
where um
oh we're gonna make a big
circle around here from like detroit and
[ __ ] where uh it's like there's the tram
and the tram is
it's like it's like a six lane road
and the tram is
sitting in a traffic jam
because
from the six lane road they didn't
allocate two lanes back to the tram
and it's like
wha what
you know
it's pretty dumb
but uh some people just don't like these
people just usually don't don't think
about what they're but they're
like of course i mean everyone has car
brain from there so you know whatever
so okay uh what we have here is
a
an elevated second
oh proud hand thank you for ten or
syrian dollars here's some money for
saving the roman the
romani children yes thank you
uh it would actually be of great help
like these these ngos they are always of
course short on money the government
wouldn't [ __ ] help them
obviously
but but seriously like it's it's if if
if aid is organized well
then even
small amount like
from like from a
government budget perspective tiny
amounts can also do go a very long way
right
um
yeah so because the people who do that
stuff they know what they're doing and
they do it uh
they do it
um
basically uh
because of their values
okay so what we're going to do here is
we're going to transition this tram here
into
a light rail
almost as good
all lrt
almost
as good
as a train
almost
so how this system is set up
okay how the system is set up
is
the tram
of course
turns around here goes through right
here and we're going to concentrate
everything around this arterial road
which we will dig in just in a moment
um
and so it kind of
skips by this
[ __ ] thing right here
uh which we which we assume we cannot
bother for now because let's say that
this is like this is this is not
within the jurisdiction of the local
government
uh
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
take this light rail
and
we're gonna drag it out and see the
skylines is once again like the this
gradient manager this game is just
amazing
we're going to
pull out this
light rail line in a ditch apparently
two
oh because it's okay
nice
amphibian light rail how cool is that
so let's get back to this thing
little bridge
like a light rail bridge
by the way if if you think that any of
this is just like unfeasible from like
local but like uh budgets like uh
depending on how rich the area is then
sure
but uh
also keep in mind that america is there
like the richest country on the planet
so in an ideal world
it should not be available but it but it
is of course very often so uh
yeah okay uh
we're gonna follow
the ray oh actually um
cities kind of doesn't support this
unfortunately but uh
usually
uh-huh it doesn't support it but usually
you can connect
the light rail line with the heavy rail
so if you have any okay so for now it's
gonna we're gonna symbolize it in in a
way that like uh
uh the light rail will
go next to the heavy rail like really
close
uh
this is actually like a system like this
was recently set up in hungary
where uh the light rail line goes into
the city
works like a tram inside the city and
then comes out and works like a regular
train and those light rails actually go
pretty fast
so it's not like you know 50 kilometers
per hour or something they do i think
like
90 or something
which is pretty good so ideally so once
again this will symbolize the tram
going
on
on
heavy rail tracks
which tram trains can absolutely do
they're designed for that
and how are we going to get these people
to get on it we'll worry about that
later
um
for now some donors
yeah nanoshake we don't need we don't
you we don't need no tea or water when
we have beer that is cheaper than water
well you're in the czech republic yes
they actually had to um roll out
regulations saying how
in restaurants beer cannot be cheaper
that cannot be sold cheaper than water
combi 49 oh one of my mods i hope prong
won't fall to the hands of ods in the
2022 election so they can continue
improving stuff
uh
i also hope bruno gets a known ods
government audience is just scar brained
to a ridiculous degree yeah ods is the
is the is the classical boomer party in
the czech republic
still better than anno which is the
trump party basically yeah i'll fix that
later um
but still yeah like i i in happy like
the the place i lived in prague inside
prague there was like a that was run by
ods the the the um that party and it was
like the entire area was like super
duper car centric uh and nothing was
getting done like everything was just
like yeah whatever there was like my
favorite oh i'm gonna i'm gonna show
this to you actually
um
my favorite [ __ ] thing about trump
suicide fuel for any
person who
is
mildly familiar with urbanism
uh
prague
let me see uh there was this place next
to where i lived well
yeah pretty close
the
where ah yes
so
consider this
street view image so this is where we
are
it's like a comedy block area mid-rise
is
low traffic etc
consider what you see here
for a moment
let me street you my way into it
do you know what this is
and what that is
it's a [ __ ] underpass
on this street where cars go by
like 30 kilometers per hour
they put in an underpass here and some
railings too to make sure that you take
the [ __ ] underpass
[ __ ] crosswalks there's one
and this other thing here like
there's this arterial road which comes
through here which is like it's ass but
like you know whatever
uh
and they actually
there's there's a crosswalk here
and if you don't want to go through here
then
actually
you have to
oops
uh one sec
there you go
oh shut up
there we go
uh
where was i
sorry here we go
so if you actually want to cross the
road from here to there then you can
either do it there or if you want to do
it here
what you have to do is
you have to cross here this is fenced
off so you won't under any circumstances
go here you cross here you go through
here you get in the underpass and you
emerge on the other side and that's how
you cross from here to there and as you
can see there's already like a beaten
path here because like people were like
yeah [ __ ] it uh and here in the street
view image like uh
a bit later
like uh you can see the dude crossing
there because like uh i mean and this is
really really the result of just like uh
car centric planning because like no
like the
someone was even so
kind as to put in a bunch of like
concrete slabs because it gets muddy uh
during rains so like this this is the
really the result of like of like car
centric planning like peop politicians
who
don't [ __ ] like walk anywhere they
like from their cars like from their
cars this all looks okay like but you
know that's not how most people do it
anyway just wanted to share it share
this with you guys
uh supers
just got here and don't know what a
charity you're streaming for but i trust
you
uh yeah it's in the in the description
actually um
the charities i'm gonna be supporting
are hungarian non-governmental
organizations uh that help disadvantaged
children most mostly roma children uh
with their uh like basically uh
day activities for children
and uh for younger children and uh
um like supporting
uh roma young adults in their higher
education uh basically
right so but back to the
oh there's one super chat actually uh
jinyoung and no public transport only
hyperloop praise mosque oh yeah ban that
person
well i i assume you're just rolling
though so it's fine
uh yeah so we have our tram set up here
and i cannot actually add
outside connections to my tram
so that's concerning
but
and i will manage
uh we need to put down a trim depot as
well because say skylines
uh right which is gonna be for now it's
gonna be here because because you know
whatever uh
normally it would be up in the city
which is once again the city is
somewhere here we're not on the map
uh okay
so
we have our
network
if we
unpause oh yeah like this has to be at
least like five frames per second
now we can send other trams
actually
and uh oh there's nothing here but
from here so we're
stopping at schools which actually
should just talk more frequently we're
stopping at schools
uh we're stopping in this like very
dense area
and uh well nothing much here yet but
i'm gonna add stops later on so
basically the tram stops at like points
of interest
and points where there are people who
have access to it
on foot or otherwise
and here this is where the
uh this is where the the uh
important stuff comes in uh of course
there's an ikea here but yeah let's
let's stop here too so people can get
there
and uh
in front of the store
this store
stadium
stadium
uh
the other end so that people can just
you know okay for now we're just gonna
have this this circular line here
and
is everything okay it's there
and as i'm going to densify this central
area
uh we're going to have of course more
tram stops along the way
uh and ideally like this this tram goes
also to the city all the way
uh
all right
there we go
there we go actually i'm gonna make a
hook here i don't know how city skylines
oh
okay there we go
okay for now i'm just gonna make a hook
here which is just like a
temporary solution
just to simulate the trams going
from here and here to there
okay
okay uh later on like there are there
has to be mods which adds like outside
connections i don't think the exits are
trends though anyway
uh so
uh chris b ten dollars i've been arguing
with my tesla and ev obsessed friends
that ev don't really solve the problem
car problem i love the content yeah
thank you oh yeah well they they kind of
don't you know like the problem with
them is the inefficiency of like one
engine per person or like per 1.3
percent
or something like that and
also that they're so space inefficient
and that cars like cars or modes of
transit which just [ __ ] wreck the
roads they wreck the asphalt they drive
on uh
like
um and it's it's actually actually very
highly uh uneconomical you know
so it's not nice
um okay
phase two of the tram cinematic universe
uh we're going to have
okay not yet actually so for now let's
focus on
uh
generating some more revenue for this
neighborhood so right now the
central this central area is supposed to
be much less noisy
although most of the noise is
what is this oh it's uh
oh it's um
yeah it's my eastern european model
uh dump trucks
so okay that's that's
cities skylines silliness
now feel free to ignore that
and
uh
okay there's still
quite a lot of cars however no you know
what no we're gonna go full community
over here
uh
no
what wait no uh where's the [ __ ]
wait what there used to be this option
ah this
oh yeah okay good
welcome to this
soviet union
let's see oh there we go there we go
that's uh
the t6b5 tatra
tram
hmm
uh janine rashik once again thank you
for 50 crowns what do you think about
the restoration of slovan's castrella
how do you did you hear about it quite
an amazing train from 1930s oh yes uh
slovens
it's a pretty nice train
jesus christ is full of frame rate
and
my gpu fans are barely spinning
also my cpu so this this has to be with
this just to be the game seriously
this this logan's cast trailer is a
nice [ __ ] train
um
and one second pause this
um
it was restored recently
this is uh
this train is just just an absolute unit
um
rip
rip
[ __ ] google
uh just a sec guys and girls
there we go
so this is the slovens castrella
is just uh just the absolute unit
beautiful uh
sloan's castrella means
the slovakian arrow
and it's just uh
is that is a
this is one train uh
for the 1930s no less
[Music]
yeah so um it's pretty cool
i like it
w price 20 pounds thank you very much
and also 2d trash five dollars this is
reminding me of learning to drive in
massachusetts and the six plus way
x intersection in springfield and
boston's brilliant city planning yeah
well
we're fixing it
uh we're we're fixing america right here
we're all about that
so
uh okay so since like this this area is
now calmed uh in terms of traffic
that means we can add some more density
uh
we're not here because this [ __ ]
thing um right so we're going to
make it more dense and also this thing
is also supposed to be pretty loud okay
whatever
um yeah
so
thing is
once you
like a i would say
decongestion measures
have uh must be like the conjunction
measures must accompany
densification of course because if you
densify an area and it's like all like
loud and
shitty and whatever then it's it's it's
uh you know like that why like no one
will want to live there it'll become
kind of like a a place to just like dump
poor people into
so instead of that
i recommend uh
sort of traffic calming measures which
which will actually improve
people's
quality of life you live in that area
um right
let's um this
and uh
this right here azizy man 20 grams thank
you very much uh do you agree there
should be a triune 2.0 what like like
taking away hungary's former like
present territories
ah
like
i feel like people would like people
would whine about it just as much so
like whatever
it's like right now in hungary there's
this big [ __ ] oh my god we will
injustice and it's like well okay dude
but but you you you do realize that
hungary was a
and still is
a so-called uh majoritarian
uh country meaning that the majority
like this is actually a more like it's
like a central european tradition
majority majoritarianism is basically
when when people
like when the country is running away
that the the the majority the the
anointed majority
has all the privileges and everyone else
can basically suck a dick
it's it's actually it's the same energy
with with how roma are tweeted by the
way
but back in the day it was like you know
if you were like
if you were uh uh i don't know jewish
then you were really like disadvantaged
if you were not hungarian speaking you
were basically like you know you you
couldn't really
uh
uh hold
higher public office
uh
everything was like gerrymandered to
hell by the way notice what we're doing
here we are uh mixed zoning
uh
so like everything back then was like
gerrymandered to hell uh in favor of
like the hungarian majority
uh that's why by the way when trianon
happened when trianon when most
territories were like what two thirds of
hungary's
territory was like which is like uh eat
like eat it
i'm just like uh taking out taken away
from hungary
uh with which
like
of course it could it could cause lots
of like this social and economic
destruction
but i mean this isn't for this was
unfortunately
uh
something which like this this was
hungary's chicken that came home because
it came home to roost like you you don't
you don't
[ __ ] treat minorities like [ __ ] for
for for that um
for that long over time and not have any
repercussions and so and you know who
would have thought you know when
when the time when the time came you
know when the when the uh
when it was time to you know
show hands people were like yeah okay
well [ __ ] this well we're out
and so you know that's when slovakia
gained in independence you know romania
became much larger austria got back i
got the the uh
the uh some of like smaller eastern
parts and we were thought we were taught
in school about this
like
uh
like hungary was this like just victim
we did nothing wrong yet even the
austrians who who caused this entire
thing it was their fault even they got
out territory how like this is not like
we were really we really thought it's
cool um
that like the the whole world just
[ __ ] hates us
and we're just like this lone bastion of
hungarianness i guess
and uh
and then and then that was the end of it
basically so yeah it was just spirit um
which it wasn't true so you know
okay um let's continue uh we assume that
we can only lay down like really one
light rail line so like no nothing
serious we're not doing
we're not doing uh
no we're not doing uh uh anymore because
uh
uh like lighter lines that is because
like usually cities cannot do that so
we're gonna do buses though um
arizona can you do a collab with city
beautiful and not just bikes compete
with each other in city skylines oh you
know if if any of them asks ask me to do
so i'll be i'll be happy oblige
uh actually i i am going to
amsterdam soon
i might be able to you know meet up with
my just by today we'll see
well we're gonna do some epic lay epic
for tony bacon
collab
which will just which will just mostly
be like me i don't know
yeah he's just he's just like recording
like peacefully recording things not
suspecting anything i just like walk up
and like slap the camera out of his man
nah
of course not so um
i'm just i'm just being sorry so um
right
we are
further what we're doing here is we're
further like so taking away lanes
uh from private transit because once
again induced demand works both ways
if you
add lanes you're going to have more
traffic and if you
subtract lanes
you're going to have
less
i know it's it's unbelievable um
but still many of our decision makers
don't really get it so the problem is
this [ __ ] thing right here so
uh instead of uh i mean we can we can
have it assume that we cannot move
everything from here but the smaller
stuff we're going to move
so football field
and
say this
track field
and most of these parking spots also
have to go
uh right so what was it like a track
track and run and football okay
we're going to we're going to handle
that in a second
i'm just gonna let's delete this
because this is
absolutely
unnecessary at this point before it was
necessary and anyone who would have
deleted them
that would have committed political
suicide now this is no longer the case
so
yeah we're gonna for good measure we're
just gonna leave this much and so the
football field
uh let's see
there's the good thing about these these
kinds of suburb setups
uh
is that we
have
lots of space
to do
anything so here's our here's our track
field
uh
yes so we're going to just uh the the
best the best thing is if we just like
put things next to the road like as
close to
calmer decongested roads as we as we
possibly can
because um
because
actually uh the tram has to be close
ideally speaking
so essentially we're moving these sports
[ __ ] cities
um we're actually moving the the the the
uh
moving stuff near the uh the houses
uh near uh
near these areas which is actually
actually pretty important the football
field was the other thing but where is
the football field i like it how i i
download the mod
ah there we go
it's like well where is it
i don't know it's left up to the
creativity of uh anyone of the person
who made it
okay uh let's see
uh okay we might need to be smart about
this a bit
okay
like this all right um
okay and this will be accessible by
pedestrians because the parking spot is
already there
all right
turn off the
turn off the
snapping there we go
so this is a big deal actually uh
because
sports fields
uh this this actually is a very helpful
tool in in integration because if you
have a sports field
actually ideally we should like just
delete this entire thing and just spread
it across here actually i might actually
do that
this is a very big deal
if sports facilities
are arranged like this
because
essentially
if you have a sports ground like this
okay who's going to be able to access
that well
children will use it obviously and those
children need to get there somehow now
if their parents are working you know
three jobs to just stay afloat
and also
uh
and also like they may or may not own a
car or like afford all that you know
going back and forth or fuel costs etc
that means the children who are the
poorest they will just miss out for miss
out
out of all this
and so
if you put um
if you put sports
sports fields and stuff like this like
in the european suburb
that means like
everyone here has access to it you can
just walk down to it or bike down to it
and it's there for you now if you have
this
nice
black spots whatever um if you have this
this like this thing right here you
cannot get there if you don't have a car
or and or if your parents cannot
uh
cannot make time for you to go there
right so this
this actually also disadvantages
um
poor youth
so that's that's why it's very important
that's why i would i would actually call
it a leftist measure to put
sports facilities within
a reachable uh
distance
of of of people like either next to
public transit or be it or have it be
reachable by bike or public transit
here we're even going to put down some
black lines here
there we go
no
not not the water
there we go
right and these suburban streets i mean
usually suburban streets here we're also
like uh reducing lanes of course
and uh
yeah so these suburban streets ideally
aren't like like like regular streets
like high traffic so you can use them
for bike biking
uh yeah but of course in serious
skylines uh
the
sims will not use
uh
the the the road surface for biking
because [ __ ] uh maxibond thank you
for turning your uh
donation hello from italy i've been a
fan since 50k
been a train friend ever since good oh
dude uh uh
uh italian trains are pretty good
actually
i really like them
uh let's get some density going here in
the meanwhile so once again the idea
here is that uh
from one of the st so we take one of the
strodes we need snapping for this we
take one of the strodes
uh
in in a suburb
and we convert it to
essentially a mass transit artery
through uh
through um
either a light rail or it can also be
like a frequent bus service with some
bus lanes which is which i which is what
i did here actually i'm going to do it
right now um and so then you can you get
this this like this this is this is
already a
frequented sort of central place where
it's emulating when it's a very
elongated one this is an along this
trend line here is the elongated version
of of of this hair right
and
and this basically so like the the
center
uh
so
businesses and uh
businesses uh and and and uh you know
real estate developers etc they can
already like start
start building up around this area and
since they do i'm gonna i'm gonna put
this thing here since they do
this these frame rates them and i like
them
the computer isn't even hot like
okay this has to be like a coding thing
um so the thing is
uh
the thing is
this this is uh actually beneficial to
everyone because
you know developers gets
like this this causes of course
appreciation and people will get better
options in terms of mobility now
actually we can we can we can go a bit
crazy
and uh
and
okay so there's a school there's some
sports fields this is good
we can do something like this
this is of course a stadium
so what we can do is we
can
uh
place a bus terminal
here
and then a second bus terminal later on
we're going to connect it with a walking
path so people don't have to like go
around here
uh so we're gonna
second
hub
which is going to be somewhere here
uh hopefully in like an emptier area
oh
what are this i love these frame rates
dude okay uh
here
so
what we have here is
any coming blocks coming using style oh
hell yeah
actually you know what just for fun
let's let's um
let's take this area here and uh
let's see what do we have here oh yes we
have plenty
no not this one
i'll get some super nice coming blocks
open up in here
uh we're going to do some kind of some
some plan some centrally planned
uh
urban planning here
here we go
there's one
and
there's one
there's one there we go some coming
blocks
and uh
some streets up in here
oh rip alignment
there we go
and
okay so
there we go
yuck
cars
um
okay
and we're going to
[ __ ] snapping
we're going to put up some
walk paths around here so people have a
convenient access
to all the amenities that's the perfect
soviet city has to offer yeah i'm just
kidding
life in the soviet union was generally
[ __ ]
um
okidoke
okay and we can actually and we can
actually densify this area as well
um these are of course mid-rises series
commons for some reason wants to always
build these like like
15 20-story buildings
and there's in these areas which is
completely unnecessary
which is i don't know
uh the developers once again have built
like i think like a like an america
syndrome
so oh well
all right
but this area there i detect a distinct
lag of commercial
let's see
and we can actually put up some
commercial
well here i guess
all right
there we go
let's delete this okay um right and so
we can do the same thing in this area as
well actually
right
right so as you can see so what's going
on here once again like we we are
um
essentially densifying the area around
uh this central artery which we created
with the light rail now
usually obviously these projects would
go hand in hand
like there's a there's like a light rail
project and then and then the uh
and then you know mixed zoning and and
then next to like next to it there's
like a less like a densification
uh
initiative
uh as well
yes
okay
so
and the reason why it's important of
course is because like due to
do these things together
is because um
is because obviously
uh
like if you don't then that that might
cause some grumbling within larger
society like okay so we we have this
nice shiny new light rail but no one
uses it because this area is intensified
and uh
et cetera et cetera so you know you get
what i'm saying uh right there we go
rip 90 degree angles
okay and
oh yeah i mean it's starting to look
like something nice oh we need a
cemetery huh
there we go
or not oh maybe yes
there we go well not maybe not next to
the school that might be a bit morbid
uh
there we go
okay so
yeah no sorry no no hyperloop [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
and um
there we go some commercial beforehand i
i like to put down the commercial first
and just like paint the entire thing
with uh
um
with a residential
and so so next to the road we're doing
sort of higher density residential
so that's that's uh
that's um
the idea
all right
okay
all right so as you can see
uh yeah so uh with suburbs in this at
this point it really is about like
plugging holes
uh in the fabric of
the town
and
oh this is this is some oh god city
skylines why you do this to me
uh
and once you do that
you can actually
become a chad
this is part of the sigma male guarantee
okay
so uh
out
out and from here we're gonna give you
low density okay um right
um so
let's give it some time then
so we're we're already we already have
some thing away something like a city
center here so ideally
this might this place might need some a
bit more parks or something um
and um
and as we can see um
this is like so the idea here is like if
you remember like something like this
like
okay like it's just it's just a [ __ ]
like it's just a bunch of [ __ ] houses
like whatever
uh
what do you do
um nothing
why why would you come here for no
[ __ ] reason however here
since we densified
since we got rid of the parking lots set
up
in parallel to that we set up some some
uh
some public transit
actually significant public transit
and uh and let's see how many sims does
this thing take
quite a few actually
so
since we have this
um
since we have this area here uh there
this is already like people have a uh
people have a reason to come here
people you have a reason to come to this
place there's things going on here
there's events there's venues there's
restaurants there's bars
and
you can also you can get
from here
to the city which is somewhere there and
there's a bunch of fires
um
oh yeah the forest fires again anyway
[ __ ] you seriously
again i i really like this game but i've
been swearing more at citizens on this
stream than i have ever in my life as
anything else i think
okay that's not true uh right uh don't
know
especially uh thank you very much three
thousand hungarian pesos
especially interested in your upcoming
tsugaming video means a lot i barely
escaped an elementary school segregation
situation myself in the 80s in hungary
where roma kids were left behind on
purpose
yeah
this actually happens so
so uh yeah right right right yes uh so
and and i i would like to make a video
about the roma situation in hungary um
so that's that's uh i don't know when
uh when i will have the time actually
i'll i'll actually absolutely
that's that's like that's the subject
which is which is uh
yeah
some water tower have fun some like
that's actually an issue which which is
which i about which i care about oh
hence this stream of course
um right
so
let's
not stop with the densification
and mix the zoning so
some parking lots will need to be left
up but this is this is uh inevitable
uh so but the idea is that it it won't
look like uh like like america does
right now
um
right so we uh from this point on
the
task is to
create a workable public transit here
which is difficult actually but
um
we can do it by
creating
little sub centers
and how will that work
uh so for example um
i believe that the best way to do this
is to just like
have an area
which you designate
let's put up some buses like this this
is for example you know
like this this bus service of course
would be very infrequent and and uh
not so practical
but that's
what you have to work with currently
um
wait no
uh right we can make it this is a like a
circle to like uh our the idea is to
cover
as much ground as possible
even if like the city is just like bad
um
badly planned
and you can then
but like uh
you do see the problem here though like
i'm trying to cover as much ground as
possible but i don't only do it in like
very awkward way
so uh
the thing is
that um
okay here here is we got the sports
grounds
um if we cannot remove it because okay
because we know what if we can't what
happens
what we do is we
uh basically
uh connect it so we're trying to connect
it at least to the rest of the city
and
that way at least for some people we
provide an alternative
of course the point is to get people out
of their cars
and to
make them use public transit
or to have have an alternative plus the
social aspect of
uh just like
providing an opportunity for everyone to
to get to these places now
now this is of course i mean this this
is of course bad well what we have here
this is far away this is nothing there
etc
so
uh what we can actually do
is uh
let's see do you have any supers that i
missed i'm just thinking okay good
nope all right so
basically uh
um
wait we're not done with the buses yet
so wait we have a connection with the
tram here
right so we got a bus
line here ideally like from here
so here and here in these two bus
stations there will be a rapid bus
connection from the city as well
if it makes sense obviously
um
all right so
let's see
we're gonna just i'm just i'm just gonna
sketch this up real quick
and uh the bus service
uh this this would be more like a
circular like this the point is that it
like collects people
um
and gives them the opportunity to to go
to that business
center uh by buy something
other than any car but you do see the
problem here like next to this road
next to this stroll there's basically
nothing
uh because no one likes to live next to
strodes and
and uh you know that's why it's empty
but we're gonna change that
so
we're gonna go here
so far it goes nowhere that bus but
we're gonna this is gonna change in a
moment
right and we're going to go to the
bus station there
why
because we can because we're chad up in
here
all of you here are mass transit chads
and don't let those cocked car centric
conservatives tell you otherwise
but since you are chad's
then of course like even if they do tell
you otherwise just laugh at them and and
grab them by their throat
and tell them to return to the basement
where they belong
or to the garage in this case so um
yeah i'm being funny right now if you
couldn't tell anyway
um so
there we go uh we connected it
and uh so we have oh actually these
things should connect here
there we go
there we go
it's best if it's best if you can link
up
actually then we can get rid of this
it's best if you can link up as many uh
as many transit uh
lines as possible
uh in key points
uh intermodality is is actually very
important oh super from rachel uh five
dollars thank you very much good morning
everyone it is currently 7 40 a.m and
i'm about to continue designing my first
transmission line have you all been
drinking water
well uh
make sure to let let them know that you
have
and uh yeah well i've been drinking beer
mostly right so here we have a uh a
suburb
uh like a regular suburb still bus line
uh the same thing can be done here
actually
uh that we did over there so real
quickly if i'm going to zone it out
and um
oh wait there we we missed that we
missed a section here oh
so once again
okay uh so the the same thing can be
done here as as on the other road like
the point is
uh
have some sort of uh
semblances
of central places
in these suburbs through densification
uh
that's i mean that would be the general
idea right
of course everything i'm saying here is
is hypothetical every suburb has its own
little unique situation but generally
the direction you want to move towards
is
um is that of uh
there we go
of uh
creating like emulating the center so i
mean i mean in european settlements damn
dude this forest fire location
uh
in europe like city center like central
locations they don't really have to be
dense
like
uh i mean they aren't really dense
uh
it's it's accessible though by by most
people but here
uh since this is just america you know
those teeny tiny little
um
gay ass
small european houses are no good
everything is
plus sized
okay so first of course uh once again
mixed development so that you know it's
not just a a a a uh
residential desert and people have a
reason to go here
uh some
nope i don't know this is too much
nope
and this is also not good and once again
we are still uh if you haven't been
tuning in uh before that we are also
uh
ending cool dissects uh eliminating dead
ends because they do nothing but
basically
you impede your mobility
uh so here we have actually
already a
pretty good looking sort of uh
residential core
uh we can also actually put up some
offices like i almost forgot
anyway like but but like
the idea still is the same like work
places places to go
yeah i think i think you can infer that
from from what i'm trying to do here
like in real life obviously this would
also be
also there would also be offices
actually let's put a few down it's just
like i'm i'm a bit wary of that because
in city skylines it's like
offices are um
i don't know like uh
they're a bit uh they're
funny sometimes
so
oh no not here maybe
okay uh and
so as we continue we have this another
artery here uh
we are going to
build
a
city center a place to go really that's
the whole thing
uh around this
artery
hell yeah
yeah and then we're gonna zoom out in a
moment and see what we have done what
have we done
okay
okay
okay so this place has its own transit
connection you can get a high-speed
railway uh there's people asking in the
chat uh no
high-speed railway here doesn't make
sense this is a satellite and uh well if
if there was a big pre-existing line
then hell yeah but like then it well
actually
i don't think even at that point no no
high-speed wheel doesn't usually stop in
satellites like this and also factories
um not in this play through
we're imagining that we are in the
american i don't know
west and like midwest now
and factories have died because of you
know neoliberalism so
all right
yeah so uh right so
we're seeing kind of our city come along
we're like uh we're chugging along
so from the
this like very disjointed
suburban uh area
we have created in the center by using
the the enormous parking lot
uh spaces
and other things
we have created this uh
essentially smaller town center
of course it's imperfect but i think
this is as reasonably with little tata
trams in it cool
which is i think is is reasonably
um
usable for people
and
it's where people can actually live like
urban lifestyles it's actually this this
might actually be
a financial benefit for the locality
because suburbs are like these parts up
in here they're usually more like
like uh essentially ponzi schemes um i
think i think yeah not just bikes i
think they did a series about this if i
remember correctly about how suburbs are
just this complete ponzi scheme uh
meaning that suburbs like i mean they
are an economic benefit when you build
them but in 20 years you're going to rip
up everything and replace the utilities
and everything
which is going to be a huge expense so
we have to build more suburbs
to cover the
expenses
uh
which will come up in
20 years
and the new suburbs you build will also
have these same expenses so you have to
keep building and building and building
so
you know
right so as you can see we have kind of
fixed our our uh suburb in this area of
course uh this whole area would need
like
a sort of thicker grid structure
um
more
like sort of even less cul-de-sacs use
all the space you have uh mixed zoning
and uh a grid like bus network so you
know like buses going like going through
like uh horizontally vertically
converging in central locations
and uh this way and of course a rapid
transit link
to the city which is which we imagine is
here
uh and actually we can take this away
because our city is now much more
walkable
uh it's not uh it's not of course uh uh
it's not uh uh ideal
but
it's already much better like like so so
this this is uh this is the point is
that this is no longer a suburb suburb
right so if you live here there's you
know there's light rail there's you know
there's public transit there's
all that stuff you uh
would want and everything is easily
reachable easier it's reachable easier
so this is a place where you could
imagine your life
even if you aren't a a
upper middle class boomer you know
right so i think we pretty much
demonstrated how we can fix the
uh how can kind of
fix this up or where you have some comic
blocks here how nice is that
uh yeah
some total trams because america has now
fallen on the fallen under communism
because aoc took over
and because of of course this would
happen
yeah uh no mega church that's true uh
sorry this is a this is the the the good
timeline where uh megachurches didn't
come to me
anyway yeah sure so thank you very much
for tuning in i think uh
it's been eight hours i don't know how
people can do streams all day long maybe
i'm just a beginner uh
but i really enjoy uh
i really enjoyed it
uh i'll i'll be back
in a moment i need to go visit the
room for rest
back in two minutes and i'm gonna be
doing a proper outro and once again for
those of you tuned in now this will be
up on the channel so don't worry you can
rewatch the whole thing and uh
why and this is of course a q a and
fundraiser and we are raising or i am
raising funds for hungarian ngos
hungarian ngos i forget how to talk uh
but towards the end
that help disadvantaged children uh and
young adults mostly roma to get higher
education to get day uh daycare programs
etc so this is what we're collecting for
and we have we have actually collected
uh 30 000 check crowns youtube displays
the amount for me in
czech rounds unfortunately that's a
thousand seven hundred thousand seven
hundred twenty six dollars
which is very good uh even ten dollars
can already finance like one uh one
course for uh like one
uh like 45 to 60 minute course for one
child so that's very nice
this is a this is very very helpful
already and i also going to anna i'm
also going to be kicking in
uh
an amount similar to this so where we
have raised quite a few money
and i'm very happy about that and uh
yeah
we
uh all i had to do for it is play city
skylines for eight hours so hey it's a
win-win situation
especially as actually it's a
win-win-win because i get to play city
skylines you get to watch me play city
skylines and children and you're going
to need to get some funding so i'll be
right back hold your thoughts and
questions whatever you have and if you
want to do some uh last-minute donations
like bear they just know thank you very
much uh then uh please do so so be right
back and i will try to get one of the
cats to to uh watch you over while i'm
gone one second
all righty i'm back
so let me read these uh
donors real quick
let's see
uh yes
so all right uh bear this was a good
stream thank you you're welcome thank
you for tuning in
uh also wp uh price 10 bucks thank you
very much i'll donate for your
engineered gaming well thank you
um
right and also
we have
adam catboy oh yeah hell yeah
uh tanya uh thorn green 10 euros thank
you very much
and uh tony nemonic ukrainians lost all
christmas spirit thanks to the russian
troops escalation announcement is the
global war inevitable how do you think
this uh story will uh with the uh russo
ukrainian war will end glory to ukraine
yes um i think i agree i think uh like
the war the threat of war right now it's
okay i want to say that it's not
realistic because russia would lose a
lot with that but through sanctions and
through like actually like losing
military however
it's really really hard to to know
what's going on inside putin's head
which is an increasingly
uh
an increasingly unstable place you know
and russia is a kind of russia is a kind
of
place where
um
sort of putin has an outsized amount of
control over the over the government
um
and it's kind of like a
sardom
chieftain you know so uh anyway
we'll see what comes out of it hopefully
nothing serious
uh if so then oof
we need to we need to uh
we need to uh
rethink a lot
so anyway thank you for the donations
uh let's so to sum up what did we do
here uh
uh i we turned a an american-style
suburb the remnants of which you can see
here into a somewhat working settlement
uh here you can see what it what a
suburb used to be like very very thinly
populated area
um
also like strodes in the middle so what
we did was we turned the strobe into
essentially light rail
with some
tatra trams going there apparently
uh and um
because yeah and um
we actually started densifying around
this light rail line which goes all the
way to the city which is somewhere there
uh so people have actually some public
transit access to the city
also
we made the we ended cul-de-sacs by uh
by
walk paths or by just simply connecting
streets that's very important
once we did that the neighborhood became
much more passable
you didn't uh you didn't have to waste
so much time you know driving around
walking around etc in huge circles
because there's just no road where
it needed to be one but there need to be
one yes um
also uh we made these uh next to the
highways we had these big compounds
lots of parking lots we cut back on
those and we actually have the uh light
rail slash tram uh do a circle here so
people can actually get there without
you having to use their cars also bus
lines connecting everything else because
of course fundings uh public transit
fundings are not infinite anyway so
this is what we did uh we actually ended
up from this like disjointed
network of streets like like uh here
to an actual thing that looks like a
city
and as a contrast of course we have the
european uh style settlement on the
other side which i also put up here
which has a definite center of course
but usually with a church and a square
plus minor cemetery sports facilities
are inside and are accessible as you can
see there are no traffic jams here
really because no one really has to use
their car
uh there's a train connection except the
air city skylines is kind of weird about
like spawning people from trains
whatever
so here we have of course a train
connection
and
otherwise otherwise if we really wanted
to like uh go nuts that could be like a
little smaller circular
uh
bus service here which takes which takes
people from like points of interest to
different points of interest but you
usually in european settlements this is
usually done through
uh like regional buses so the regional
bus
goes through the settlement
and and um
and uh then it stops along the way and
it also acts like local public transit
while it's there so yes so anyway um
thank you for tuning in we have
collected quite the quite the amount of
money
uh um
for uh the disadvantaged children over
here we have the forest burning again
because
this is my favorite [ __ ] dlc
anyway
um
so thanks a lot in the end let's make a
total we have collected
uh 39 000 check crowns youtube displays
the currency for me in check
uh
1770.56
very nice and i'm also going to be
kicking in
a similar amount so once again thank you
very much for tuning in
and i'm gonna go
to
have my
vocal cords recover because i've been
talking for eight hours and
yes so thank you for tuning in and this
was fun so hey i might do another stream
uh
later on
and uh
because this was fun really and also my
second channel it's linked on my first
channel the top right corner adam
something else
uh that's that is where uh
maybe clips of this stream will go but
otherwise videos which don't fit the
whole uh
theme of the main channel plus if the
first channel gets nuked then
there's the second one to to go to so
yeah that's why i couldn't change the
plan and uh carla toomey thank you for
the two or three and arrows thank you
for the stream adam well thank you for
tuning in
and i'll be seeing you next time